[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody here we are it's wednesday
night yep cheryl's favorite subject
she says he's here just for this show
and i gotta turn this on hold on i can't
believe we didn't even think of doing
this yeah until recently and actually we
didn't think of doing it somebody else
suggested it and i was like duh i can't
and it's all you know it's like
some of my favorite things yeah it's
true crime and it's also punk rock which
like i said one of my favorite things
yeah we got we got the [ __ ]
temple of [ __ ] set going on here with
looking for the [ __ ]
eye of horus or whatever it is what was
it what was that [ __ ] [ __ ] what in
the god damn hell the temple of tennis
is [ __ ] beaming lights through oh
right you know indiana jones and his
[ __ ] staff for a second i'm just
sitting there going uh
what are you talking about that [ __ ]
right there oh well because i think i
said that before because it was actually
just like a beam of light that's more
like a
huge square of light yeah so you know
uh i kind of feel like the camera moved
because
well i was moving stuff around in the
background i got like a little couch and
[ __ ] like that back there now so i kind
of had to
i didn't i don't usually like that much
of the window in the thing dj's having
[ __ ] truffle mac truffle mac and
cheese sounds pretty good actually the
fresh truffles are gonna be must be
truffle oil in it
cheryl says i'm making maple mustard
chicken that also sounds good yeah
man yeah that does sound good
yeah we need to find a recipe for that
oh people
i bought that [ __ ] air fryer
yeah this is the food portion of the
show
that thing worked out good
cooked whole chickens in it did roast
beef in it big old roast beef oh yeah
make sandwich meat i know you could have
actually when it was still hot fresh out
of there
had uh roast beef and gravy mashed
potatoes it was good yeah that was good
we had that for uh yeah last night and
then today for lunch we had like just
sandwiches but i'm i'm impressed with
what it does with pizza for you guys
people that don't want to invest in a
pizza stone and a peel to get it off and
on the stone
and you don't have a oven that can get
up to 550.
you can do it in that airfryer
uh what i have is big enough it's got a
little pizza
levels on there and a pizza setting
but don't cook it on the piece of metal
that they tell you to cook it on
cook it in the damn wire basket for the
french fries
it's just a damn wire screen it makes a
square pizza
about that big
cooking times 13 minutes comes out great
yeah honestly i didn't i can't really
tell that much of a difference between
that and like cooking on the stone like
you were doing before and it's nice not
having to like preheat the oven no
preheat because you usually put the oven
on a pre for like an hour an hour hand
so it gets like hot enough for like a
stone cooking times an hour and 15
minutes an hour of it is heat up is
preheating this stove
now once the stone's hot you can make a
lot of pizzas so if you have a bunch of
guests over you can make seven pizzas
quick
yeah because that's what we usually do
we have like a lot of people but if you
just want a quick pizza you only have 20
minutes prep time you already got dough
made and aged and ready to go you can
just throw some dough down on a table on
some flour roll it out into a square
drop it into the basket form it top it
put it in
12 13 minutes on i got the mechanical
timer it ticks and [ __ ] about 12-13
minutes and it comes out it's beautiful
beautiful
it take them out really good yeah you
made me like a white pizza yesterday it
had like uh mushrooms and peppers and
yeah it had artichoke hearts on it yeah
it had some
bacon bits and some of those uh
some of that uh what do you call it
freeze-dried dried
um
sausage sauce had some little tomatoes
on it and tomatoes on it yeah which yeah
i like that now the next thing to do is
get with them [ __ ] insta pot or is it
quick pot what's it called well instant
pot is the is the brand name yeah you
can buy other ones that are like the
instant pot that are different yeah i'm
gonna get that six quarts one
and like i said they're really good they
seem to be really good for making like
soups and stews and beans and
stuff like that i told you i'm obsessed
with those [ __ ] videos of those
people that made that do those uh
grocery challenges like i ate for ten
dollars
for a week
and uh you know they make a lot of beans
and soups and they make stock in there
and they just like they all make rice in
there everything yeah so most of them
seem to be six quarts
it seems to be the size to get
i think there's a an eight or a ten
quart out there but it's considerably
more expensive unless you guys recommend
that bigger one i'll get that but it
seems to be that the sixth court is
really all you need yeah tammy said she
loved hers six court uh well i don't
know if it was six score but she said
she loved hers um sheila anne says dj
you're killing me how are we gonna talk
about two smack heads on an empty
stomach
we kind of have empty stomachs too i
mean we ate
we had it we had a roast beef sandwich
at what like 11 30. yeah and because i
don't ever ever eat breakfast other than
a cup of coffee i was drinking protein
protein shake i will say i didn't know
that yeah yeah you should drink that
with me i don't know because eating is
beautiful
it's not though i make mine with the
[ __ ] juice i'm not i'm not into like
protein shakes i always kind of figure
like a smoothie if i'm going to have
calories i want like some nice calories
that i'm going to enjoy i don't just
mine's enjoyable well yeah but not for
me it's not though i don't know i don't
want calories there's only 200 calories
i don't want a milkshake i want i want
actual food maybe 200 calories yeah
it's like well the food content is like
eating two chicken breasts and i know
but it doesn't it's filled up it's not
good like two chicken breasts that's
what that's what i'm trying to tell you
i'm saying i'm saying that i don't just
want because to me that seems like you
know back in the old days because my mom
was like always on diets and stuff when
i was growing up and she would always do
like oh well she'd always do like that
slim fast [ __ ] like oh that's not the
same no but i no i'm just saying that
it's like a meal replacement i'm like no
i'd just rather have a meal honestly i'd
rather just eat like a salad yeah those
weren't meal replacements though they
were too high in carbohydrates it was
just glorified but that's well yeah but
that's how they sold how they sold it
and honestly you probably would lose
weight if you ate that instead of like
two meals yeah but that's not what
that's not where protein
drinks are for you eat those chicken
breasts
and that salad and that and those
protein shakes it's not about losing
weight it's about getting muscle
cheryl says trying to get it's low
calorie very high protein right but it's
i mean that's like not what i'm trying
to i'm just trying i'm trying to eat
something
food that i enjoy
that's all i mean yeah if i had to i
would i would drink them but i would
rather not i would rather if you're
gonna have a salad drink protein shake
with it see
and then you get your protein because
it's not an additional calories not that
much or just have a chicken breast and
put that and then there's the cost and
the time for cooking it and and
or you can just get canned chicken
okay cheryl says i don't like drinking
calories unless it's alcoholic yeah
that's kind of where i'm at with it but
the calories there's only a couple
hundred calories it's like less than a
can of soda it's a lot less than canna
soda i don't like soda
either you can't reason with women you
just can't reason with women no
it's simple mathematics no the problem
is
but the problem is that you're coming at
things from a completely different uh
point of view
it's not so much not reason it's just
like look if i'm going to have calories
i want actual food i don't want like a
shake you know what i'm saying i want to
eat some actual food well you want to
eat the food i would rather eat like
just the actual food and not you know
what i mean it's a supplement though
you're eating the food i get that
i get that i just don't like them okay i
just don't like them all right
you know i don't think there's anything
particularly unreasonable about that
they're they're good
well to you they're good they're very
good taste is subjective they're very
good that seems to be the thing that
you're not yeah
i was making them if you had the ones i
was making i have had them it's not my
thing it's good you know it's not that
they're terrible it's just that i don't
i'm not a big milkshake person i will
fight in the defense of my [ __ ]
protein shakes they're good but well
yeah but you like them yeah i nobody
said that like i said taste is
subjective i don't understand why that's
something that you've seen it's okay
incapable of understanding it's okay
pookie poor little pookie i know when
you give up i know when to give up
pookie no you don't
poor little pooky has had a rough day
you guys
oh my god my [ __ ] morning
poor little pooky
i was in here i got up early like i
usually do so i think i got up at like
[ __ ] quarter to seven or some [ __ ]
and i came in here and i started working
and
i don't even remember what time it was
it was pretty early but all of a sudden
i hear
yeah and i was just like oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is that now at first i thought
pookie was like throwing up or i thought
that beijing had come up here and throws
up because she kind of throws up all the
time um but usually she doesn't come up
here usually she stays downstairs so i'm
just like what the [ __ ] and i'm like
running around and i couldn't find
pookie and i was just like what the [ __ ]
is that pookie had got into
my cloth my walk-in closet there in the
dressing room
and i guess she had been trying to like
climb over there was like a box or
something in there and she climbed over
it and she fell
and she fell into i had a bra that was
like hanging on a hanger
and her neck had got caught in the bra
and she was like laying there like
strangling she was hanging herself i
didn't see it and i was just like
freaking out i mean i think it just
happened
because i heard her
and i was like freaking out and she was
like
and i was just like oh jesus i'm like i
pulled her out of it and she seemed to
be okay like i felt that she didn't like
yell or anything like that and i was
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] what if that
happened like in the middle of the night
and i didn't hear her
oh my god i was like so [ __ ] stressed
out i'm still like stressed out
i woke up i heard something wrong what
happened stand your underwear in my
hands
yeah he was on the way to the shower and
i was down here going oh my god oh my
god i was like flipping out
you know and it's been she came running
pokey came running to me all happy like
nothing happened i was like you sure she
didn't seem to be upset
i mean i was upset
yeah she didn't seem to be like anything
had happened maybe she was just coughing
or something and you sure we you sure it
was wrapped around her neck yeah i saw
it well i had to pull it off yeah okay
because she was like that and she
couldn't get off because like the hanger
was like pulling on the closet thing she
was calling for help and she was like
and i was just like oh no but i was like
i was flipping out i was oh my god i was
flipping out you guys know how i get
about boogie but she was i mean i sat
there i think i was more upset than she
was because i sat there going oh my god
more pookie and she was like chill out
mom
i'm all right but you know i was kind of
like feeling around here to make sure
like she wasn't like i didn't want her
to yell or anything like that if she was
in any pain but she doesn't seem to be
yeah i've been watching her all day and
she hasn't coughed anymore and now she's
pigging out like she usually does so i
guess she's okay thank you very much
sheila she listens my arms look great
because i actually cut back on my
on my on on the days that i lift i'm
down to only like maybe like two days
one and a half days a week
give it time to [ __ ] grow that's
probably
i can do three but i think two is the
best a week
give it time to grow
time to grow time to grow i don't know
what i'm doing
yeah camp guy says indian cooking uses a
lot of pressure cooker stuff just like
instant pot so yeah yeah because we make
a lot of it
it was an indian woman that recommended
it to me her husband's a doctor over
there where we used to live
and she said yeah like i said they seem
very very they seem very useful yeah she
goes you need to get that and follow the
recipes on youtube because that's better
than the old-fashioned and like i said
they all like everybody makes rice in
that [ __ ] too it just seems like so it's
not just a grey goat thing you gotta
make like an indian women or that's
they're using that they're using that
pot they're saying it's better than what
do indians call white people not gringo
i'm sure i'm just making it up i know
yeah i know i'm just i'm sure i'm sure
there's a word for it i just don't know
what it is if anybody here is from india
let me know yeah uh cheryl says yeah tom
stop trying to reason with women yeah uh
granthar says this is awesome arguing
about protein shakes it's not so much
arguing about protein shakes it's just
that he's a battle of will
i'm way more stubborn than you
i hate to tell you but um
it's just
i mean i'm just like absolutely no i'm
not doing it but um it's not so much
that like i said you you have this weird
thing where
you like your subjective taste you think
that that it's objective that's not
weird that's just a matter of course
that's just how it is we talk it is
weird it's just the way it is see now
he's arguing about that
he thinks like subjective things are
objective yeah of course
that's tammy's laughing lol only tom's
taste is correct i think he actually
does think that yeah i think that seems
to be like the source of a lot of our
disagreements i'm just kind of like do
you understand that other people have
different like taste and opinions to you
he does not seem to understand that at
all no no that's not correct
you're like this guy i used to work with
this little like uh weaselly dude
no i'm not i'm not saying that he was
weasley you weren't weasley i'm just
saying that that's i was describing him
um
he was like real real into movies and he
was just bound to determine if you did
not like the same movies that he thought
were brilliant then you were just wrong
there was no subjective taste involved
there was no ah it's not really my thing
you know but if you like it that's cool
which is kind of my whole situation but
he was just like no you were wrong and
this is why you were wrong and he would
like have this big so i just stopped
talking to him after a while because you
don't you can't argue with somebody like
that because they're never gonna like
well they're never going to concede that
you have a valid opinion only their
opinion is valid and so they're just
gonna like sit there and like lecture
you about
why you're wrong and i'm just kind of
like i just i don't have any interest in
that so i just like stopped talking to
him
luckily he didn't work in the same
department as me so i just tried to stay
out of that department as much as
possible because you know i don't have
time for that [ __ ] uh and cheryl
also says protein shakes are not my
thing i'm with you jenny yeah i'm just
they're not terrible i'm just like i
said if i'm gonna have 200 calories i'd
rather have 200 calories for something
delicious it depends on what flavor you
buy don't [ __ ] with the chocolate one
because you can't do anything with
chocolate you want vanilla
because you can add in you can add
berries or peanut butter to it or you
know dried peanut you can change the
flavor you know and make something don't
get chocolate people when it comes to
that just my experience because it
you can't really add anything to it
so it's not very versatile
one time i accident one time i accident
i accidentally ordered uh um
what do you call it strawberry just body
fortress
it was good body fortunately fortress
body fortune
strawberry body poor today so yeah your
body is a [ __ ] fortress
it's a wall around you
okay
right around the
enterprise shield and [ __ ] yes
structural integrity and hello
you gotta [ __ ] spock at the [ __ ]
calm you got him at the helm but uh
[ __ ] with the science [ __ ] desk
anyway um the the strawberry was good
because you can mix it with the berry
now um i haven't tried the
banana jenny would absolutely hate that
she hates anything artificial banana she
doesn't she hates banana i mean i don't
i actually don't mind
actual bananas every now and then it's
not my favorite like if i'm gonna reach
for a fruit it'll normally be like an
apple or an orange or a pear or
pineapple or something like that i'm not
a huge fan of bananas um but artificial
banana can go straight to [ __ ] hell i
hate that taste sometimes on amazon i've
come across body fortress five pound
[ __ ] kid because i get into big five
pounders of uh banana and it'd be like
half the price
well because everybody hates bananas as
much as i do art well now there's some
people that like bananas
like artificial banana flavor yeah i'm
not harsh in y'all's thing okay
um you know i don't want to be one of
those people it's like well you're just
wrong but to me artificial banana flavor
is like the grossest i mean it's really
gross if i see that deal again i'm gonna
get it so because i bet you'd be good
with frozen berries in there probably be
good with that uh powdered um
powdered dehydrated uh peanut butter
something like what the [ __ ] you talking
about peanut butter if you go to go to
um walmart
yeah walmart
and you go to where around where the
dried milk is and stuff it's usually in
the near the hispanic foods you're going
to find it
it might be in the peanut butter section
too they i've seen in a couple different
places big old plastic jar powder if you
add water to that it comes peanut butter
it's real lightweight
use that for uh
for you can put it in shakes for
flavoring and it becomes peanut butter
if you don't put that much if you put
add a lot of water to it it'll become
like a peanut butter sauce
so it's pretty good with cooking
not real cheap but it is lightweight
lasts forever
grantham says uh when we were talking
about what happened a little poor little
pookie today granthar says in the movie
witness harrison ford threatens to
strangle a woman with her bra if she
took a photo of him that's nice i had
forgotten all about that i hadn't seen
that movie in a long time i don't
remember that i didn't remember that
movie uh he was the bad guy
i can't remember wasn't that was that
the one with the amish weren't wasn't
that amish wasn't he investigating a
murder like in the amish community or
something like that that's what i
thought
oracle says tom maybe pookie was running
to you for protection that's what it was
and uh cheryl said pookie better stop
giving mommy heart attacks that's what i
told her i was like don't scare me like
that
dad mom is freaking out harshing by
mello probably that's that's probably
like that uh thorn cezanne says it's
tom's world we're just in it yeah pretty
much um
oracle says i knew a guy like that if he
didn't love the media he loved he said
he had the right to convince you to love
it too yeah i mean i've known lots of
people like that but this guy was like
just off the [ __ ] chain with it um
and the camp guy said sounds like my
brother-in-law he knows everything
uh lauren said thornton says my body is
the derelict house
cheryl mcwood i [ __ ] hate banana
especially fake banana yeah i'm just i'm
not a fan
to be honest with you and honestly
i think one time in my life
i was kind of like you know what i think
i'd like a banana maybe i had a maybe i
was like short on potassium or something
so my body was like you should eat a
banana but most of the time people like
want a banana or banana something i'm
like no i do not i don't know why i just
i don't like that that flavor and i and
i'm not usually like real picky about
food i used to be
but
um i'll eat pretty much anything within
reason
but
not a big fan of bananas and i
especially do not like anything that's
like fake banana flavor super super
gross uh fourth throwdown says will my
body fortress protect me against lawn
darts
uh
maybe
because you have deflectors you deflect
your screens your hands you deflect the
[ __ ]
so yeah
um hopefully
hopefully the stream holds steady yeah
well i mean we had i had a couple little
hiccups when it was still on the
starting soon screen and i was like
flipping out because i'm like no
honestly i've been having a hard time i
was trying to like watch a movie over
there yesterday
and it kept like it would go for like
five or six minutes it would go low-res
and then it would you know the the
connection would lose and then i would
get the connection back and it's just
like i was like [ __ ] it i watched like
30 minutes in the movie and i limited
this to [ __ ] 240p so hopefully it's
okay
try to keep that data down low oracle
says jenny i've heard a reason for evil
fake banana taste the evil fake banana
taste is because the chemical is based
on the earlier cultivar of bananas and
since most people alive these days have
never eaten the older one we reject it
as not banana that might be
um because yeah bananas
uh they don't look like that in the wild
those are mostly a human creation
as a lot of fruits are corn is is uh
fake yeah it's that's why i don't really
that's why i'm not really that bothered
when people are like oh gmos and stuff
like that i'm like well
most things that we eat nowadays
were didn't exist yeah i mean they were
cultivated by humans they had this like
a young earth creationist he used to
make all these videos and there was a
channel they used to watch that used to
[ __ ]
basically bag on what he was talking
about and he was saying of course
vegetables and all this stuff was just
created recently to be used by man and
the example that he used was the banana
yeah he says look it's curved
it's actually mint so you can peel it
and just and it's perfect nutrition and
atheists were quick to point out uh yeah
that didn't exist that's only 80 years
yeah they're totally man-made dumbass
the real banana was yeah it's a couple
inches long i've had them yeah some of
them were that's the guy that hangs out
with kirk cameron what's that douche's
name yeah it is i know they call him
banana man but i can't remember what it
i can't remember he's totally wrong he
has no idea he's talking about obviously
and
when i was in brazil they had some
really good banana plantations there
that
had kinds of bananas you'd never see in
the united states one of them was a
little bitty banana came on a big bundle
and the each banana was maybe two and a
half three inches long they were kind of
straight
and you peeled them the same way but ray
comfort that's recovery that might have
been his name that is his name
what was weird about that banana is that
it the texture was like a banana but the
flavor was like an orange
it was you would have liked it
probably anything it doesn't taste like
a banana yeah it was kind of like a
cross between an orange and a banana
excuse me crust between an orange and a
and a um
an apple
it's kind of a creamy yeah
see that sounds delicious not like
whatever [ __ ] they have going on
kind of like a
kind of like a creamsicle bar it's like
you know what i mean in a weird weird
yeah
yeah hugo says chicken breasts have
grown 400 in the last hundred years
honestly i was watching on
i was watching on rifftrax the other day
they had this short it looked like it
was from the 40s or maybe the early 50s
and it was like a thanksgiving dinner
like it was trying to teach kids like
table manners
and the turkey that they brought out
under the same like that is the saddest
most pathetic looking turkey i've ever
seen that was smaller
than chicken yeah then the chickens you
just buy at walmart for four dollars it
was scrawny looking not sweet it was
about the size of it i was like you
can't feed a family with that it's about
the size of a big duck are you guys poor
yeah it was not very big the chicken of
tomorrow yeah yeah
honestly that's one of my favorite
shorts that they did on mst i don't know
why i love that short so much uh but the
chickens that they show on there are
yeah very very scrawny yeah because yeah
and the size of a pigeon yeah pretty
much i mean that was kind of like uh
you know that before all the hormones
and all the [ __ ]
yeah that too um you know they do give
them things to like fatten them up yeah
outside laurel mississippi there's
santas and farms
and they could have a chicken would take
it from a hatched chicken hatched chick
the day that it hatched
to ready to ready for [ __ ] slaughter
i think it was two weeks that can't be
right
there's got to be something wrong
yeah to get a chicken that big and uh
there were people that would work there
and like rumors would come out of status
farm
that those chickens grew so quickly that
they would break their own legs
that's why they keep them in those
little baskets in this little cheryl
just said poor chickens can't even walk
anymore
yeah well no they put them in those
[ __ ] baskets because if they let them
run around their legs will break
because the bones the bones never quite
harden
because they're not old enough but they
can
they're jacked up on so much steroids
if they grow they grow to maturity like
i think it was two weeks
it's just [ __ ] amazing
and they uh
they feed them a lot of stuff to make
them grow big feed them a lot of food
um they just keep them in basically a
small cage and just let them just eat
themselves just [ __ ]
24 7.
they're just an eating machine and then
they were kind of selectively bred too
they they're breeding the ones the
bloodlines that can do that there was a
bunch of other bloodlines that can't
grow that big that quickly and they're
not they let those die out they just
send those to slaughter they don't breed
any more of those
and it's artificial i think insemination
i think with all of it i don't think
it's normal chicken breeding yeah i
don't really think they just let them
like run around and like you know [ __ ]
whoever they want it's all kind of
artificial process and they all look
like clones they're all the same color
they're all just white
it's it's amazing you know it's it's
just a meat machine
yeah that's the meat factory yeah i mean
that's exactly what it what it is and
the chickens don't seem to mind because
the chicken's job is just to eat so they
just put them in this little box and
they just eat there's like oh just eat
all this all right yeah i can do that
yeah
and they're not very old so they they
you know they died like a week two weeks
something was two weeks
it's [ __ ] damn that's
bizarre
fourth throw down says have you ever
seen a cooked pigeon it's like a thumb
with legs
that's kind of like with these chickens
but honestly the chicken the chicken of
tomorrow short i mean that was like kind
of an eye opener too but i can't even
remember what that was that one was in
color but i think the thanksgiving one
that i saw the riff tracks when it's on
youtube for free if you want to watch it
um i can't remember what it's called
it's something about table manners or
eating as a family or some [ __ ] like
that i don't know uh but the
thanksgiving when the turkey was what
really like threw me off because i'm
like wow
that it was really small the only the
thing that really kind of weirded me out
the chickens don't bother me that much
what bothers me was the the
the sly
the fish in the barrel
yeah fish just packed in a 55-gallon
plastic barrel a drum with a lid on it
they just pop oxygen into there it's
just living in a bunch of oxygenated
water
like a froth of water
and they change the water it's the
machines that change the water out so
they're not living in their own waste
and they feed them in there and pump a
bunch of
antidepressants and [ __ ]
and they just stay in that barrel their
whole lives lots of drugs that's
relevant to uh to tonight's topic yeah
they pump drugs into them to keep them
into the water to keep them calm so they
don't fight in that barrel and they've
never really seen daylight or lived as a
fish
they're just hatched from little eggs
and little guppies and
i mean that's a weird thing it's like do
they i mean i guess they wouldn't know
any different they don't know any better
they live in total darkness pretty much
yeah
that's still i don't know yeah kind of
weird to think i mean they are a robot
they're robots basically but
that's weird that's really weird but
sometimes i wonder if there's just like
something going on there like what the
[ __ ] how much could you learn inside of
a damn barrel with a packed full of
other fish just right next to you
you know yeah it's like
goddamn it'd be like being in utero your
whole life
yeah that's probably exactly what it
would be like which yeah i don't know
i don't remember what it was like the
first time so yeah but i think that's
kind of what they're like
and i'd and i'd look at scans at anybody
that said they did actually remember
right i don't think
that was that was the chinese method of
growing them
farming them they do that here
well that's why i swear so cheap yeah
they're super cheap and they uh it's
weird man because they're like uh
grown in the dam and they did it's for
practical reasons you don't have to
pull them you don't have to build a pond
you don't have to pull them out of a
pond or catch them you have to net them
it's real efficient just put them in
those barrels
and uh you can you keep them separate so
if something goes wrong with one barrel
it doesn't destroy all the other barrels
because they're segregated
you know so it's like they got it down
to a science
it makes you wonder how those fish
[ __ ] experience reality
or or are they just robots they don't
really experience reality
i mean they've got to experience reality
to some degree or they wouldn't still be
around that's kind of how natural
selection works but once it gets to a
point where it's like artificial
selection like with humans involved um
yeah i'm not really sure but that's i
don't know that's always kind of
something i wonder about because i'm
always like really interested i've
always been really interested in like
animal intelligence like how animals
perceive the world and
i you know so i i'd be really curious
i you know what i think it would be
really cool i don't know if this would
be cool it'd probably be horrifying but
if they could somehow like transplant
your consciousness into an animal for
some so you could experience the world
like that yeah just to see what it was
like
everyone would probably become
vegetarians when that happened
or they would just grow meat in a lab
probably be like when you were like a
real real little kid
probably like that less than that maybe
um that uh just gonna depend on the
animal of course yeah depending on the
animal i mean we've we've said and we've
said this on the show too it's like it
is pooky seems very much like
like a human child yeah uh you know
maybe like toddler or maybe even older
because she's it yeah because she seems
pretty smart she can figure some [ __ ]
out right she can figure out how to get
into some situations as i mentioned
earlier which you know that's like
little kid and honestly i really like
jackson galaxy said this because i watch
his videos sometimes and he said people
think that you could just like leave
cats and they'll be okay and you can
like run around and stuff he's like no
man it's like you get a cat it's like
you gotta baby proof your house because
they're like having a cat is like having
a toddler that can reach the ceiling
that's what he said and i was just like
thank you very much for saying that
because i think that that will really
like
because i didn't even think about
leaving that closet door open and now
i'm like okay now i can never leave that
closet door open and now i'm like
worried about the cabinets like
underneath the bathroom because she can
open those yeah i don't think i don't
think there's there's nothing in there i
think that can hurt her
and that one's just like foam and like
coffee cans and stuff so i don't think
she can anything can hurt her in there
but i'm definitely not letting her get
in that [ __ ] closet anymore that's
for sure
um you know i don't think she can she
can't open that door but she can
definitely open the cabinets under there
uh but yeah so are we like kind of uh
warmed up at this point you're talking
about the chickens and you know the
thing about the chickens is that you can
the chickens you can see the chicken
sitting in the damn little cages
you can see them eating the food they
are kind of
experiencing the outside world they seem
they don't seem to be
you know super unhappy or anything
because a chicken just mostly just wants
to be fed
and they're not very old they don't live
very long
so that's just all they know and by the
time i think they would ever start to
question it it's too late it's time for
slaughter
you know it's like a couple of weeks
that's it
and they're doing things when they're
chicks
so you know
yeah
they don't seem to be under into under
any stress they're not having to you
know give them antidepressants or
sedatives like they do the fish they try
to keep the fish calm or they're
the birds or they'll fight they start
fighting in a barrel yeah
well as any as most species would if you
cram them that close together i mean
whatever species no matter how
intelligent they are quote unquote they
don't want to be like [ __ ] crammed
like with a bunch of other you know
nobody does right
so the chickens aren't under that kind
of stress they just seem to be chilling
out and eating constantly looking at the
other chickens and
and if you let them go they've gained so
much weight so quickly if you let them
run around they'll break their own legs
literally because they just weigh too
much for those hollow little bones that
haven't really set yet they're not old
enough form to set
they're not they're growing much faster
than they should have grown in the wild
a lot faster it's not a wild animal
totally genetically engineered
yeah
uh ian england says jenny has too much
faith in humanity lol there's [ __ ]
cannibals running around out there there
are but i mean human cannibalism is
pretty rare
um
you know yeah people suck i get that uh
but
i don't know
i don't think people are necessarily i
don't know i don't think i have much
faith in humanity at all in fact i think
i said to you the other night that if
aliens came i'd be like get the [ __ ] off
get me off this [ __ ] planet
um you know so i'm not a big fan of
humans but it's just like
but cannibalism among humans is pretty
rare you got to say i think most people
in normal circumstances
yeah and that's what i mean uh just in
the run of your everyday life you know
how many cannibals you're gonna meet in
your entire life probably not all that
many hopefully the the human kingdom is
just like the animal kingdom the
predators have risen to the top
if you get into the top one percent of
the power structure of the planet bad
people
to acquire that they've inherited a lot
of it and they do a lot of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in order to [ __ ] maintain that
power you can't be
a good person and
hold on to that kind of power
they do something small that destroys
millions of lives people get killed
just by pressing a button somewhere in
some bank
putting people out and that's me and
that's
mostly i don't even know if that's
um that's just them like look
selfishness that's what that is that's
just
that's just right and you know they
literally believe that you're you're
here on their planet using up their
resources they just see you as a hungry
mouth
and obsolete farm equipment obsolete
factory equipment
it's zardoz [ __ ] [ __ ] exactly that's
how they see you junk
and if you're educated you have a
college degree you're not rich
you're just originally designed to be
the servant class to the elites so they
could have a professional service to
serve them
that happened at the end of the damn
end of the middle ages the beginning of
the of the uh
renaissance started educating the middle
class and they really don't need that
anymore they can replace you with david
like those robots from a prometheus a.i
granthar says i know a prison guard at
the milan uh psychiatric prison for the
criminally insane he tells me the
inmates are all fed uh trazadone and are
just happy as clams totally zoned out
just like this fish yeah i mean probably
the best thing to do yeah circumstances
uh tammy says go buy some baby proofing
kits to put on your cabinets honestly
that never occurred to me but after that
happened today i'm like yeah i think i
might i might do that because
i'm not sure like how because those they
don't have handles on them those
bathroom cabinets like i said there's
nothing under there that could hurt her
um you know all that i keep under this
one is like
my coffee for my coffee pot and
[ __ ] and some foam like some soundproof
foam that's all it's under there but
i don't know i just i don't like her
getting into stuff and now i'm like
really worried about it so you know um
let's see okay so i guess
we'll just start talking about the
actual topic now although i should
probably wait until top comes back so
maybe we can talk about some other stuff
but uh yeah so
i don't know i don't know i don't know
how those those baby-proofing kits i've
seen them they're kind of like don't
they clip onto the inside of the thing
and like
you have to push them because
she can um she puts her little paw like
underneath and then she just pulls it
because it's like magnetic and she just
like pulls it and then sticks her head
in there to keep it open and then goes
in there she doesn't do anything she
just goes in there and then comes back
out
pookie goes where she wants she does
pretty much
um
so you know i just like i'm trying not
to worry about her but
now that she pulled that crap with the
closet today and i'm super worried now
we don't let her go in the closet in the
bedroom we never have because
tom's boots are in there like he has
like these kind of expensive like work
boots
and she
is obsessed with them and will
absolutely tear the [ __ ] out of them if
you let her and honestly she likes to do
that so much that if she hears you open
the closet door in the bedroom like to
get clothes out or something she runs in
there
and then like she sees you standing
there she's like they're looking
can i go in there and tear the boots up
while they're looking or can i sneak in
there like she's like trying to do it so
you can't leave it open for any length
of time because she hears it opening and
she'll run in there and like start like
[ __ ]
jumping on the [ __ ]
all right so uh
yeah
thorn says anne says can't all those
drugs and hormones be ingested by us
yeah probably i mean
i don't know i guess i'm not all that
concerned about it but
it probably is bad for you at some point
oh we got some
bots
showing up so let's get rid of that
oh went all blurry you blurred all the
[ __ ]
are you ready to start talking about sid
vicious now now that everyone's probably
like took off and everything yeah um
why not get no duplicate boots for her
to scratch okay we've tried this kind of
stuff no yeah she's way too clever for
us here's one thing that happened
another thing she likes to chew on is
tom has these uh they're kind of they're
radios
and they have like antennas on them yeah
and
he has another antenna that's like
broken
and she was like chewing on the
expensive one and he was like okay well
here's a broken one like chew on that
she absolutely will not no she knows the
ones that you're using she knows the
ones that you don't want her to do and
that's the one she wants and the same
thing happened too because your tablet
yeah she likes to sit on the tablet and
also you have like a little bit of tape
on there that's like over the camera the
camera's got a tape and she wants to sit
on the tablet and eat that tape off or
like pull it off with her mouth so he
had an old tablet and he put pieces of
tape all over it and gave it to her as a
toy she won't play with it she's like
nope that's not the real thing she's
like nope that's not that's not daddy's
yeah i want that one right
yeah it's only the one that you don't
want her to [ __ ] with what she's talking
about with radios is i had a bunch of
uh you know
basically you call them walkie-talkies
but the ham and gmrs ones
a couple different country companies the
antenna on them has got a soft rubber
covering she loves that [ __ ] she wants
to bite the tips
teeth marks all over it looks ridiculous
every single pen i have because i'll
i'll be writing something and she just
comes over there and goes right like
while i'm trying to she loves to choose
she chewed one of them off of ocean
radio of expensive radio 200 radio
well i got a damn the antenna was like
15 bucks i got another antenna didn't
have the damn teeth marks on it and i
gave her the one they had the teeth
marks and she's like oh no [ __ ] that one
that one's all right
she wanted that she wants she wants
something so what it is i took the new
antenna and hid that
so i just keep the old one on there you
have to hide things yeah i keep the old
on there i just covered it in the damn
uh little adhesive tape for the [ __ ]
met uh for um you call it
tennis rackets a little tennis racket
yeah and look it looks okay you know it
looks better hides the teeth barks
she but you know she wants to bite that
too she's absolutely not dumb any kind
of anything that's like a stick that's
rubbery and
she likes to chew on it gosh she loves
that and she knows if it's been freshly
chewed or never chewed before she likes
that
virgin rubber
no teeth marks in it she wants to be the
first one to put teeth marks in it it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
and to be honest take this one they're
like no no
i even yeah i even bought her
a big bag of chew sticks that are like
rubbery and they kind of taste like
chicken yeah do you think she will chew
on those she will for a second she'll
kind of chew on him and then she just
pushes him off the desk and then she
looks at him yeah she's like nah nah i
would rather chew on your pens yeah
you know your radio antennas radio
antennas your boots yeah your couch
[Laughter]
you can't be mad though she's too cute i
mean but she's not dumb tries to reason
with you
she tries to go this is how pookie does
well her eyes are kind of like narrow at
you i'm going to invite this
come on
see her
trying to talk you into it yeah give him
little angry looks when you say no yeah
she has a little yeah she makes a little
face like that if you like say something
that she doesn't want to hear that [ __ ]
she wants to chew that thing
and as soon as you turn your back she'll
over there
hey
i wasn't doing it i wasn't chewing it
she's [ __ ] it's hilarious she totally
tries to play it off try to play it off
like she's like what i wasn't i don't
know why you're yelling at me i wasn't
doing anything just like a little kid
yep
she is like she is freaking like she is
frighteningly smart yeah that cat she's
really smart she's very deceptive yeah
well they said that in about max cats
that and how they're described yeah it's
exactly the way that they've described
so it's genetic
yeah i'm sure because other i've seen
other breeds of cats that were kind of
like that too but yeah the mex cat in
particular yeah uh they're saying that's
one very like common
hallmark they're not like
that mortal dog or monkey like and it's
exactly in the sense that they follow
you around everywhere and it's like they
want to be involved in everything that
you're doing yeah you literally can't do
anything you can't put laundry away you
can't make the bed you can't do anything
without her programming radios
hey i'm going to help you
[Laughter]
working on little machinery she's got to
come up and look at it and [ __ ]
take something and she's like what you
got there yeah right yeah
it's funny i told you i can't even brush
or comb my hair anymore she's got to get
involved in that [ __ ] yeah she's like
jumping up on my chest like hey i want a
brush i wanna all brush making shirts
you're using a heat gun she's gonna run
up and [ __ ] get try to get the heat
out and watch it
why why what does it do how does that
work she's just very curious she is very
curious yeah why are you throwing the
hot wind on that
[Laughter]
humans don't make sense
yeah i mean when tom's in there like
working on something in his man cave she
will sit there for hours watching me
just watching yeah and like what you
doing you should put her hand in there
and try to get involved
and she's like oh and then did you try
to put it well i was in here putting
that couch together and she was in here
trying to help like climbing on
everything going like do you need me to
help you like screw that in or yeah
[Laughter]
and i told you you can't make the bed
without her jumping on it and like
trying to
try to like sit she's not helping but i
tell her she's helping okay should we
get the sid and nancy yeah we got enough
people in here
uh i don't want to be like too drunk by
the time it gets although it would be
very punk rock if we got to the end and
we were so [ __ ] up that we couldn't
talk anymore yeah
let's not do that
uh okay so first thing all right
so we're gonna talk a little bit about
sid vicious background i wanted to talk
a little bit about nancy sponge at the
background and then we'll kind of i
didn't want to get too much into the sex
pistols the band
um i kind of wanted to mostly focus on
sid focus on kind of like the [ __ ] that
was going on around the time that kind
of like the crime and what happened to
sit afterwards it's really funny i was
like watching i watched like a whole
bunch of documentaries about this and
like you know read a whole bunch of [ __ ]
about it and like i said this is
something that
you know particularly of our generation
and people that are into punk and
post-punk and stuff this was something
we grew up with i used to have a poster
of sid vicious like when i was a
teenager uh i saw city nancy back in the
80s whenever the [ __ ] it came out with
gary oldman in it even though gary
oldman uh hated punk music yeah so not
quite as cool as i thought but uh you
know he was [ __ ] great in that movie
though yeah it's a good movie it does
kind of i will say that it does kind of
like romanticize it but i'm not gonna
like [ __ ] on it for that because
a lot of people do romanticize
the story even though
uh
i don't i don't know it's i kind of feel
like i i feel like i probably
romanticized it too when i was younger
but
i guess it's just kind of part of that
nihilistic that's self-destructive it's
just like oh you know the and they were
so [ __ ] young and yeah ever they were
living in squats in this [ __ ] squalor
and they were just like so [ __ ]
drugged up but i'm sure if you were like
experiencing it at the time it was
probably not romantic at all because
it's like everything was [ __ ] dirty
and gross although the weird thing about
it is that people who were there like i
was watching this one documentary
and um legs mcneil who uh you know he's
a music journalist and he uh was you
know
instrumental like he was in the punk
scene he knew a lot of them and he wrote
a book about it i think it's called
please kill me which i read a long time
ago
and he knew all of them and even though
he's you know an old man now but he was
just kind of like you know there was
something kind of
you know alluring about the squalor
and i get that i get that a lot with
especially people that maybe grew up in
new york city like back in the 70s and
days before it got cleaned up
and a lot of them were kind of like yeah
well it's nice that we don't have the
crime now but there was just something
cooler about it back then like before it
got gentrified like it was dangerous and
it was dirty and it was crime ridden
and
[ __ ] like that but there was something
kind of alluring about it so i get that
but
i don't know nobody was up your ass
yeah i mean a lot of people do whatever
you wanted well yeah you could yeah
which in a lot of ways was probably good
and very liberating but then on the the
dark side of that uh a lot of you you
could do anything you wanted so p bad
people could also do anything they
wanted which i'm sure was not a good
time for some people and uh yeah so i so
i kind of feel like i see that there are
like two sides of the issue or whatever
yeah before she gets off on into this
if you hear any negativity about sid
you have to remind yourself that sid was
a [ __ ] kid
he didn't live long
he was dead by what 19 21 21 was he's
21.
[ __ ] man i mean
he was dead i don't even remember he was
being 21. he was dead by the time most
people are just getting their starts
i mean
our buddy nick
[ __ ] who i kind of adopted a little
bit
he's he just made 21.
okay
and he's starting out he had a pretty
good start in life you can't imagine if
i'd imagine look at nick even though
nick's dad
he's gone all right
he
nick's dad was a drug abuser
and died okay od
but his mom and his other extended
family they they took good care of me
turned out good um yeah he's a he's a
nice kid yeah he's a nice kid he's a
really nice guy and um
in some ways kind of like a much smarter
version to sit
but without the drug problem
all right now he's no angel but he's
he's not addicted to anything
he he's someone he told me he says man
you know there's kind of a weird allure
i wouldn't mind taking that i want to
know what my dad went through and i said
don't you ever [ __ ] do that [ __ ] you
won't come back
i'm like i'm fine with some drugs but
[ __ ] like heroin and stuff like that i
just feel like maybe
not
yeah i said
you you won't come back that's why your
dad didn't come back from that he goes
yeah that's what i figured yeah i don't
think i would be i mean i was never
tempted he's like well i didn't really
know him i just wanted to know you know
[ __ ] what it was he was fighting
against i said no dude i get that though
like i get that right um right i you
know i get that desire right but told
him about rich and [ __ ] and some other
guys and other people that i knew back
in the day that got involved in that
that right there just turned you into a
piece of [ __ ] man you don't want
anything to do with that
and poor sid was born addicted to that
his parents were addicted well i don't
know if he was born addicted to it
because i think that his mom his mom was
a heroin addict but later
um and his dad actually left when he was
a baby this whole uh that angle doesn't
fit the stereotypical
situation because his mom was in the
british army she was just like but they
were like later on did you think you
think you don't he was born with it no
okay um he didn't actually get into
heroin until
later okay
but his mom also was
was a heroin addict she actually died of
a heroin overdose but i don't think she
got into it later she was a pothead
right uh i think when she was younger
but yeah we'll get into i don't think
one half of the addicts i knew up and up
i don't think he was born addicted to
heroin though more than half of the
addicts that i knew and that was up in
boston they came their parents came from
that new york scene they were born
addicted to it a lot of people probably
were i mean it was very prevalent right
very prevalent back then which not just
in the punk scene either right
um i mean that's i kind of feel like
that's what's associated with it but
yeah but
their parents were kind of punkish yeah
and these were got goth kids older than
me they were goth adults when i was a
kid
and they were born addicted
yeah because i mean we i mean you're
slightly older than me you're so you
were
69 you were born i was born in 72. so i
was like
still pretty young
when punk rock because i was i got more
into like in the early 80s so i was more
like into the post punk thing because
punk has
had pretty much already kind of uh you
know blown its wide by then
but um i got into it a little bit later
like in the early to mid 80s
but
yeah you knew some people we knew some
people that were like uh you know 10 20
years older than us yeah that were into
it right you know before and they had
had kids you know
and they're they're born well i guess in
the 50s
and they were addicted to it then
so it had been around for a long time
yeah it's been around for a long at
least in the northeast in new york area
area
people forget that
morphine and morphine addiction goes way
back into the 1800s way back
so it does yeah it was kind of yeah drug
addiction is not generation absolutely
not a new thing at all right um it was
usually passed down generationally
which you can see that happening i mean
there's i'm sure there's a genetic
component to addiction um
and there's also if you were raised
around it yeah well it's just like if
your parents smoke chances are you want
to smoke yeah it's kind of the same kind
of thing my parents smoked
yeah so you know which is weird because
my dad and my grandparents always smoked
but i never really was interested in it
until i got older i didn't even really
start smoking so i was in my 30s
i smoked up until what 48.
yeah you saw me quit about 48 probably
yeah something like that yeah i haven't
smoked since then
nope you have it
no interest in it but it's just re it's
weird that like i didn't i grew up
around a lot of smokers my mom didn't
smoke but everybody else in my family
pretty much did or my immediate family
and i just was never
i was never interested in it i kind of
thought it was gross for like a long
time until i was like in my 30s and i'm
like then i started smoking clothes
because i got into like gotham so some
of what i was talking about
if we say anything negative about sid
you gotta understand that sid was a
[ __ ] kid okay
they both were yeah and to be honest
with you it's like older than him but
sit i mean sid did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
nancy did some [ __ ] up [ __ ] i mean by
all accounts she was intolerable to be
around yeah but she grew up with a lot
of problems too yeah um i'm not excusing
anything they did because like i said
they did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
but
they were
dumb they were young and dumb real dumb
he was much younger dumber than her
um by all accounts she was actually
quite intelligent but sort of crazy yeah
uh sid was dumb
sid was kind of it was dumb
some people just said that he was just
dumb as [ __ ]
he was funny people liked him yeah
people thought he was quite sweet yeah
uh that he had a good sense of humor
right yeah like i said he did do some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and i'm not gonna gloss
everything
and uh
you know his friend you know john lyden
or johnny rotten was light years ahead
of of sid in terms of intelligence
which i would i would probably put john
above average intelligence
[ __ ] did we lose it wait a thread
okay okay we're back i don't i don't
know i would just what i was saying
before if i got cut off
i would say that sid was [ __ ] below
average intelligence
um
but i would say john lyden his friend
was probably above average intelligence
he was way way ahead but
i know that
i know that john
seen in interviews with him he feels
real bad about what happened he does
yeah okay
he felt responsible for that yeah but no
it's it's survivor's guilt there's
nothing that [ __ ] john could have
done
yeah but that doesn't i mean saying that
yeah um if i'd been in that situation i
would probably feel bad my whole entire
life too whether i was actually
responsible or not that doesn't really
matter at the time at the time john was
around with sid and all this has
happened john was also young he was a
little bit older but he was also really
young he was john was not equipped to
help sid it just
he was too young to help him he was just
not psychologically equipped for it well
they were all kids they were all kids
you're right i mean they were all kind
of like working class kids they didn't
know what the [ __ ] was going on or i
would say under class but yeah that's
you know let's if you want to say it
that way yeah john had spite was it i've
got spinal meningitis from having
[ __ ] rats piss on him
he grew up in a [ __ ]
rat infested
council
estate was constantly [ __ ] sick
[ __ ] his eyes up and everything um
but he was an above average intelligence
guy
john
just cursed
with uh
being born into that situation at that
time england was not a was a rough place
in the in the time that he grew up
well and that's what i and that's what
kind of makes me sad about the whole
thing is that if some of these uh you
know individuals had been born in a
different time or different place or
different circumstances they probably
would have turned out okay yeah two of
us it was poverty now it wasn't poverty
it was more environment
poverty in a [ __ ] city is a lot worse
than poverty in the country good guy
like said if he was born to poverty say
out in mississippi they still had good
upbringings
because it's just
you don't have the population density
you got the outside you got fishing you
got hunting you got other things to do
it's just a totally different culture
trying to grow up in a [ __ ] highly
congested city with no money [ __ ]
with rats everywhere man
that's bad
i mean i grew up fairly poor but you
know iron rural is very bad i mean i
didn't grow up rural it was probably
more like suburban
right um but honestly until i was older
i didn't really realize
that we were poor yeah poor and urban's
the heart is the worst
because my parents who my parents were
actually very very young when they had
me they were only 18
uh when they had me
so
uh you know we were always kind of
living with family and stuff but
honestly it's to their credit i didn't
really realize uh
that we were poor until i was older i
mean that [ __ ] went red again i know
well i'm trying not and you know it
seems to be like coming back at some
points but i'm just like really
i'm just hoping this isn't doing gonna
do that [ __ ] like it did the other night
where we have to do [ __ ] in like four
parts because that was really annoying
okay come on green green green green
green
god damn it
i hate this look at it it's like coming
and going in here too
i hate this yeah
well it's just like i try to get
you know
i feel like i'm trying to you know all
right you have to explain some [ __ ] let
me go ahead and restart the [ __ ]
router i don't know it seems to be okay
now
it seems to be okay now but
i don't really know i don't know why
we're having so much trouble with this
[ __ ] connection lately
um
[Music]
anarchy extra says sid didn't kill her
honestly i'm kind of like i don't know i
wasn't there but
i kind of feel like if i had been on if
you know if
circumstances had been different and sid
had actually gone to trial for it uh you
know spoiler alert he died before that
happened
but um
had i been on the jury
i do not think i could in good
conscience have
said that he did it because
there were just too many other factors
he very well might have
but if he did i don't think he
meant to kill her
um or it's very possible she could have
done it herself or it's possible that
there could have been like a third party
involved because
there had been a lot of other people
like in the hotel in and out of the
hotel room that night because they'd had
a party
and
you know there were some mitigating
factors there um so
i don't think and you know i don't think
we can even like really say
what the [ __ ] happened there i don't
think anyone will ever know
um
had he gone to trial i don't think if
the jury had been in the right mind i
don't think he would have been convicted
i mean i think the worst thing they
could have convicted him of was maybe
manslaughter maybe
maybe second degree murder maybe i don't
even think it i don't even think they
had the evidence for that to be honest
with you
but
did it fall again no it's fine okay it's
fine
but um i was saying that ooh you made it
all go blurry
everything went blurry yeah
look at it why does it do with that
that's weird
come on
there we go it came back
uh yeah somebody said sid didn't kill
her and i was just kind of like i you
know we talk about that
i mean well no well we can talk about in
this show because this was a show that's
actually like about it
but
i don't think there was any way of
proving it i kind of leaned toward maybe
accident it was just an accident or b
that somebody else might have done it
too it's you know there's
kind of like uh because there was a lot
of other people like in and out of their
crime scene doesn't support murder
not really no no
um
you know i i think it was just like a
terrible
accident or there might have been
somebody else involved because i think
uh dj maniac said earlier he thought uh
rockets read glare who we'll we'll get
into that who was a comedian uh that
maybe he had something to do with it he
was actually at the hotel room that
night and there was like some kind of
[ __ ] so it's so it could be uh mango
says curious fact courtney love
auditioned for the role of nancy instead
of nancy yeah uh she did actually
although chloe webb got it
and uh
that's like i said i really like that
movie i'd have been curious to see
courtney love in that role because
although chloe webb was great and she
was annoying as [ __ ] but
according to everybody that actually
knew nancy spungen and i'm not saying
that she deserved to like [ __ ] die
the way she did because that was awful
but
pretty much everybody except sid
hated her you know what i mean so
they but like i said she had a [ __ ] up
upbringing too so
she she also had some problems so i'm
inclined to be
i'm inclined to be like a little bit
more charitable toward the two of them
they were dumb kids
it was a bad scene and
you know [ __ ] happened like i said i'm
not excusing like some of the [ __ ] that
they did but you know
so um all right so sid vicious obviously
not his real name um this is like really
funny because i was watching like i
think i was going to say this earlier
but i was watching like a bunch of
documentaries about this
and i saw this one it was like 15 or 16
minutes and it was like this really
younger
woman
and she was doing like a true crime
episode on it
and the one of the first things that she
said was like this case isn't very well
known i'm like where the hell have you
been i'm like maybe it's not that well
known to like [ __ ] 20 year olds but
i'm like everybody our age knows about
this [ __ ]
this is like super super famous
yeah and uh also i was kind of inclined
to be in a lot of people in the comments
i don't i don't like to be shitty like
people on youtube especially like
younger people they don't know but um
you know she kind of pronounced all of
the names wrong and [ __ ] like that so i
was just kind of like
right i couldn't like watch the whole
thing but yeah so i just thought it was
funny that she said that it wasn't that
well known like i said i guess
i don't know i'm not i don't have my
finger on the pulse of like the [ __ ]
uh 20 year olds nowadays but
i kind of feel like just from our
perspective this is obviously a very
very well-known case uh so yeah so sid
vicious uh born
simon john richie
now he was born in 1957
and as i said uh his parents john and
anne
anne
had actually dropped out of school and
then she joined the british army and
that's where she ended up meeting
sid's dad
now his dad was also a musician he was
semi-professional he was a trombone
player uh but he was into jazz
he was also a guardsman at buckingham
palace so there was that so he had
by all accounts like fairly normal
parents for the time i guess
now after sid was born no that's not his
real name but that's just what i'm gonna
call him like so it's not confusing
so not too long after sid was born
though
um
he and his mom like moved to ibiza
now uh they had every expectation that
uh his dad you know her husband was
going to join them i mean that was the
plan
but uh he never showed up
and uh he also never paid child support
so there was that
so now his mom is a single mother
uh and supposedly start selling pot like
just you know to get by because like i
said she's in ibiza at this point
so then since she'd been in the army i
guess she was able to go through the
british high commission and you know get
some help like moving back to the uk
so she moves back uh they moved to kent
1965 when sid was about
eight years old i believe
um
and married again
she married a guy named christopher
beverly
now he
died
of kidney failure only six months after
they were married
so at this point she's a single mom
again i don't know if he was an
alcoholic or if he was just unlucky or i
don't really know but he had kidney
failure
got jaundice somehow yeah maybe i mean
huh john is from liver or kidney uh yeah
i thought i thought jaundice was liver
but i could be remembering that right
just might have some kind of renal
failure
that's what i mean it's like it happens
i mean you don't have to be an alcoholic
for that tap and that was the first
thing i jumped to but
that doesn't mean anything
uh so at this point like i said ann is a
single mother again so her and sid uh
kind of moved around
but then in 1971 ended up in east london
and at this point sid even though he was
born simon richie starts using the name
john beverly which john being his middle
name and beverly being the last name of
his stepdad
who had died
so
i don't know to me maybe i'm
psychoanalyzing but to me that suggests
he was looking for a father figure
and i don't know how long anne and
christopher beverly knew each other
before they married
but
i mean it was only six months after they
married then he was dead so i don't know
that seems really sad to me but yeah so
he took his stepfather's name
now uh two more years go by and at this
point
anne uh has become addicted to heroin
and opiates as well
so as i said that's why i've kind of
questioned whether he was born addicted
to heroin i think she was into kind of
like the drug scene from early like i
said she was a pot dealer
but i don't think she became addicted to
heroin until he was a little bit older
you know what i mean that's maybe now
the thing about it was a relapse maybe
maybe the thing about and this this is
so [ __ ] up like i was watching this
one i think it was a documentary i think
it was called uh i think it's called who
killed nancy
and in that one i don't know how much of
this is true because you know a lot of
this was people that were kind of in the
circle at the time
and sid's mom
they said that her that um
her and sid were more like buddies than
mother and son like she was very
protective of him
but
she would like hang out with him and his
friends
um she would score drugs for him
they you know yeah they used drugs
together
a lot in the scene
yeah so it was a little weird like the
the relationship was a little weird it
almost seemed a little like codependent
and honestly i kind of feel like when he
got together with nancy i think he was
almost using her as like a mom
replacement a little bit even though his
mom was still around at that point
but yeah it was a weird situation he was
young he needed management
yeah i mean you know
um he didn't know what was going on all
the time he needed somebody kind of put
him in the right direction
oh maybe i'm getting ahead of the head
of ourselves no it's all right just go
ahead go for it one of the things about
sid
he's remembered a lot of the based on
upon how he looked he was a good-looking
kid
yeah
yeah and he had a badass [ __ ] style
for the time it was like proto-gothic
a lot of the way that that [ __ ] sid
dressed was kind of like very early 80s
gothic
style black leather jacket spiked black
hair
stuff you saw in bauhaus
uh
stuff that looked like maybe like susie
might be into from susie in the banshees
well he was in susie in the banshees
yeah briefly
for like five minutes yeah
well that look actually came from nancy
nancy got him dressed in that way and i
think she kind of based it on the new
york punk rock scene probably yeah she
was she was american yeah it was
probably the ramones mixed with [ __ ]
bondage gear
and you know sid's look was the [ __ ] man
cool hair well even though he couldn't
really play all that well it's all it
looks yeah but his look was such that he
had like a bunch of different bands
which i'll get into he had a bunch of
different bands like wanting him in the
band just because he looked so good he
had the looks
he had a good stage presence when he
wasn't
[ __ ] stoned out of his [ __ ] gourds
which he usually was he used to be
affair but he could play that too you'll
see some recordings of him [ __ ] doing
[ __ ] he
he had some stage presence to him and he
had a recognizable name and an image
okay
he was kind of like the billy idol that
couldn't sing and had no talent billy
idol could at least sing he had doubt
but
sid didn't
could sid have turned into an artist
yeah
yeah
uh but not pry with that drug addiction
no
yeah let's call that drug addiction yeah
because like i said he started real
young right and he did everything and
honestly
by the time he was you know 19 or
something like that like people around
him were like man he was taking enough
drugs that would like kill [ __ ] three
people yeah if you gave it to a normal
person so he had like a really high
tolerance uh you know which like i said
[ __ ] up
so as i said 1973 at this point sid's
mom is uh is
managing her own action not even
managing it
so she was so [ __ ] up
that she didn't even know what the [ __ ]
was going on with sid
uh sid was going to westminster kingsway
college which was like a vocational
school with uh for difficult
kids so he was actually going to school
most of the time from what i hear
now while he was at king's way this is
where uh he met
um
john lydon
now i should note that around this time
when sid was around 16
he seemed to
um
be exhibiting some uh
problems some mental problems this is a
picture of sid vicious
just so people who don't know who he is
trying to get it
that's what he looked like he had pretty
good style
john goris says sid sings is a fun album
though i do agree
uh like i said he couldn't really play
and he couldn't sing all that well but
i don't know there was something kind of
charming about that
yeah
i think he did a little bit on um
on um
rock and roll swindle too yeah he did my
way yeah he did a good version of myself
my way uh honestly um i like that i
liked he did uh that song something else
i always liked that song
there's my way is also hilarious
quintessential [ __ ] up sid
yeah
when he's like carbon things yeah yeah
yeah what not which we'll get into
uh so
he had
really the perfect late 70s punk rock
look
that [ __ ] and the attitude and mclaren
absolutely saw that yeah
yeah he was defining that
scene
here's a good picture of him
so he was a good-looking guy
good-looking young guy very charismatic
in his way
yeah
so yeah so around this time as i said
sid's about 16 years old he's going to
kingsway college
and he apparently um
like shared with a
counselor because he was having some
problems which like i said not crazy
because his mom's an addict like you
know his dad left his stepdad died it's
like i'm sure he was having a hard time
uh you know they didn't have a lot of
money
he uh said that he was contemplating
suicide even when he was 16 years old
also reportedly i don't know if this is
true if it is as i said i don't have i
don't truck with this kind of [ __ ] but
uh apparently he tortured and killed
some cats or at least one cat and like i
said even if you just do that to one cat
i'm not forgiven that sorry
uh but i don't know if that's mentioned
in some songs
but yeah i don't know if it was i don't
know if it's true or not i think it
might be legendary it better be yeah i
think it's legend it better be that's
all i'm saying don't [ __ ] with cats
that's what i'm saying don't [ __ ] with
cats
uh so sid turned 16 and his mom kicked
him out which seems a little
hypocritical but okay
1973 as i said uh sid meets john lydon
now uh at this point you know because
john lydon was going to the same school
so at this point
there's he introduces them to two of his
friends john gray and john wardle
so these four guys
collectively known as the four johns
they decide that uh school is just not
for them man so they all quit
and they started uh you know going to
various places like you know being
squatters essentially is what they did
so at this point uh three of these four
john's
got their iconic nicknames
john lyden
uh named sid vicious
because he john lydon had a hamster
named sid who was named after sid
barrett uh from the original lineup of
pink floyd
uh and apparently the hamster so the
story goes apparently the hamster bit
sid
and sid said something defective wow
that hamster is really vicious or
something like that so they gave him the
name sid vicious i don't know if that's
true or not that's the legend
uh johnny rotten got the name uh
apparently because of his teeth i guess
because his teeth were kind of funny i
think that's partly legend that's
probably legit see that's that's what i
mean the punk rock scene was like so
iconic and it's just like i kind of feel
like people
make up a lot of stories because some of
the stories like if you read like the
wikipedia page about it or you read like
the all that's interesting page about it
or you read it or you watch different
documentaries everybody's got slightly
different
stories about things so
part of the punk rock street cred
is to glorify
a flaw within you yeah and turn that
into a brand name
john's teeth obviously were not rotten
yeah it evidently came from that he had
green teeth that's what they were
i don't believe he had green teeth i
think probably he when he was young
probably didn't brush his teeth that
much yeah or or somebody noticed that he
didn't brush his teeth that day
and that became part of his uh
his persona yeah but he has all his
teeth or most of them
i think he might have missed a couple
but that could have been a that might
have been from fights because these guys
got their asses beat a lot
yeah um
honestly i saw was it malcolm mclaren
that said i was watching like the
documentary
it might have been malcolm mclaren or
somebody else that uh that knew said he
called sid
uh
a willing victim
in the sense that he was like pretty
scrawny and pretty small he would get
into fights pretty much knowing that he
was going to get his ass beat
yeah he was he was a little and that he
said that he said he was like a little
bit of a masochist he knew he was going
to get like his ass handed to him yeah
and it's almost like he enjoyed it yeah
well he cut himself and just and but the
thing is is that that would kind of get
him laid
in the scene well yeah getting your ass
beat would get you laid yeah because
then you'd have all these damn
psychophantic [ __ ] punk rock girls
try to you know
make it up to you that you got your ass
beat and then those days that meant a
[ __ ] or a hand job
according to billy here's your reward
yeah
accordingly according to billy idol
yes i'm not making that it worked for
sid also i mean he really didn't seem to
have that many problems getting girls
had according to billy head was rare but
hand jobs the [ __ ] girls just had it
out like it was nothing
uh in this scene
they would give you a hand job behind
the [ __ ] place uh just to [ __ ]
just like you know
so they could brag about it
or just just
kind of like on a dare
and
and billy who's another character i
don't know if you guys know he is you
know billy you know
but who was a little bit younger than
these guys not by much a few years
though
um billy evidently he was getting hand
jobs at like 14 by
17 18 year old punk rock girls but that
was on that was on the menu back then
you know just the way it was
it was all that same scene there was
nothing about
underage drinking or anything there was
no rules really yeah no one really gave
a crap i mean as long as you were in the
same seat yeah if you were all into the
same [ __ ] then no one really
asked you how old you were they didn't
care you know what i mean
well i mean as long as you obviously
weren't like 40. yeah i mean everybody
was young you know as long as you
weren't [ __ ] you know ten
yeah it's just yeah i didn't i don't
recall ever hanging out now
if you were in the [ __ ] bar as long
as you were like a teen and you were in
the sea it was like you were you were
you were they were all young people
anyway
yeah everyone was roughly the same age
they were all teenagers
or or early 20s or early teens or yeah
12 13 12 13 14.
but that was in studio 54 too
true there was like
some big scene girls who were famous and
david bowie dating them and then you
look you do the math and you do the
dates you have been a 14.
yikes yeah which like nowadays yeah
nowadays they get you in trouble but
back in the 70s not so much
yeah no one else was really all that
worried about it yeah
uh which you know i'm not saying well
you know they were 20s
yeah so it was between 20s and and
early teens
which i guess in the 70s and with the
law enforcement of the time and it just
they just
they didn't care i guess it was just
like free love type of deal
yeah i suppose it wasn't really a as big
an issue like i said as long as everyone
was in the same scene no one really and
everyone was like close enough in age uh
no one really seemed to worry that much
about it
um like i said i didn't really
experience anything like because you
know for me it was kind of more 80s but
you did kind of have younger people but
nobody likes super super young i mean
everybody i think was at least 15 or and
older
so it wasn't and you never saw i never
really saw like anybody in obviously in
their 20s dating something that was
obviously in their teens it was more
sometimes you'd see 15 year old 18 year
old but
it wasn't all that common most people
were pretty close in age
uh so yeah so i don't know like i said a
lot of it's probably legend like how
johnny rotten got his name ever
the big story is that it was because it
was gross ass teeth i don't know if
that's true
um
and sid was apparently the one that gave
john wardle his nickname of uh jaw
wobble which
is the name he ran with because like i
said he was uh he
was in uh public image limited later and
various other things
so these four guys uh they start hanging
around the iconic
uh store called sex which was owned by
malcolm mclaren and vivian westwood it
was clothing store
and it was on it was in king's row in
chelsea which was kind of like the
epicenter of you know youth subcultures
at that time and that was where all the
punk rockers in london hung out at that
point uh most of them were broke
and uh a lot of them that were
interviewed in some of the documentaries
said yeah everybody just stole from
there so because they never had anybody
so they're like oh that's nice i'm just
gonna have that so everybody would just
like [ __ ] steal from this [ __ ]
store
uh but yeah now at this particular store
interestingly sid vicious
uh meets very famous chrissy hind now
this was before she had uh you know
formed the pretenders she's an american
obviously
uh but she was living in london at the
time christy highs yeah now the uh the
story goes again i don't know if this is
true or this is like some later [ __ ] but
apparently she approached sid vicious
and said hey can i marry you so i can
get my work permit
i don't know if that's true or not she
said that she said that that's that
sounds like some [ __ ] she would do yeah
she said some broke dude you know what i
mean he's
good looking he might need a drink you
know what i mean [ __ ] i'll give you a
hundred bucks marry me and we'll go in
there
so yeah maybe yeah but i guess he turned
it down but yeah yeah uh so i think he
was only like 16 or 17 at the time but
she was she was pretty hunky
uh so at this point uh john lyden and
sid vicious
uh they started like begging or busking
as they call it in the uk we're just
basically like performing in the street
for money
uh the story goes again i don't know if
this is true uh sid fishes would play
the tambourine they would play alice
cooper covers and people gave them money
to stop
i thought that was like super super
funny i don't know if that's true or not
but that's kind of what the story was
now at this point so sid wasn't in the
sex pistols from the beginning he came
in later
so 1975
john lyden uh has steve jones glenn
matlock paul cook and they put together
the sex pistols malcolm mclaren who uh
was partial owner of the sex
clothing store in uh on the kings road
in chelsea was their manager
and uh sid vicious was kind of like
their
super fan like he would go and see all
their gigs but he wasn't in the band yet
but
he was in some other bands so
like i said i don't know it would be a
stretch to call him a musician
uh because he by all accounts he
couldn't really play all that well i
mean sure he probably played better than
me
but
you know
so 1976
like a little while after uh the sex
pistols were formed hold on let me
address them cheryl's going so weird she
didn't seek a medical attention he's
talking about nancy we're gonna get to
that in a minute but cheryl uh
knowing the people like this and the
generation was right but right after
this that i hung out with
actually they were part of this no not
weird at all that she didn't seek
medical attention a lot of people didn't
not weird at all i don't think that they
would have been like oh i can shake that
off that's no big deal yeah i don't hear
that [ __ ] smell i don't think people
took it as seriously
no
um and i remember that too from like
growing up and i and i think that's kind
of like a holdover from the older
generation totally different generation
where they're just kind of like you know
look just snap out of it
you know what i mean they didn't really
understand they look down the gravity of
mental illness yeah they looked down and
saw a little bitty slit
and they probably didn't see much
bleeding oh it's okay
that's
that's and they went give me a hit of
that smack
you know they don't want to go to the
[ __ ] hospital they want to lay it in
the bed and [ __ ] do smack
yeah i kind of feel like you know yeah
yeah it's just it's it's really not that
weird you're thinking like a normal
person of
21
who's not on heroin and not a punk he's
not on all the drugs ever right made not
in a pre-internet civilization
uh that was very high testosterone for
the men and the women
and uh
they fought constantly
talked a lot of [ __ ] they were dirty
they were fun they were very fun
um
but it was mindless fun looking back on
it there's you know what i mean
you'd get bored with that today as an
adult i think even a
i think a normal 20 or 30 year old would
get bored with them pretty quick
well to be honest it's probably i mean
and this is you know from my own
personal experience too it's more fun
for you yeah than it is like hanging out
with you know what i mean it's more fun
getting super [ __ ] up drunk or super
[ __ ] up on drugs or whatever it's fun
for you
but it's not fun with people that are
hanging out with you that maybe didn't
take as many drugs as you did yeah uh
because they have to like deal with your
[ __ ] now yeah so you know what i
mean they have to deal with your
shenanigans
right yeah so it's kind of like yeah it
was like a self-fulfilling kind of thing
where it's like they just ended up
hanging out with other the people just
like self-destructive people like that
because nobody else would hang out with
them because that's like not fun for
told you earlier other people to hang
out with i told you early in the show
that [ __ ] heroine makes you a
worthless piece of [ __ ] you [ __ ] then
that that's what they are yeah it's i
mean it's fun for the person taking it
i'm sure
but obviously he was a non-junkie it's
just like what the [ __ ] and they're just
like sleeping yeah i was friends with
[ __ ] he was a great junkie he could
hide it he could he could function
normally and then he'd go off into
junkie land and rich and he ended up
blowing his brains out
and he was he was 50
i think 52 when he killed himself
and he lived a great life i mean i
he didn't do anything than other than
stay in his [ __ ] room he worked
during the day as a maintenance man and
[ __ ] commonwealth ave in boston
and he was just a good-looking kind of
punk rock
proto-goth guy kind of looked like gary
newman
and uh he was 51 and i don't think he
ever dated a woman older than 35 and
they were just these cute little
goth
junkie girls because having heroin makes
you very attractive to junky women
well obviously yeah you got drugs okay
well but yeah and and i was sexy i was
in my late mid to late 20s hanging out
with him
we didn't hang out full time but i would
hang out with him quite a bit
and uh and the people that hung out with
him like the barbiturates and [ __ ] from
[ __ ] sleep chamber
and john's whiz and all those
that was some weird [ __ ] there it was
fun though
but um
i never saw john as an old man and it's
and normally a 20-something year old guy
sees a 50-something year old guy as an
old man
not john
john came across as a 30-year-old
and psychologically he probably was in
terms of development because he slept
most of his time away
yeah
he could drink an entire fifth and
remain standing
i just i've always kind of admired
people i know it's like a weird like
niche talent but yeah
my brother used to be able to drink an
entire fifth remain standing snort lines
of code and then go and then go inject
some heroin
or snort heroin too you do that also
see i hear about that kind of [ __ ] and
like you know when you hear about like
[ __ ] rock stars and like people like
this and stuff like that i'm like how
are they still like some of them are
still alive look like iggy pop or like
nick cave or something like that like
this [ __ ] are still alive and they
have like all their faculties and they
still look reasonably good oh holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] i got a picture of john
oh he's gonna be rich i got a picture of
rich
i got a picture of rich doing a quick
fashion show when he was in his 30s or
maybe 40s well should i get it
if you want
because i've talked about him a couple
times on the show i'm gonna show you who
it is i'm talking about
and he he did a little modeling tb
drinker says i don't even do smack and i
don't even want to go to the hospital
when i definitely should i know that
feeling i mean honestly i don't know if
it's just because i you know most of my
life i have not had health insurance so
i'm always kind of like
is this really worth
however many thousands of dollars this
is gonna cost
uh i could probably get over it so
i don't know so i never go i mean i have
to be super super dying before i would
actually go to the hospital
uh john gorra says punk was a real
reaction to the hippie boomers yeah and
it totally was and honestly
i get it and like i said i i was really
into i was a little tiny bit young to
get into because i was still kind of a
kid when punk came along but
i got into
post punk and new wave like almost as
soon as it came around like when i was
only like 10 or 11 years old and so i
totally got that [ __ ]
uh that [ __ ] attitude because i'm you
know i'm not into like the whole drug
thing like this whole self-destructive
thing but i get
i get that they got to a point where
everything they thought everything was
like too
hippy-dippy and self-indulgent
and
you know and i get that i'm not really
into it they wanted to go back to like
more of a simple
you know kind of thing and i get that
um so okay so where was i all right
[Music]
so as i said 1976 so sid vicious was
actually in a couple of bands sort of
uh before he was in the sex pistol so
you did find the picture oh yeah there's
rich with his ray gun oh yeah he had a
ray gun he's showing us me yeah i've
seen that i've seen him
that's the guy i'm talking about
and that was like
80
1984 or five around that time
yeah he's doing some kind of little
fashion show
please expound on john gore's statement
punk was a reaction to the hippie
boomers
while i go to the bathroom okay yeah
punk was
punk rock was everything that
was anti-hippie
hippie was all kind of like something
came out of the 60s it was kind of an
age of aquarius
i guess you could say it was kind of the
pc of its time
political correctness
it was kind of like
free of free love
environmentalism in a way
um
anti-industrialist returning back to
nature
kind of motif
um
peace and love and
uh getting along with your fellow man
like it'd be like saying diversity
it would be kind of it was just a lot of
platitudes of the time
in a way it was the optimism
the uh
the the hippie movement
chill out
do some psychedelic drugs
search for like your inner peace and
meditation
timothy leary type [ __ ]
punk rock was actually the opposite
of that
it was more like uh nihilism like [ __ ]
it there's no hope
um
more kind of like anti-social
more like
yeah [ __ ] nature that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
that's played out
trump i'm trying to come up with some uh
some good john lydon or johnny rotten
quotes
okay okay somebody some woman mentioned
something about
sex and having sex and [ __ ] john
lightning because that's disgusting
[ __ ] sex was just
uh
anything that was uh
anything that was natural
it was just kind of like a rejection
[ __ ] it yeah it was it was just
nihilistic yeah
basically right
um in the sense that it was just trying
to like tear down established yes
and norms
where it it was just like i don't want
to say it was reactionary but it was
almost kind of like they just wanted to
be or you know they were just
contradicting everything and honestly
musically
i think it was almost more a reaction
yes it was a reaction against hippies
but it was almost kind of more reaction
against prog rock because i kind of feel
like prague rock had kind of become
really popular in the 70s like late 60s
early 70s and even though a lot of punks
were like were into that when they were
younger i kind of feel like they were
kind of rebelling against
this
thing where everybody had to be like
super musically proficient
and
so the thing about punk that i think a
lot of people
relate to and certainly what i liked
about it
was the democratization
of music like you don't have to be
pretty you don't have to be musically
proficient you don't have to sing well
you just have to have the right look the
right attitude um you you know in the
right presence
and you can still make good [ __ ] so to
me that was kind of like i liked the diy
aesthetic of it i liked the creativity
of it because i kind of feel like for
you know particularly for a time and
like i said that's why i'm saying
notably like prog rock because it was
something that
those you know the people in prog rock
bands very musically proficient and i'm
not [ __ ] on that because i like some
of that too oh yeah they were great so
but yeah
punk was kind of like look anybody can
do this you don't have to come you don't
have to be rich you don't have to go to
musical school you don't have to look
good you don't have to have done all
this stuff you can just put out the
records yourself we're just going to put
it in a [ __ ] sleeve and draw on it
and
you know and it's still just as valid
right so i think that's what a lot of
people related to and why it was like
such a big [ __ ] cultural
deal and i would say that
i would say that at the time old people
like my grandparents generation
they would have seen hippie
stuff as
counter culture
the punks saw hippy stuff excuse me
they would have saw okay my grandparents
generation would have saw hippies
counter culture
the hippies would have saw [ __ ] punk
rock as counter culture it was against
that all right
somebody said hold on who is this um
adriana goes nick cave did heroin
[Laughter]
that there was hardly any left for
anyone else he did all of that he did
pretty much he's all over all of the
heroin
yeah and he lived to tell the tale how
do you think and honestly it's so skinny
right and he's still looking pretty good
he's like he's probably pushing 16
huge junkies but uh well yeah
at one point and honestly one thing i
admire about nick cave
is that i've read an interview with him
it's it was a few years ago it's before
his son died and everything like that
but he was kind of like
he was like look um
i know that people want me to come out
because i had some uh experiences with
heroin like obviously at one point he
was arrested for heroin and said look
you're going to jail unless you go into
rehab and so he's like okay fine i'll go
to rehab that was right around the time
the good sun came out like in the early
90s and he's like and he had a real a
hard time
and uh so there was that but he did come
out later and he said you know all these
people kind of want me to come out and
say oh you know say no to drugs and you
know talk about all your experiences
he's like but you know i had a really
good time on drugs for a very long time
yeah he's like so
i'm not gonna tell people like not to do
them he's like because i had a good time
on there it's like you know i'm not
saying that people should do them yeah
i'm not do heroin he's like i'm just
saying that i think it would be
disingenuous
to be like oh it wasn't fun sometimes
because it totally was
i mentioned this on other shows i'm
gonna mention it again because we're
doing something about sid vicious
in the 90s there was a heroin chic
revival some people got sucked into that
bad [ __ ] happened
i'd be hanging out with [ __ ] john
john's whiz and the sleep chambers and
had these [ __ ] dancers they were
[ __ ] gorgeous i showed them on
another show
show
because some of their stuff is on
youtube
beautiful female fetish dancers
they were called the barbiturates all
right oh anyway they kind of should tell
you something they did so much backup
stuff for that act
had them over at my place one time we
were in another two story houses that
was the haunted one i've told before
that [ __ ] was weird
and john was over and [ __ ] rich was
over and a bunch of barbiturates was
over and there was one of them i was
waiting for her to show up you know what
i mean because
well you guys saw her i saw some [ __ ]
went down last time
i had saw her and i was like man she
shows up i'm gonna get lucky tonight
type of deal
and uh
she never showed up
and i can't remember what her name was i
think her name was sin that's what it
was sid this is where's sin and they
went
without missing a beat they go oh her oh
she died i was like what
oh no no yeah she's no like people died
yeah she died she died last week i was
like what what are you talking about it
was like three weeks and it's sorry you
know what do you mean she died
yeah she died what what happened
oh she od
and it was just like was nothing that it
turned around at god yeah yeah yeah she
got a hold of some good stuff well i
mean to be honest it happened a lot back
then yeah and she went right back i'm
gonna have a [ __ ] show that video so
you guys understand the loss of mankind
this woman was gorgeous [ __ ] and she
could dance too
like she died and this is oh man
i mean well yeah i mean you said that
before but yeah but this is my probably
a different crowd tonight i mean on the
show go ahead keep doing we've known
people yeah that that oh deed yeah
um honestly it's kind of sad but
it's weird because a lot of people from
our generation like the generation
before that were like into you know the
po punk and post-punk scene you either
died super super young
or the [ __ ] seem to live for [ __ ]
ever and they're just like just kind of
just preserved yeah you know what i mean
most of them died young i'm not gonna
say that uh but
if they did manage to get through it
then they do seem to live a long time
yeah so it's like just it's one of the
other there's like no in between but
like i said we've known
a lot of people yeah uh
that yeah i mean i knew a lot of people
that was her
that died that died of uh overdoses and
it's just like
and nowadays i feel like it's not as
prevalent i feel like uh you know
there's no
i mean in in the goth scene in the punk
scene [ __ ] like that in the late 70s
early 80s i kind of feel like heroin was
like the big thing
uh some people were on speed like
amphetamines that was kind of a big
thing too but
um
i feel like nowadays not so much there's
really no one drug that defines it um a
lot of people each uh you know like i
said everybody smokes pot but that's
just that's not just goths that's kind
of everybody
um
honestly most of the drugs you see
nowadays are more like you know
molly yeah
[ __ ] like stuff that you can kind of
come back from it's not that bad but
yeah or ecstasy type [ __ ] i showed you
guys who it was i was talking about
and it was just like
months after that
for nothing
yeah no reason just
well as i said taking a [ __ ] drug i
kind of feel like uh yeah
adriana says i thought nick cave did
antidepressants but never saw him as a
heroin kind of guy he was absolutely a
heroin kind of guy um
yeah he did he was uh pretty sure lou
reed he was kind of a drunk too uh nick
cave when he was younger
uh but yeah big heroin addicts like i
said he actually had to go into rehab or
they were going to put him in jail and
that was like late 80s early 90s inside
inside information i heard earlier
years and years ago so was susie but she
kept it
as i said it was very prevalent um i
would not be shocked that anybody that
was into the punk or postponed scene
even if they weren't really known for
being a druggie
like nick cave was known for heroin iggy
pop known for being a heroin addict um
even though like cheryl said he's still
running around uh you know and still
looks pretty good he looks like an old
man but he looks like a skinny like
pretty spry old man yeah and like i said
nick cave
he's looking pretty good too even though
he's got to be in his 60s by this point
iggy pop probably also heroin
oh definitely definitely as heroin um
well and like i said it wasn't just
heroin and honestly with sid vicious it
wasn't just heroin either they were
doing pretty much any drug they could
get their hands on it was usually just
heroin that killed them that's what it
was uh but they were not shy about
whatever anybody
and honestly like watching the
interviews with some of the some of the
people that were in the scene at the
time they're just like you didn't even
ask like somebody gave you a pill or
something like that you just took it you
didn't ask what it was you know what i
mean it was a different time
which
i was you know
i never did that but
uh but i know a lot of people did and
amazingly amazingly a lot of them are
still live although like i said i guess
i shouldn't be shocked that like people
gen x and stuff like that are
maybe dying off kind of young
because of that [ __ ] i don't know like i
said i didn't really even start drinking
and [ __ ] like that until i was older so
i didn't do a lot of the [ __ ] in my
teenage years i drank a little bit my
teenage years but not much uh but yeah
so uh
okay so the sex pistols had formed in
1975. now sid
again didn't join the sex pistols until
later so 1976 he actually uh co-founded
a band called the flowers of romance
he was a singer in that and played the
saxophone i don't know how well he
played the saxophone probably not very
well considering how well he played the
bass which was not well at all
but flowers of romance also contained uh
keith levine who was one of the
co-founders of the clash
and viv albertine from palmolive so
again he's very up in the scene he's
like all of these uh kind of people
now he did learn to play bass sort of
by listening to
the ramones
um
but it seemed and that's i'm not
i'm not [ __ ] him like i said uh it
seemed that he just learned the bass
line to one ramon song and just said i'm
just going to play this bass line
i mean it seems easier right
it's like it's a bass
it's only got more strength
so uh i'm just going to learn this one
song and i'm just going to use this for
other songs that let's i kind of feel
like that was maybe his attitude about
it uh so yeah so but he learned to play
from the remotes
now as i mentioned uh sid vicious big
fan of the sex pistols and he would go
to pretty much all of their gigs
june 1976 he goes to
uh see one of their gigs at the 100 club
now this guy named nick kent who had
played in the sex pistols like early he
wasn't with them anymore but he had
played with them earlier
um he actually went on to become a music
critic for the nme actually quite famous
i mean i knew his name for real because
i was you know
all up in that kind of british music
journalist kind of thing so i know all
their names and stuff because i'm nerd
like that
um
he was also chrissy hein's boyfriend at
the time
so he was at the show
uh apparently and uh also supposedly he
was in sid vicious's way and sid
couldn't see
so he decided uh sid was high as [ __ ] uh
on amphetamines at the time
so he decided he was going to take this
motorcycle chain that he always carried
with him apparently featured on the
great rock world swindle and yeah and
beat the [ __ ] out of uh out of net cat
with it yeah so uh he decided to do that
so even though this was kind of a big
enough deal to be in the papers nobody
got charged with any crime at the time
so
but he did like apparently beat the [ __ ]
out of a guy with a chain so there's
that
now
the flowers of romance this band
um they didn't ever do any live shows
and they didn't actually ever make any
records
but uh some of their songs that they
wrote actually were performed later by
other bands so they are kind of iconic
in that sense and like i said there were
kind of like people that became famous
later on
um
at this point uh and this is something
i'd totally forgotten about until i
started researching this again hold on
one second
granters are saying punk was a
reputation against brit rock fans like
the rolling stones kinks the who et
cetera i would say only halfway
more against prog rock bands like alan
parsons projects pink floyd even though
john lyden secretly [ __ ] had a lot of
respect for pig floyd pig floyd but you
couldn't say that you could say lose all
your credit right
in some ways the bands that you just
mentioned
borrowed a lot from from punk rock they
would have never been
a thing without punk rock like
punk rock is where the edge came from
for the in the british new wave
and there are some there is
early early [ __ ] stones [ __ ] that was
never recorded just
rumors of what they sounded like before
they were recorded
sounded like the sex pistols evidently
they sounded like punk rock they were
real raw
in the 60s well [ __ ] man if you listen
to [ __ ] that came out in the 60s yeah
like american [ __ ] uh you know like
[ __ ] the stooges yeah uh i mean
that's punk yeah
and there is some there is some stones
tracks that man there's so goth it's not
even funny like [ __ ] painted black
very [ __ ] goth uh there's uh sympathy
for the devil has a weird goth undertone
to it there's a lot of [ __ ]
that stones had that had a darkness to
it
that's why it's i always kind of feel
like it's hard to pinpoint yeah where
punk is a genre came from because like i
said you had the late 60s you had bands
like the stooges or the mc5 or velvet
underground who had uh very obvious yeah
punk or goth
uh sound to them like if you listen to
it nowadays without any context
people would be like oh that's a punk
band or oh you know my favorite goth
band which have been the old sisters of
mercy
with the original band
like first and last noah's album
andrew eldridge says that that album was
a new interpretation of what the rolling
stones were doing well and they covered
they covered rolling stone songs yeah he
was super into the rolling stones
so
goth was very punk
inspired in a certain way
it was a different interpretation and
it's punk classed up some and i kind of
feel like punk at least as it came from
[Music]
say the ramones
who were you know early 70s
the ramones i kind of feel like what
they were trying to do
was i don't even think they were trying
to like make a new genre they were
trying to go back to like rockabilly
they were trying to go back to like old
simple yeah um you know just simple
songs that were just like a few chords
and just simple lyrics and were just
catchy
and it was kind of seen as revolutionary
in that uh you know cultural context
yeah you know what i mean
um
so the british new wave was still very
punk and the american response to the
british new wave was still very punk
um
duran duran which is nowhere near
well it's the opposite of what punk rock
was punk rock was duran duran would have
never happened without puck rock
no from the same scene
yeah they were like yeah we're punk rock
but let's pretend that we have money
yeah let's dress up pretty there's like
pirates and stuff we're gonna be on
we're gonna be on yachts drinking this
with these beauties like because punk is
fun but nobody wants to like have like
live in a [ __ ] squat somewhere with
no electricity
but they all came from those same clubs
yeah what i mean duran duran came from
they were also very grew up very working
class very art school they were uh they
came from birmingham and uh they were
hanging out more gl it was more glam but
like i said early goth
punk took a lot from glam that was like
new york dolls and [ __ ] like that billy
idol
was
knew the sex pistols knew susie knew the
new [ __ ] the guys from the cure
he was that same thing but he's like i'm
gonna take that and move to new york and
become a biker from mississippi
and that's what billy idol was that's
why he's got
that's why he's got
motorcycles and harley's and [ __ ]
flying the [ __ ] flag of the
northern virginia army it doesn't have
anything to do with the the south or
[ __ ]
the civil war per se it's just he really
liked elvis in the south and
rebellion as i said
you got the same thing since we were
talking about nick cave earlier you got
the same thing with uh you know his very
early post punk band the birthday party
which is actually one of my favorite
bands of all time
who they're from australia
but they so they're it's their own
interpretation of american
southern southern blues blues right yeah
mixed with mississippi del punk right
and it's and i find that really really
fascinating like mixed with all the
drugs yeah as i said earlier
because they have a very very
distinctive sound so you might have some
people in new york and california says
what the [ __ ] these second rednecks in
the mississippi and louisiana and
florida what do they know about punk
rock oh no
i don't know
south was very punk rock through the
eyes of people that were from outside
the united states they saw it for what
it was
watch i'm gonna give another plug to
white lightning watch the movie white
lighting well it's any kind of like
outsider outsider stuff like poor
people that are just like these hard
scrabble lives like outside of the
mainstream like around the fringes so i
kind of feel like punk rockers could
like relate to that yeah and then anne
rice comes in with her gothic ass and
makes it vampire gothic the south the
south becomes a vampire
and then poppy zebra picked that up
right ran with it right
transsexual vampire
sure yeah there was that whole thing
yeah i mean that was that's a whole
[ __ ] scene that's a whole [ __ ]
thing yeah
uh john gore says the car's first album
was way more punk than what came later
honestly um
yeah because i do kind of feel like sad
and this is another thing and we've kind
of talked about this before but like
when the early 90s came along and
remember when like nirvana got super
popular and everybody suddenly just
decided or said like realize that punk
rock existed even though the rest of us
are kind of just like yeah welcome to
the club like 20 years too late or
whatever
um but yeah so when when it went
mainstream it was just kind of lame but
then like afterward
you got these kids that were gonna like
hot topic and [ __ ] and they were talking
about like bands like green day and like
blink 182 and [ __ ] like that
like they were punk bands and like the
old [ __ ] wasn't punk anymore
and i'm not [ __ ] on green day i
didn't mind green day i actually saw
green day live before they got popular
like before uh dookie came out like they
were just like a college band like i saw
them at like a university campus or
something i don't remember what year
that was maybe my sister went but um you
know they're they're a good band but
honestly if you're gonna be real into
music like at least kind of know where
the [ __ ] came from
or if you don't know where the [ __ ] came
from then at least keep your damn mouth
shut about it don't go around saying
like blink 182 they're like the first
punk band because that is absolutely not
true and everybody should shed will
should brightly like shout you down
about that stuff cheryl was saying this
uh she thought the stooges were the
first punk band honestly i mean they're
in the in the contention for sure
because if you listen to a stooges album
now
that absolutely sounds like punk rock
absolutely and that was
late 60s
um same with velvet velvet underground
had more of a gothy thing
because they had more of that drone they
were so they were kind of more like a
person a post punk or the first goth
band
um especially with nico singing that's
yeah mary
i mean her album the marble index which
i think came out in oh i want to say 71
but i can't remember
uh that is very much a goth album forgot
to tell you our friends of starry night
are doing a uk tour soon uh they are
[ __ ] special guests of clan of zymox
[ __ ] great band and [ __ ] maybe
maybe we'll post
uh did you do the poster or somebody
else do that poster for that tour
because he posted a uh it's probably
okay i don't think that was me okay okay
we'll put
maybe we'll post something in uh data
stream for uh uh on on
uh what you call it for tour dates
because i know we have some uk
listeners and if you guys want to meet
friends of ours they will be there yeah
they're opening for uh glasgow
um
glasgow glasgow okay
they're doing um
bristol
and uh there was like two other [ __ ]
uh
uk
locations but it sounds like it's going
to be good that i would love to see that
show those [ __ ] better record that
[ __ ] and just send that to me they will
i would love to fly there no those
[ __ ] need to fly me there
to go to those [ __ ] ask them see how
that works out
they wanted me to manage that [ __ ] for a
while but i was like man
yeah fly pay you to fly me over there
and like uh buy me a hotel room yeah and
i'll manage you you know man no they
don't need management now they don't
they don't imagine that um
dj maniac says blixa wasn't in the
birthday party was he no uh he was in
the bad seeds later
if you don't know who he's talking about
he's talking about blix of bargail from
einsteirson and noy belton who was also
in who's a rad dude and uh he was in
uh
he was in nick cave's later band the bad
seeds but no he was not in the birthday
party um
and then mango says nirvana the band
that ripped off killing joke they ripped
off killing joke and they ripped off the
pixies so you know i'm not mad about it
i don't mind nirvana but
it just kind of made me angry that
because i remember first hearing that
nirvana song because i think they had
their first album bleach i think
somebody gave it to me like before they
got popular
and because back then i was broke so you
had to like kind of have
friends that could afford to buy records
every now and then would tape them for
you so uh so i did have the first
nirvana album
but then when never mind came out and i
heard that first single off it smells
like teen spirit i was like that's a
pretty good song that's a good song and
then like literally like the next day
every [ __ ] in the world knew that
[ __ ] time yeah and i was just like
well that's i recognized it right
honestly that's the end of that
and look we're talking about albums
we haven't mentioned it so far in this
song we're gonna get back to the sex
pistols the sex pistols [ __ ] really
only had two albums and only one of the
albums was kind of like a normal release
album and it is a classic it was called
never mind the bullock's politics
let me [ __ ] spot let a [ __ ]
talk i'm gonna say bollocks okay but
that's not how
i'm gonna say though okay
i'm not aligning i said i'm living down
to bollocks here's the [ __ ] sex
pistols all right now that's a [ __ ]
great album it is
by today's standards a normal
hard rock album
with real trashy
vocals that sound great really good
lyrics
wicked bass lines sid didn't play those
bass lines then [ __ ] could not play
that bass all right sid did live
performance and so he didn't play on
that record he didn't play on that
record i think
paul cook did all that [ __ ] he played
they let him play bass on bodies
but then steve jones over dubbed it okay
all right so uh sid vicious is not on
that right he's not on that [ __ ] no but
it doesn't matter okay it's a [ __ ]
great album
uh and then they came out with a double
album it was called um the great rock
and roll swindle where they troll you
through the whole thing but it has a lot
it has good songs on it a lot of people
don't like that one as much
i liked that album it was a double album
wouldn't it or was it a single album
that opened up
yeah see a lot of mine opened up well
yeah a lot of them had that gatefold
yeah it opened up and it had a dead deer
with a bunch of arrows stuck in it mango
says it's bollocks i know i could yeah
i'll [ __ ] you you can't tell him
anything [ __ ] y'all all right
he's not allowed to be wrong i'm from
mississippi
i [ __ ] i i have my own interpretation
of bollywood testicles
bollocks yeah i got it i got tons of
them i got tons of them wait how many do
you have tons of them he has tons of
toughness got tons of ticks yeah you
heard it here first i ain't saying i
ain't seen [ __ ] around these [ __ ]
come on you just did though
maniac i have tons of tapes maniac
your memory is probably better than mine
was that an album a double album
or was it a single album that opened up
i haven't heard it in years yeah see i
don't have that one i have never mind
the bollocks but i don't have rock and
roll it was good you opened i know but
it had a bunch of cartoons taken from a
movie like a little movie that they did
or uh
it was like a little movie kind of like
a uh what do you call it
and like uh uh
the sex officials made a little movie
had malcolm mclaren in it yeah what what
do you call it not not a movie a um
it was a movie-like product
like a historical documentary yeah it's
like a documentary
it's a movie
yeah and it had had uh there was some
cartoon sequences sequences of [ __ ]
sid vicious
wearing a [ __ ] swastika t-shirt and
his leather jacket well he wore that in
a real life because there's
there's photographs of him wearing that
yeah okay
you people can't understand that it was
susie used to wear like nazi [ __ ] too
but they weren't nazis though no the
whole idea was just to be deplorable to
the maximum it was it was all
provocations
yeah they just wanted to wear something
that was like as offensive as possible
because they wanted to provoke a
reaction it's the kind of [ __ ] that is
needed in the world today it's whatever
you they were they would try to [ __ ]
soil every sacred cow you believed in
that's what they would go after
so now it would be i don't know the race
they would go after that they would just
anything then it was just pushing your
[ __ ] buttons
they didn't believe it it was just they
wanted to see you blow up yeah they just
wanted to make people mad and if you and
if you beat them up they didn't care
they would they would love it they were
you know they were psychos but i mean
kind of cool i mean sid in particular
yeah
i mean
he seemed to enjoy getting his ass beat
it was a true counter culture and i will
say too and you know many people in
their circle have said this malcolm
mclaren
who was their manager yeah his whole
thing was he wanted to provoke as many
people as possible so he would do [ __ ]
on purpose yeah
um you know he would hype set up to do
that kind of [ __ ] he would like he was
the one that set up that whole tour of
the sex pistols when they came to the us
and they toured all those like redneck
joints in the south he did that on
purpose
they were they were touring texas
and they had [ __ ] it was it was a sid
or was it or was it [ __ ]
i think it was sid sid was up there with
a [ __ ] white t-shirt
with two gay cowboys rubbing their dicks
on each other and they were like
illustrations of cowboys like from a sex
comic
yeah and he's showing that to a [ __ ]
well and he he would go to like redneck
bars and he would like on stage and he
would on the stage he would call them
like [ __ ] like cowboy [ __ ] yeah
yeah because yeah in new york and in
urban more urban settings
the cowboy motif was a
was a sexual a homosexual sexual fetish
you know what i mean gay got gay muscle
dudes dressing up as cowboys taking
pictures
for more information
muscle guys dressed up as cowboys doing
each other and you make a lot of money
on that all right so
they would go to texas and [ __ ]
confu and [ __ ] accuse them of
basically being gay porn stars that's
basically what for the cultural
equivalent and they knew full well
like i said malcolm mclaren did that on
purpose for provocation purposes right
and sid vicious for sure and i'm sure
like most of the other members also knew
that it's like well we're going to get
our ass beat but that's just
right that's what they did and that was
the genius behind punk rock music and
the sex pistols what all marketing man
whatever sacred cow you musicals
that's what they would attack
and they would got free publicity all
throughout and they didn't care if they
were hated or disapproved of they didn't
care if they went to prison or jail
because they ended up doing that some of
them they were in the papers they made
money yeah they didn't they didn't give
a [ __ ] they did not give a [ __ ] they
would laugh at it and if you beat them
up they just laugh at it they didn't
care nope there was a certain strength
to them you know
and yeah you couldn't really [ __ ] with
them because they didn't have any shame
and they didn't have any fear nope the
[ __ ] wouldn't bathe
okay they kicked one dude out because he
kept bathing
i don't know how i extended that but i'm
gonna arrest you but i don't [ __ ]
bathe you know but those dudes are
[ __ ] nasty tom had to make sure that
you guys know that uh john gore says i
never saw urban cowboy with john
travolta worth seeing ah well
it was all right
it's
in a cheesy
way
and i wasn't talking about urban cowboy
i said midnight cowboy that's a totally
different urban cowboy is a totally
different type of movie midnight cowboy
is a it's a totally different kind of
movie so uh so yeah but urban cowboy is
i haven't seen it in a long time i
remember it being fun in a in a cheesy
sort of way uh midnight cowboy is kind
of more it's fun for a little while and
then it gets like super depressing
but uh yeah so
where was i all right so
sid vicious like i said uh he had done
this he was in this band the flowers
were romance uh they didn't do any live
shows they didn't do anything like that
but they kind of got known in the scene
because
you know some of their songs were
performed by other bands uh who were
around at the time however
uh at that point and somebody brought up
the damned uh who are actually one of my
favorite bands of all time i [ __ ]
love the damned
um
thank you vandal cabbage72 y'all are the
best keep doing what you're doing thank
you very much that's very very nice of
you vandal cabbage 72 is that because
you were born in 72 because so was i i
don't know if that's why you put 72.
might just be random
um
so at this point uh the members of the
damn they didn't have a devenian yet as
their singer
so apparently legend has it
that sid vicious was also under
consideration for being the singer of
the damned again not because he was a
great singer or because he could play
because
not really but he did look good and that
was kind of what mattered
so uh so basically uh
what happened was
they told him to come for like a you
know an audition
and sid didn't show up
so obviously so it went to davinian
now later sid said that oh well they
lied and they told me that the audition
was like a different time or a different
place or something like that because
they really didn't want me i don't know
if that's true or not but like i said
that's kind of how the story goes but
dave vinion ended up being anna's doing
it you're all the best keep doing what
you're doing i love you bub
[Laughter]
i'm gonna do some sid quotes so that
they don't ban me i got some said quotes
that'll get you [ __ ] rolling i just
don't want to give i just don't want
[ __ ] susan wizinski or whoever who
owns [ __ ] youtube banned my ass for
saying it he says some crazy [ __ ]
it was funny though and it was kind of
there's an element of truth to a lot of
[ __ ] that they said they would see
things for what they were and they would
[ __ ] dumb it down to the masses and
troll you with it
that was what they would do
i mean the thing that i think people
liked about it was because they just
didn't give a [ __ ] they didn't give a
[ __ ]
okay i'm gonna throw it at you
queen was in studio [ __ ] recording
one of their albums and
[ __ ]
the sex pistols were in there recorded
too as sid busts into the [ __ ]
recording studio when queen is in there
and [ __ ] freddie mercury was singing
and he says
so
have you clearly succeeded in bringing
ballet to the masses
i don't even know if that's true but
that's still pretty funny
well no that was according to the queen
the band members of queens said that and
then they they they beat his ass and
kicked him out
because he was a little bitty
yeah he was a little he didn't weigh
nothing
have you
succeeded in bringing ballet to the
masses
the thing about it though i mean
particularly when we're talking about
sid vicious it's like he was probably so
[ __ ] up most of the time he didn't
even know what he was saying
i bet you john lyden put him up to that
[ __ ] because i don't think he had the
intelligence to come up with that [ __ ]
as an original material that was
something john lyden said go ask them if
they've succeeded in bringing ballet to
the masses
the thing about sid i don't know
i'm not saying he wasn't kind of an
idiot because i think he was i'm not
sure he was as dumb as people thought
that he was you know what i mean i think
he was like pretty average intelligence
i don't think he was like
i think he was below average it's just
the thing about it was that he was so
[ __ ] up all the time yeah that
probably people just thought he was dumb
because he was just like so [ __ ] on
drugs most of the time that he was just
like sitting there like well he was dumb
because he was young too
you can't beat that that's when you're
that you when you're there you you know
so it's like i'm willing to get people
john lyden made up
because he was only like [ __ ] 19 or
some [ __ ] like that it's like everyone's
an idiot when they're 19. john lyden had
a lot more in intellectual intensity
and i think he put him up to that
you know that sounds like something he
would have done that does sound like
something that's because that was yeah
go ask them if they bring if they
brought ballet to the masses yet well
and as i said
one thing and this is something that i
kind of read between the lines of some
stuff that i read about the sex pistols
was that as i said malcolm mclaren who
was their manager
um his whole thing was provocation so he
didn't really care and
honestly you could tell sid to go do
something [ __ ] up and he would do it
so malcolm was like always kind of like
hey why don't you go do this thing or go
cut yourself with a razor or something i
don't know if you told him that but he
was like just told him to go do [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and he would do it cheryl thinks
that it was freddy mercury that told
that story i think it might have been it
might have been yeah because i have
heard that story yeah but
that's a good one so like i said even if
it's not true i succeeded in bringing
ballet to the masses yet
i'm so conflicted because i like the sex
pistols and yeah the [ __ ] queen
[ __ ] genius
i like both of them freddie mercury for
different reasons but mercury was one of
the best live performers ever
[ __ ] watch that live aid live
performance they've got that [ __ ]
remastered on youtube
where he condenses that [ __ ] down into
like a cabaret show it is [ __ ]
awesome he doesn't even bother finishing
the songs
he'll do another one bites like two
minutes ago okay [ __ ] that let me go
around to the next song
he was great mango says i can't recall
what freddy called sid it was great
though yeah [ __ ] or something you know
yeah
i mean
you know it was the whole thing and like
i said there's a lot of myth-making
around it too well they were all
personalities for the time
sure but i'm sure that did happen i'm
sure they did that yeah that totally
yeah
but yeah so
uh had sid vicious showed up for his
audition apparently he could have been
the lead singer of the damned but
apparently the damn wouldn't have went
anywhere
probably not gotta say because dave
vadian
not only looked hot as [ __ ] he could
sing but he could [ __ ] sing yeah and
he had good eyes he can still [ __ ]
sing yeah
i have a couple of their new albums and
they're still pretty you guys don't know
the damned get an album called
phantasmagoria
and uh it's kind of like a pink floyd
album of the gothic world very good
album very good
fun fact
that woman that's on the cover of
phantasmagoria is now nick cave's wife
yeah she was in um an interview with a
vampire wasn't she oh i don't know i
thought maybe she was an extra in the
cemetery scene in france wouldn't she i
don't know i thought she was she's the
model so she very well might have been
yeah i thought she was in there like i
said that's uh that's nick cave's wife
though what was her name um [ __ ] i can't
remember good looking woman she is yeah
and she doesn't look that much different
i haven't seen her in a while but um i
think last time like i said you might
remember her name last time i said well
i'll probably remember it like later on
but last time i saw her in the press was
when their one of their sons died
do you remember that and when was that
2016 2017. they had twin sons and they
were like 15 or 16 and one of them like
[ __ ] fell off a cliff in
bristol or some or yeah
it was an accident yeah
and uh yeah it died that's it's [ __ ]
up cheryl agrees that that sounded like
something john lyden would say yeah i
think that sounds like something he
would say he would come up with
something witty like that i think he
came with something witty and said sid
and said sit in there to [ __ ] say
that mango says freddy called sid simon
ferocious that's right i had to look it
up yeah i remember seeing that interview
that's right simon ferocious
that's actually a better name why didn't
somebody why did somebody like some punk
rocker i think freddie would have been
forgiven as sid because as cute as sid
was freddie probably would have cut him
some slack
he was just a [ __ ] cute idiot this is
what he wanted
yeah i kind of feel like he's kind of
like freddie's type i thought yeah he'd
have been like all right i'm into that
uh but yeah
so um
yeah cheryl says uh
that um
that sid wouldn't have been right for
the damned yeah i agree i mean honestly
no
man i said like i said i still love the
damned and i love that they started out
as like just uh they started out as a
punk band yeah um you know and their
early punk [ __ ] is good like new rows
and all that
and uh but then they later kind of went
into
like a more goth direction and a little
bit of a psychobilly like much later
they kind of went into more psychability
well i thought their punk rock was
lukewarm good but lukewarm oh i like it
yeah i like all that [ __ ] sex whistles
were better
ah
but i also liked hardcore stuff like
exploited i really i did this yeah i
just wanted yeah and honestly i even
liked i liked a lot of uh american
hardcore uh like your dc [ __ ] like minor
threat and stuff like that uh i like all
that even though it's it's still punk
but it's like a different it's a
different sound i'm kind of i like all
that kind of [ __ ]
uh the only uh
i kind of soured on punk later when it
went more in a pop punk direction yeah
uh which
which i didn't love but all that old
[ __ ] i love all that stuff
um all right so where was i oh and i
even like all that old like uh all the
old like punk goth like crossover [ __ ]
from la like 45 grave and all that
island adriana's in there [ __ ] giving
hearts black hearts to dave vane and
carl mccoy and all these hot goth
hotties it's okay it's all right girl we
you know
oh i get it they're out there you know
jenny gets it i understand it i get it
yeah i understand it honestly uh davey
like the damned were on the young ones
yeah in the early 1980s
playing a song called video nasty yeah
and uh man he looked so good he was like
covered with cobwebs and he had that big
[ __ ] all that black back combed hair
with like the white stripe in it like
the bride of frankenstein is so [ __ ]
rad he looks really really good i love
that episode
that was from [ __ ] 81 or some [ __ ]
like that i remember that episode yeah
i think i think the episode was called
nasty but the song was called video
nasty but i'm not really sure
did they ever release that on an album
like i have it like i have the song on
my phone but i thought that might have
just been
like a single or something i don't know
if that was on any of their albums or
not
uh okay so
later on so we talked about the damned
uh late 1976
sid vicious and i talked about and i
mentioned this earlier he shows up with
susie and the banshees he played drums
at their first gig
at the 100 club that would have been on
oxford terrible
yeah i don't know if he played drama any
better than
i don't know how that went this is not
the susie that you know the early early
susie had no musical training she was
not a polished act that wasn't until
much later she ended up becoming one of
the best
new wave slash goth acts of all times
[ __ ] susie was the [ __ ] role model
the model
female for all goth females how to be
was started with susie
she invented the goth look in a certain
way i would say yeah i mean she took
inspiration from other things yeah uh
you know particularly like night time
notifying that [ __ ] and stuff and you
know like vampire and stuff like that
but yeah yeah i mean that that look was
iconic and honestly she started out well
like a lot of other uh you know that
would later be iconic musicians
following the sex pistols around yeah
following the sex mrs brown
she did a lot of [ __ ] that television
appearance where [ __ ] the sex
whistles were [ __ ] up [ __ ] with
that dude she's in the back always
wanted to meet you what's the name
[ __ ] uh
boy i didn't see that thing on on
youtube
but uh susie was uh
ended up becoming one of the one of the
key players in the goth scene one of the
best gothics of all times
talented talented musician
great performer
madonna just ripped her off madonna
isn't the american ripoff of susie
but much much later
[Laughter]
much later the the more basic version
yeah
mainstream basic version
the original was susie dj maniac says
have you got a video yes we've got a
video yeah i remember that episode i've
seen i've seen every young ones episode
about a zillion times i think i have
them all like memorized but that was my
favorite one because the damned were on
it
uh that one and the one where they were
on university challenge i mean that one
[ __ ] killed me and that had like some
famous people like emma thompson and
[ __ ] like that on it before they were
super famous
uh okay so
so yeah so he's playing drums at the
first susie in the banshees gig so
there's that
uh the next day the damned were
performing with davian so apparently
like sid was upset about this
uh because i guess he wanted to be in
the damned uh he was very drunk and he
was very high on speed
so he threw his glass at dave bainian
but he missed
uh the glass broke against a pillar and
blinded a woman
uh in
the crowd so that's it permanently
uh i don't know okay so sid gets
arrested and he gets put in jail for
that uh he wasn't in there very long but
yeah
now uh at this point so it's february
1977 malcolm mclaren kicks glenn matlock
out of the band
out of the sex pistols
he says it's because glenn likes the
beatles
glenn said it was because no i quit
because i was sick of it i don't know
which story is true uh you know malcolm
mclaren has been known to like you know
make up some [ __ ] like again myth making
but i don't know which one is true so
glenn matlock leaves he was the bass
player
so uh at this point
um
it's kind of like
as i mentioned earlier malcolm mclaren
was very much
he wasn't really a band manager i mean
he had a store
and
he was kind of like he just wanted to
make headlines so he didn't really care
if they could play or whatever he just
wanted to get in the papers so whatever
it was that they would do to get
attention
he would encourage them to do that
so he thought
that if glenn matlock left and he got
sid vicious who already kind of had a
reputation in the scene if he got him in
the band and could encourage him to just
be like drunken on drugs all the time
and do crazy [ __ ] then
you know then they would get a lot of
attention from that so
i kind of feel like
um
you know
that's kind of why he wanted him in the
band like i said he didn't give a [ __ ]
if he could play he looked good and he
was a [ __ ] up person and would do
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and if you asked him to
do [ __ ] up [ __ ] he would do it so
you know
again he was just trying to get press
um
so at this point
uh john wobble actually said i found
this uh quote on wikipedia john wobble
said
sid was offered up as a sacrificial lamb
by the people around the pistols meaning
probably malcolm mclaren mostly
none of them would have gone over the
top he was their kamikaze pilot and they
were all too happy to strap him in and
send him off so like i said he was so
[ __ ] up on
drugs and you know he was just drunk
most of the time and he would just do
crazy [ __ ] without much provocation and
it was getting them attention so
that's kind of i think that was the main
reason that malcolm mclaren wanted him
in the band so that's what they did
so uh so he joins the band march 1977
they get signed to a m which again a
rather large uh record company
so to celebrate this they trashed the
offices of a m records
and then they had a party at the
speakeasy uh which was kind of like
a club that a lot of sort of like london
music industry insiders uh hung out at
so while they were all at this party
they ran into this guy who uh named bob
harris who was actually the host he was
a bbc dj and he was the host of the old
gray whistle test which was kind of like
a big deal it wasn't like top of the
pops was the stuff that was like in the
charts whereas old gray whistle test was
more like stuff that wasn't in the
charts but it was more like you know a
music show that was to highlight stuff
that wasn't in the charts
so they come up to bob harris
and uh they're kind of like well when
are you know when are we the sex pistols
gonna be on your show
and uh apparently there was a little bit
of confrontation a little bit of a bar
fight going on uh and at this point so
they're like starting to hit each other
with broken bottles
and sid apparently uh
broke a bottle and stuck it into the
face of a dude that worked at the bbc
like a recording engineer named george
nicholson
uh at this point like that guy gets like
pulled out by some other like musicians
that were there and then there was like
a whole big fight i don't think it was a
riot but it was just like a big bar
fight like it was a big brawl uh the
cops had kind of like uh you know
cordoned off the whole block or whatever
uh none of the sex pistols actually got
arrested in this situation but
because it was kind of such a big deal
a m
uh dropped the sex pistols uh you know
avoided their contract and at that point
like capital radio which was kind of
like the main uh radio station it was
like a national radio uh they said okay
we're not allowed to play play any sex
pistols music on any of your stations
now because they were causing such a
[ __ ] problem
uh so there's that
now sid uh ends up playing his first gig
with the sex pistols in april of 1977.
uh and this was actually recorded if
you've seen the uh documentary punk rock
movie which was done by don letts uh
he's in that so that's like the first
time he played with sex pistols
uh obviously like i said he couldn't
really play
um and
on the first album we mentioned this
before they did let him play bass on
bodies but uh it was later overdubbed by
steve jones because apparently sid
didn't uh do that well
so summer of 1977 it was july
sex pistols turn up on top of the pops
and i kind of feel like this was like a
big [ __ ]
i mean i remember seeing footage of this
this is a pretty famous uh situation
so top of the pops that was kind of like
the indication that you'd made it into
the british mainstream like everybody
knows who you are
uh for this point uh sid did not come
so glenn came back and played bass uh at
that show because sid couldn't be
bothered or whatever right on heroin
well that yeah they said most of the
time well actually at this point um he
was he had a hepatitis c probably from
intravenous drug use yeah which a lot of
people uh get you know from that and uh
so he was kind of in and out of the
hospital a lot at this time so they're
like not only was he not on top of the
pops but he also didn't show up to a lot
of their rehearsals and a lot of the
recording sessions and [ __ ] like that
like you know for very soon he was
either on drugs or because he was in the
hospital with appetites so uh there was
that
now as i mentioned uh you know yeah he
had gotten really into heroin at this
time uh and his mom was usually the one
that procured it which is really [ __ ]
up
but
they were both addicts that yeah so
there so there was that she gave him
[ __ ] heroin for christmas
yeah that's kind of like yeah yeah
which i can't even imagine what it must
be like living in this don't have any
goddamn sense man
you're a [ __ ] pharaoh
she got addicted he was important it
became a priority he got addicted he
goes it was a priority so they're just
like yeah okay here
it's cool here you take it don't tell
nobody
like smokers giving each other
cigarettes that's what you know yeah
which i mean that's weird too it's not
weird it's not as weird as like giving
someone heroin obviously because at
least cigarettes are legal social stigma
yeah yeah
cheryl says top of the pops is a weird
show it is honestly one of the things
kind of low budget yeah
it is but
of its time of its time you know what's
strange that i always thought was
strange because i've seen a lot of top
of the pops episodes they always make
you um
lip-sync yeah and then the weird thing
was that new order when they were on the
show yeah they absolutely refused to lip
sync yeah
and so when they're on this so if you
see their pr their performance of blue
monday on top of the pops it sounds
awful yeah it sounds awful because they
absolutely refused
and i think some bands that actually
kind of had some integrity like wouldn't
go on there because they're like we
don't want a lip sync in the u.s we had
something like that it's called solid
gold
yeah that's right i forgot about that
the main attraction to solid gold was
the solid gold dancers yeah no one gave
a [ __ ] about the bands they just they
just they honestly honestly sporty [ __ ]
they didn't even have the bands on there
did they i thought it was just they just
played them and then they just had like
hot girls like dancing it was kind of
like casey kasem's [ __ ] show of
[ __ ] yeah like the top 40. the top 10
of the top 40 and they would do these
stupid ass reenactments using these
[ __ ] smoking hot dancers for the time
all these girls [ __ ] on anavar and
implants and [ __ ]
yeah at least they had meat on their
bones
that was the first time they started to
bring they were going away from the
skinny cocor look to the [ __ ]
kind of pumped up [ __ ]
booty look you know what i mean which
was effective and that was that show was
a hit but it was a hit and the way jerry
springer was a hit
i remember watching it sometimes yeah
there's nothing else on trail you're a
captive audience yeah i mean i wasn't
super into like a lot of chart music
right but you know you'd kind of walk if
it was on you'd be like okay that's a
good sign i've gone watch i've gone back
and watched all the classics on top of
the pops [ __ ] billy idol [ __ ] uh
damned
everybody [ __ ]
and uh it's just a cheap low budget
well as i said they didn't really have
to they had to look like well i just
thought it was very weird because
they're like well look like you're
playing live but it was like some milly
vanilli shakes yeah
it's funny they got iron maiden up there
doing that [ __ ] early iron maiden doing
top of the pops and then i kind of feel
like if you were gonna be like if you're
gonna stick to your principles like new
order did yeah and they're like no we're
gonna play live they're gonna we're
gonna make you sound as crappy as
possible then yeah because i mean okay
let's be fair
new order i love new order okay i mean
i'm more of a joy division fan but new
order are amazing they can be good um
yeah barney
not the world's best singer
but he made that work for him like i
said you don't have to be a good singer
you just have to have the delivery has
to be a thing yeah um but him singing
live on that top of the pops was just
like it it hurt me to like hear it
because i'm like
oh
it's like i know
uh
i don't know it just i i have a hard
time watching it maybe because i like
them so much i was just kind of like
i kind of wish you guys had just like
[ __ ] lipsticked and shut up yeah
you know what i mean i i just kind of
wish that but i will
uh yeah somebody said ed mcmahon i was
like yeah that wasn't solid gold yeah
that was star search
yeah mega remember solid gold i haven't
seen that in such a long time i'm sure
they're all on youtube now because
everything is
but uh yeah
so all right so at this point where are
we 1977. so this is where the fateful
meeting of sid vicious and nancy spungen
occurs we're finally getting to it two
and a half hours
nancy spungen uh she was an american uh
she's actually from philadelphia
originally
she is usually listed as a
amateur music journalist
also a drug dealer yeah hooker and a
hooker
sometimes
um
mostly i think she's uh they usually
call just a groupie because what she did
was she would follow rock bands and it
wasn't just them i mean she was a
bad company aerosmith
uh ramones new york dolls she so she
just kind of like followed them around
and you know they presumably had sex
with you yeah that was the thing and
like i said i you know i'm not
justifying like i'm not glad she got
killed or anything like that but
almost everybody that knew her other
than sid who apparently like loved the
[ __ ] out of her
um for whatever reason
pretty much everyone else
said that she was like intolerable to be
around yeah but as i said
that might have been i mean she had a
pretty [ __ ] up
life
right but um what
she was a star [ __ ] yeah that's what
she was she was a star you have to look
at you have to look at nancy from sid's
point of view he
he's a young guy he doesn't have a whole
lot of experience he's got a bad
upbringing he's got a lot he has a weird
codependent relationship with his mom so
i kind of feel like
because nancy in a way
she kind of was like his mom too like
she was she's older than he is
and she's
given him guidance
okay but it's guidance from the scene
it's not guidance from
back home or anything
so he i think he's kind of looking up to
her
and i do think that she was protective
of him
but i also think that she was
manipulating them she was using him as a
vehicle to her own
fame i think
but you know
and that was a super unhealthy
relationship yeah i think i think she
did [ __ ] love the dude
in her way yeah i think she did no yeah
no yeah he was a lovable guy yeah yeah
and from her point of view he would have
been in a dreamboat you know
although she actually tried to [ __ ] john
lyden first
apparently the story goes that when they
met there at a party
and she fell asleep between john lyden
and vicious and she rolled over trying
to get a jump on john stick and he said
no and so she just says like okay and
she
again that's the story but that's the
pecking order yeah
she's gonna try to go with the with the
with the with the front first yeah sure
the leader of it
and look man [ __ ] lyden was a [ __ ]
hardcore intellectual compared to to to
to sid
siva's kind of a beta in a certain way
you know he's going along with the flow
trying to put on a good show he's not in
charge of anything
so he's a beta
not to talk bad about he's young
he's young well and he seemed very happy
well he was on drugs most of the time so
he just seemed very happy to just go
along with whatever yeah whatever yeah
so but she's gonna go with one of the
bad leaders first
so she's gonna head right to john lyden
when he says no or johnny rotten you
know he says no she's gonna go okay well
i'll take this one i'll take the cute
one
that's well they were both cute in the
day you know just be honest they're both
cute guys but in terms of if you take
the fame away
and the [ __ ] um the whole sex pistols
thing away
sid vicious was cuter than john lyden
physically
yeah yeah so you know it's just yeah so
she's gonna he's gonna you know so she's
going from power to beauty you can say
that's that's that was her echelon she's
just trying to attach herself to that
band
then she's going to try to make this guy
a winner
that's what she was doing she was trying
to manage him like a manager well she
did actually kind of later after the sex
pistols broke up she did actually like
get him some gigs she did act in a
managerial role of course you know and
she did help him uh she did give him his
look or help him with his look a lot and
really the iconic john the the the
iconic sid vicious look
was nancy that kind of helped him with
that
just you know it just was
thank you janet that's very nice of you
she says drinks thank you
thank you very much you know janet a
whole 25 dollars i know man thank you
very much crap we can have a lot of
drinks with that
but uh
from what i from what i've learned
through my studies it was and this is
john lydon that said that john lyden did
not approve of the waste sid vicious
dressed
he said it was goth and he didn't like
it
and he had gotten that from nancy
uh but i'm gonna call [ __ ] on that
the
john was right about a lot of [ __ ] but
he was wrong about the way sid dressed
sid [ __ ] had a better look than they
did was way hotter
look [ __ ] good okay i think i think
there might have been a little bit of
johnny rotten player hate even though so
big time
even though some of the some of the some
of the live acts that i've seen it
recorded with john when he had the white
shirt with the [ __ ] black vest on and
the black and the black [ __ ] leather
pants
john looked good too
but um but my take on that is that he
kind of [ __ ]
tipped his hat to the [ __ ]
sid vicious gothic look
okay i'm gonna do a little bit of that
too that's what i that's how i
that's how i interpreted it i mean the
thing about like john lyden back then he
wasn't a bad looking dude either no he
was good too he was a pretty good
looking dude too but i'm just gonna say
if it was me if i was like you know 18
years old at the time in the rock scene
i mean sid's like hotter sorry that was
physical although the thing about it
though was that yeah he was physically
hotter but would you really want to put
up with that for a long time because
yeah i kind of feel like he was such a
druggie and john and kind of a dummy and
john had wit and he uh yeah he might
have been a little bit abrasive at first
and kind of obnoxious when you first met
him
but according to people that actually
knew him that's not the way he really
was he was actually very sensitive and
thoughtful and very intelligent which i
kind of feel like a lot of the punk
rockers and gods and stuff like that i
think people have this perception that
that's the way they really are that they
were all these like really obnoxious
like but and a lot of them were not like
that though a lot of that was kind of
like a persona it was kind of like a
defense mechanism yeah for a host a
world that was very hostile from their
point of view sure and the world was
hostile from there forward if you were
getting stabbed yeah they were getting
stabbed so yeah it was absolutely a
defensive first saying crazy [ __ ] about
the queen
yeah and what
if you look at the lyrics of god save
the queen they were true
people couldn't handle the truth yeah
they made you a war big trouble for that
potential h-bomb which like i said has
no future now it's like not a big deal
but like back then it was a massive
[ __ ] deal like you couldn't say that
they were telling the working class to
downsize there's no future for you
okay and that's exactly what they told
him
and uh
the
[ __ ] the queen dumbed you down and
made you a potential h-bomb
and uh [ __ ] john as young as young as
he was was [ __ ]
dead on that's exactly what happened
well they kind of saw the thing that i
think was appealing about punk
particularly at that time was that it
was cutting through all the [ __ ]
yeah i mean it was just calling
everything like it was exactly what it
was which was something that hadn't
really been done yeah
right now everyone was just kind of like
pretending that things were this that
the other and it's they were just kind
of saying like no this is all [ __ ]
this isn't the way it is
and they were just coming out and saying
more money's coming i guess we're saying
the problem things that are thank you
thank you
oh yeah
thank you
i have to thank you for being so awesome
thomas jenny oh thank you so much
um look we got sid nancy in her little
icon oh
john goris says leiden had a simpy
mid-age crush on bjork so i heard and
that wouldn't surprise me
surprised me cute as [ __ ] was cute
honestly crazy
and crazy okay and uh uh leiden would
we're all into that crazy right yeah
honestly i was a massive [ __ ] fan i
like bjork's solo stuff too but i kind
of lost track of it in the 90s but i was
really into the sugar cubes yeah man the
sugar cubes were so [ __ ] good yeah
that saw him live
opened up for uh new order they were new
new order and uh public image limit i
remember that tour yep i remember that
tour yeah um
yeah it was like it was three it was
three big three bands and it was that
was a good show so i mean
pine knob theater so my uh my boy
[ __ ] knows exactly what i'm talking
about
life's too good uh it was such a great
[ __ ] album yep i mean when the sugar
cubes came out in 1988
nobody sounded like that nobody the
first time i saw the video
for birthday
uh in 1988
i was just kind of like what the [ __ ] is
this i was like this is awesome nobody
was doing anything like that in 1988
nobody
i mean now it might be like kind of
passive the sugar cubes were good but i
would think that some of the bjork's
solo stuff was a lot better that um it
got a little bit more purified and it
was uh
some of the [ __ ] was just very gothic
yeah she didn't go wrong honestly
i did like a lot of this kind of i mean
the first sugar juice
was really good this i bought the second
one but i kind of feel like there was a
little too much of um einar
on it like with his weird like chanti
he almost kind of like served the same
purpose as like fred schneider in the
b-52s but not as cool or almost kind of
like
like flavor flav from [ __ ] public
enemy he was kind of the hype man yeah
and i i didn't love it i didn't like it
i mean bjork was kind of the star of
that [ __ ]
but
i mean the slave jammed [ __ ] [ __ ]
public enemy would not be the same same
without the flavor but [ __ ] you know
it didn't work too well with [ __ ]
on [ __ ] sugar cubes to have a male
vocalist pop in and do do all that kind
of stuff and it was some of it was kind
of pro kind of rap
rapist yeah yeah didn't work that well
dj maniac said i never heard the sugar
cubes but i remember bjork being a huge
deal when debut and human behavior
dropped yeah i mean honestly i got into
the sugar cubes as soon as life's too
good came out because i saw the video
for birthday they uh she had been in a
band prior to that called cuckol
uh in iceland which didn't really get
much traction here until the you know
until uh the sugar cubes got big
but um so i never really heard that but
i had like that album i had their second
one i had like a bunch of our 12 inch
singles and the cool thing about the
sugar cubes is that every time they put
out a single
the b side would always be the same song
but sung in icelandic so i thought that
was kind of cool that they did like an
english and icelandic version
um but life's too good is a [ __ ]
great album yeah i [ __ ] love that yes
i love that album this is the green one
right yeah it's like neon green with
like uh pink on it yeah
um the one that i had after that what
was the one that came out after that i
remember it was kind of like it was pale
blue with like kind of it looked kind of
sci-fi i can't remember what it's called
i liked that i liked two or three of the
songs on that but i didn't love it
life's too good was
way better honestly the weird thing
about it
in apparently i you know i didn't grow
up in iceland so i don't know
but in iceland
apparently
a bunch of everybody that was into the
music scene in iceland which i'm sure
was not massive
they were all super into the fall um and
i really like the fall like you can
seriously like hear that uh that
influence
and
so i guess that like everybody like so
all of their
music
sounded like so [ __ ]
strange and it just sounded like but
awesome it was just something that
nobody else was doing they were just
coming from a completely different
cultural context but also kind of
filtered through
again like the fall who were a british
band but
they're a really weird british band so
it was just interesting to hear that
like juxtaposition of sounds but yeah
like life's too good is like their easy
easily their best album
uh dj says flave was the only reason
public enemy got signed because he was
the only one in the group that could
play an instrument
he plays about 15 it turns out which is
funny because
it's almost kind of like they relegated
him to like court jester status but i
don't know you know what i mean
it's just kind of like that
uh let's see um dj says oh i heard a
cover of cold sweat on a comp today i
mean cold sweat and birthday are my
favorite um songs oh deuce is good too
um but that whole album is good i mean i
listened to the [ __ ] of that out of that
back in like the late 80s it's like so
[ __ ] good i remember like you know
buying it as soon as it came out as soon
as i heard that song i was like oh my
god that's great and it's just funny
that bjork got so famous later cause i
was like
you never know what's gonna hit i would
have thought that [ __ ] was too weird but
i don't know whatever there's
no accounting i guess uh so yeah
so let's see where was i
hugo says first sex pistol song i heard
was who killed bambi it's hilarious yeah
that's off of uh
great rock and roll
swindle that was their second album and
some people say that that's not a real
album from them that it was kind of
pieced together after yeah it was which
there but the thing is is that it was
pieced together you still have people
playing on it you still have people
singing on it that were the the belson
was a gas that was a good song [ __ ]
which they're talking about the
belson was the guest belson was the
[ __ ] concentration camp yeah you know
they whatever was what
offensive whatever was whatever was
offensive that's what they were gonna
[ __ ] talk about which is like they
were like [ __ ] you
yeah they were just trying to offend as
many people as possible that was kind of
like the whole thing
uh so yeah
where was i okay so at this point yeah
so nancy's a groupie
uh she actually she ended up in london
because she had flown there with the
heartbreakers uh so she was like hanging
out with them in 1977. so let's go back
a little bit now nancy was actually born
as i mentioned in philadelphia
now uh she was jewish where's the
where's the uh cat treats she's asking
for um right right there
oh is it is it empty oh my gosh did she
eat all those yeah
she's like sitting over there going what
the hell it's like there's no treats on
this [ __ ] plate
now
nancy by all accounts when she was born
you know how sometimes babies are born
and the umbilical cord is wrapped around
their neck
um that happened to her so when she was
born like she was blue
and
you know normally they're like well
sometimes that causes like brain damage
now
the doctors at the time said that no she
seemed okay and like that they didn't
have any brain damage but
her mom and i saw like a little bit of
an interview with her mom
her mom said uh when she was a baby
she's like look i know babies cry and
[ __ ] like that but basically this kid
all she did was scream all the time yeah
so
they thought so the mom thought probably
there was something like wrong with her
like maybe she'd have like some kind of
oxygen deprivation or something like
that
so i don't i don't really know
um but doctors didn't notice it didn't
see any brain damage but i don't that
doesn't mean it wasn't it
now uh nancy did get like i said she was
a very loud child she was very combative
uh when she was 15 she was diagnosed
with schizophrenia
so again she
not having a good time she she had some
problems
uh she actually got uh kicked out of
college
uh and ended up flying to london as i
mentioned with the heartbreakers because
she was a groupie in uh 1976 tom betty
tom petty's band no different ones okay
yeah that was johnny thunder's okay the
heartbreaker okay
yeah that that's that's a totally
different tom petty's that was his
backing bay but there was another band
okay like a quasi i didn't know i never
heard the heartbreakers never johnny
thunder i don't know who johnny thunder
is but i don't know about that but you
don't know who johnny thunders is no i
know who johnny thunders is i didn't
know that yeah johnny thunder's had a
band called the heartbreakers
uh so she flew over there with them
uh as a groupie and that's where she met
sid
now
it seems
that
even though like i said
it seemed like this documentary that i
watched that oh cid was second choice
because she was actually after john
johnny rotten because he was like the
lead singer
uh but after he rejected her she was
kind of like okay well we're going to
the second one
but for whatever reason like her and sid
uh just [ __ ]
clicked man and
but the problem being that it seems like
the way that their personalities were
like he seemed by all accounts very
even though publicly
um you know he was always drugged up he
was always drunk he would do crazy [ __ ]
all the time he had violent tendencies
like he would get into fights and [ __ ]
but
if you were just like hanging around
with him most people said he was very
sweet he was very quiet he was very
soft-spoken
um
and you know he was just kind of like a
teddy bear type of dude like he wasn't
real uh obnoxious or anything
and i kind of feel like
nancy
on the other hand uh the best things
anybody said about her they said yeah
she was really intelligent and she was
very like streetwise
um you know she'd grown up
in philly she grew up in new york city
scene
and uh you know she'd kind of been all
over and hung out with bands and [ __ ]
like that so she was kind of like knew
her way around
um but other than that everyone thought
she was just as i said intolerable to be
around they said she was very brash she
was very abrasive
uh obnoxious she would if you made her
mad she would get like uh violent
uh she was very aggressive
and uh she was kind of like
she was she was kind of thing where she
wasn't getting all the attention she
would like do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] to get
some attention type of thing so there
was that i'm gonna show you guys
nancy okay just in case you have to see
who it is we're talking about
some people like what was he doing with
her
she was cute nancy was cute
she was just crazy but he was kind of
crazy too you know it's just she was
around and
there there was some attraction there
and they fell in together
it doesn't it i understand it you know
and i mean as i said it does kind of
feel like it was a little bit of a weird
like codependent relationship because
she wasn't that much older than him but
she seemed even though she i mean she
seemed everything that he wasn't she was
very outspoken she was very brash
whereas he was kind of more which you
wouldn't know from his image but he was
a lot more like
quiet
uh and kind of shy like around so
and he didn't have a [ __ ] ton of
experience with women
and he might have been attracted to her
because as i said he had a weird like
codependent relationship with his mom
and
he might have liked that she was bossy
yeah and that she was like managing him
and like kind of telling him what to do
and [ __ ] like that so he might have
i think he was responded to that yeah i
think maybe
there was that kind of thing that he was
responding i think she was giving him
some guidance
um now i will say that uh so it's not a
crazy match really
it wasn't crazy i mean it's just
that i'm sure that made sense if you
were there
especially if you were older than the
people than the witnesses
john lydon was like what the [ __ ] why
you know they were trying to throw her
out windows and do everybody they were
all trying to like they were all trying
to like yoko her yeah essentially yeah
it's it was a yoko but they're all young
people you know what i mean it was
if you were in your 40s or 50s it
probably wouldn't have been as odd it's
just she was just crazy
yeah yeah she's crazy but he was crazy
too you know
and to be honest um
this is not great but there was a lot of
uh domestic violence on both sides yeah
uh he would smack her around she would
smack him around uh so not great
hunk rockers though
they were just they just they were just
[ __ ] rough
you know they were [ __ ] rough people
and
it was kind of
kind of a thing of equality you know
what i mean
you said some crazy [ __ ] to me i'm
bitching yeah you know they just beat on
it they beat on each other
you [ __ ] up my lighting i'm sorry
about that yeah
you keep doing that you [ __ ] up my
lighting of my focus yeah
uh yeah so
as i said pretty much everybody except
sid seemed
to seem to hate her
and we're trying to like uh get rid of
her
now uh at this point so
the sex pistols uh broke up there was
all kind of like [ __ ] going on with that
and after that happened like the two of
them kind of went off on their own thing
so we'll kind of get into that in a
little bit but
after that happened they moved to new
york city and then that's what happened
what happened
um so as i mentioned nancy
i i kind of feel like she's
she's usually just called a groupie
which is what she was but she was also a
drug dealer so that's kind of i think
that's how she sort of ingratiated
herself into the scene that's why people
put up with her not just because she was
sid vicious girlfriend but also because
when she was living in london she would
like get all your drugs for all the
bands so that was her end
so yeah so everybody was just kind of
like well we don't really like her but
she's getting us our drugs yes so you
know
um and she again occasionally would work
as a sex worker she did like topless
dancing [ __ ] like that she was just like
trying to make money the way i heard
hooker though too well yeah well i just
said that um that she did was a
prostitute sometimes okay but um and
wasn't like uh ashamed of it either she
would tell people that but like i said
she did uh topless dancing also
um
so yeah there's one story malcolm
mclaren tells the story again i don't
know if this is myth-making or if this
really happened
but apparently they all hated her so
much
that at one point malcolm mclaren had a
couple of his like a couple of people in
the scene
kidnap her
and throw her in the back of a car
like in the trunk and take her to
heathrow airport and put her on a flight
back to the u.s you're talking about my
ipad so i'll put the eye patch on okay
um
yeah so that's how the story goes that
they actually had her in the back seat
of the car and they said well it didn't
work out because when we got to the
airport like she kind of came to or
whatever and jumped out the back and
there was a cop there and she said i'm
being kidnapped by the sex pistols
and so
i like i said i don't know if that's
true enough but malcolm mclaren told
that story like on a documentary that i
saw so they did apparently either they
plan to or they actually did kidnap her
and took her to the airport and tried to
get her to like [ __ ] leave the
country like and go back to where she
came from
because they were just like so sick of
her so it's like weird so this is
something that i that i found so
again they had a very weird relationship
uh
apparently
i found this very weird
apparently according to one of their
moms
nancy would cut sid's meat
for him like she would like
yeah so it's like this really weird like
i said it was a very motherly yeah
which like i said
the whole psychology of this is like
very strange to me but like i said i
think it kind of it makes sense because
of sid's relationship with his own
mother who by all accounts and like i
said this is people that knew both of
them
said that they weren't even like mother
and son they were more like buddies that
like
like drug buddies that hung out yeah um
so i kind of feel like he was just
approaching her the same way
i don't know so so he's like finding a
girlfriend that's kind of like motherly
in that way which is very very weird
they loving that i got the eye patch on
that i put the eye patch off
i even got the pleasant shirt on that's
right
yeah
um let's see uh where was i uh yeah so
we talked about
uh nancy being occasionally uh doing sex
work and that uh sid might have set some
[ __ ] up and maybe even watched they
don't really know
um maybe that was going on not really
sure
so uh at this point 1977 summer of 1977.
uh the sex pistols actually went on a
scandinavian tour and nancy went with
them uh so no one was happy about this
except for sin
now
in late october of 1977 never mind the
bollocks uh here's sex missiles came out
and they even though they the album
actually was not allowed to be sold at a
lot of places because of the controversy
particularly around godzilla the queen
which we brought up before
um obviously you ban people from having
some [ __ ] they're gonna buy some [ __ ] so
it debuted number one on the uk album
charts went gold on the 17th of november
which is like just a couple weeks after
it came out and it was on the charts for
almost a year
like all the people buying it so it is a
badass album it is very good i actually
really do like that fun album and it's
honestly so many people the sex pistols
even though punk had been around for a
while the sex pistols are obviously not
the first punk band by any stretch of
the imagination
but i think it was the
it was the album that like popularized
punk i feel like it was it was even
though there had been
punk bands before that
when that album came out and made such a
big impact everybody that saw the sex
pistols i mean the story goes everybody
that saw the sex pistols live like
formed a band which
is an exaggeration but not much
not much
um a lot of people that were at those
early shows went on to form bands these
members of joy division the smiths it's
like pretty much every it was just
yeah yeah yeah
but uh no and never mind the bollocks
you can [ __ ] watch it that's a
[ __ ] good you can listen to it you
can listen to that album [ __ ] over
and over and over again i did as a kid i
listened to it recently now this [ __ ] is
still good it's still good it's very
simple very hard driving
really good lyrics and [ __ ] john
lyden [ __ ] does great vocal work is
he just goes insane it sounds like he's
losing his [ __ ] when he's [ __ ]
singing
and the way mark mothers brow loses his
[ __ ] doing devos sometimes it's just
like he's on the edge of [ __ ] losing
it
it's just good it's a good album real
good
yeah and i mean i mean by today's
standards it's not all that quote
unquote hardcore and nothing like that
it just sounds like a good rock album
yeah good a good rock album with [ __ ]
weird [ __ ]
vocal work and [ __ ] great lyrics it's
good
yeah i still really like it way ahead of
its time i still really like it broke a
lot of [ __ ] broke a lot of [ __ ]
boundaries
and as i said even though they weren't
the first punk band they totally were
responsible for like popularizing yeah
for sure yeah because that album was so
massive and they were just like known
around the world really
so um i mean as as influential as they
were the sex pistols were not really
around they weren't together for that
long no um never mind the bollocks was
kind of like
their only really
real album while they were still
together
sid didn't even play on it uh even
though they told him he did but then
they fixed it later
um but it sold like a zillion copies it
was like this big cultural thing
so but honestly by the time the end of
like christmas of 1977 rolled around
sex pistols they played two shows uh in
west yorkshire
and those were their last performances
in the uk that was the last time they
were born there now as i mentioned
earlier in early 1978
uh they went on a u.s tour
now malcolm mclaren had kind of like set
this up and as i said malcolm mclaren
was all about provocation
so he's like well instead of putting you
in some you know cities where people
would actually know about punk rock and
would actually go see you like new york
city or somewhere like that
let's go and like these [ __ ] redneck
bars like down south
um and see what happens well the wrong
it was wrong timing it was
but he totally did that on purpose now
of course he totally did that
he was trying to get some headlines to
the [ __ ] the thing and it went about
as well as you would expect uh not very
well at all ces is in there saying that
she got she got [ __ ] um never not
never mind the bullets [ __ ]
stuck in her car [ __ ] tape player or
cd player to play it over and over again
for two years drove her crazy that's
[ __ ] funny
i had that happen one time i had like a
cd or a tape or something like stuck in
my thing and i just had to like listen
to it or burn over after a while like i
just kind of like i didn't hear it now
in the 70s the south would have not been
ready for the sex pistols they would no
they absolutely would have not even been
able to interpret that
they wouldn't have they wouldn't have
underst the concept of trolling was not
in the southern mindset of the 70s they
didn't they wouldn't have known what
that was
because everything was literal they
would have taken that [ __ ] literally
and then they're like what yeah and
[ __ ] them coming with the gay [ __ ]
cowboy t-shirts oh [ __ ] you'd have been
in big trouble and as i said sid
actually on the stage like called them
cowboy [ __ ]
and he got his ass beat but like i said
he knew he was gonna get his ass beat he
didn't give a [ __ ] evidently though some
of some of the southern girls the
[ __ ] were into it according to like
well i could see that they they they
understood that
yeah okay well it's a whole bad boy
thing yeah be into it yeah yeah so
they're playing in [ __ ] georgia and
[ __ ] like that and it's like yeah that
that went uh not all that well they were
probably still wearing [ __ ] like
bell bottoms and [ __ ] yeah this was
nice
you got early nights yeah they would
have been wearing [ __ ] big belt
buckles
yeah um can you imagine yeah the mullet
had not even been embedded in the south
in 78. well we've talked about this i
mean the mullet the mullet was
progressive yeah that was like a new
wave it was like new waves in the early
80s so it's like if you had a mullet in
the early 80s everyone would have
thought you were gay yeah
um and then who like who knew how that
would turn out but like yeah and the by
the time the late 80s early 90s came
around suddenly it was a redneck thing
you had to mull it that's because you
were listening to the journey you were
you you you had progressed beyond
country west we didn't stop believing
god damn yeah now you're listening to
journey and foreigner yeah yeah
and asia
remember asia yeah that [ __ ]
it's the heating moment yeah the heat of
the moat
i remember all that [ __ ] funny
whether i remember it whether i want to
or not this is what happens when you get
old yeah whether you want to or not like
you just remember [ __ ] you remember she
you didn't even like
from your like teenage years and 20s and
stuff it's like wow i wish i could
forget that [ __ ] so i could have some
like useful information in there but no
that's not gonna happen that's not
that's not how the human brain works
unfortunately now the southern mind
would not have been able to understand
that i can't imagine in early 1970s them
playing at some like podunk bar in
[ __ ]
georgia or louisiana somewhere oh man
and having the [ __ ] sex pistols and
having sid up there
cutting [ __ ] into his chest with a razor
yeah
the rednecks had been like what the [ __ ]
is even happening they wouldn't have
known what a sex pistol was
just the word sex in it would have
offended them sure and then when they
got there
i can't imagine although i have to say
malcolm mclaren
that was genius it was kind of genius i
mean he knew absolutely knew what he was
doing yeah
i mean he knew how to get headlines that
was for sure he knew it would go down in
legend
it was right it did
it did
you guys sit up there in a gay cowboy
shirt
yeah
like i said like he would he absolutely
did like at some of those gigs like he
would take a razor just like cut his
chest so
so he's right bleed
so again that's what i'm going back to
like sid would just kind of do anything
that you told them to hey do something
like really [ __ ] up
what we're talking about
you foreigners i don't know the north
of the united states had a gay scene
that was fetishizing
southern like
[ __ ] the southern look with like gay
cowboys
that [ __ ] didn't exist in the south no
[ __ ] if you took that [ __ ] down south
that would have been a direct insult you
literally could get killed literally
well some people did get killed yeah for
some [ __ ] like that this uh it was a
very different south back then
it was different people it was
pre-internet um it was a very low
information society
that would be like going to afghanistan
with a shirt with gay taliban on it it
would be like even though cowboys
weren't taliban just
but that's like it was a cultural thing
you wouldn't i feel like that's
something they would do on jackass yes
they'd be like jackass exactly and then
they would get shot straight out of
jackass they would have taken that as a
direct insult and [ __ ] you're lucky
you [ __ ] get her out of this [ __ ]
without getting shot okay
i'm actually shocked that none of them
did get shot yeah well because like i
said it's you know we laugh about it but
back then in those days that was very
dangerous uh yeah uh and you know it's
it's funny like to talk about it now
because they didn't get killed but you
absolutely could have and it did happen
like back then
not just like you know punk rockers you
gots whatever like gay people yeah they
absolutely did get killed get killed oh
yeah it doesn't have anything to do with
laws okay
law enforcement military operations
everything on mexi military if you're a
new listener
everything does it doesn't things don't
depend on law and systems everything
depends upon terrain
the southern terrain
and its population density
means that it's very hard to enforce any
kind of laws in most of it
not so much anymore you have urban areas
now most people are in kind of cities
and towns and
there's local locally elected law
enforcement but no man back in the day
no you could shoot somebody just walk
away from it
nobody would know and they did they did
it all the time
and he said well the guns are banning
guns they would not even give a [ __ ]
about that they cut your head off with a
knife or beat you to death with a club
or their fists or set you on fire
they did all that
you had to be careful back in those days
and these kids showing up doing that
[ __ ]
but kind of stupid i've seen the
recordings of it it looks like a normal
club event
um
i kind of have a feeling that the
southerners that were watching the event
that i saw recorded were amused they
were a mixture of amused and offended
but they were lucky that
that i i think they kind of thought it
was funny
or
or uh
they didn't see it as a threat i don't
think if it was a really threat that he
killed him
yeah yeah
yeah i mean maybe they didn't really get
it but they just thought oh maybe yeah
they're like uh whatever the [ __ ] is
this yeah
i think they knew it was i think they
knew it was some kind of a troll
i mean adriana says what was big in the
south back then the allman brothers
let's see late late 70s 70s
elvis
well i don't know i do kind of feel like
this would have been his time had kind
of passed yeah that's that was like
their grandparents at that yeah i kind
of feel like a lot of southern rock
southern rock leonard skinner almond
brothers
brothers uh doobie brothers yeah that
was that was more like your pothead
redneck thing yeah eagles eagles yeah
yeah you have to understand [ __ ]
the south
was not you even in the bible belt was
not real religious like a lot of people
think religion didn't have anything to
do with it a lot of them were doing
drugs
okay a lot of them were doing
weed and [ __ ] watched gator gator and no
actual white lightning
we talked we did reviews on those two
movies we haven't done games we haven't
done gators we just watched it last
night but if you if you watch white
lightning that's a very accurate and
fair portrayal of the south of the 70s
um
and it was made by southerners for
southerners and it's still entertaining
but that's a very good
uh impartial portrayal of the way that
it was
and then you watch a gator that's in 76
i think is when that movie was taken so
a year later the sex pistols would have
been there imagine gator the movie gator
with the sex pistols showing up it would
have been very shocking to them people
but
they were
from the recordings that i saw they kind
of thought it was a troll and they were
kind of get off the stage or they didn't
really know what's going on there uh you
guys suck whatever
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
but yeah so so they did all that [ __ ]
they kind of got their ass beat whatever
yeah
um they did a show actually in san
francisco
and at that show they had just given up
on any pretense of like actually being
an actual band at this point
um sid just kind of like stood there his
guitar wasn't even plugged in
uh johnny rotten started like losing his
voice and basically he was just kind of
like
he said something like have you ever
felt like you've been cheated or
something like that and they just like
left the stage and by that point they
just like [ __ ] broke up
now at this point just like less than a
week after this last show
sid gets on a plane uh and goes back to
new york now
while he was on the plane he apparently
like had somebody like [ __ ] supply
him some [ __ ] before he got on this
stuff because by the time
that he got off the plane he was so
[ __ ] up
on alcohol methadone to see they were
trying to malcolm
was trying to get because the other band
members and malcolm not you know i'm
sure everybody everybody was doing drugs
back then but they weren't
addicted the way sid was
so malcolm
mclaren
understood that sid had a problem
and he was trying to ration so he would
only give him like 14 a week to live on
because they were like making decent
money at this point
because they sold a lot of records and
whatnot uh but somehow even though he
only had 14 a week he was still uh
finding drugs somewhere so he was still
getting [ __ ] up on [ __ ] so it wasn't
super successful
but uh so yeah so he goes back to new
york and he had got some drugs he got
[ __ ] uh drunk he was so [ __ ] up
that uh he was basically comatose so as
soon as the plane landed they had to
take him uh in an ambulance they had to
take him to a hospital in queens
and the doctor basically told him look
you need to knock this [ __ ] off are you
gonna be dead in six months uh you know
just all the drinking and drugs and
whatever so he gets out of the hospital
a little bit later
and uh he goes back
to nancy
uh now at this point him and nancy uh
you know the sex pistols are broken up
and um so he's kind of at sixes and
sevens i guess so the two of them go to
paris
and they're filming the uh great rock
and roll swindle the mockumentary
and uh the whole time they were there
pretty much uh they were in their hotel
room just you know doing drugs
although uh they did actually get sid to
like off his butt long enough to record
a few songs
uh my way which we talked about earlier
something else which actually i quite
like that i like his cover of my way
also and uh come on everybody which i
think that's also a cover in it in that
um
[ __ ] man who the [ __ ] is that
i'll think of it in a second
um
eddie
[ __ ] i can't remember uh so yeah so he
did a bunch of covers
and uh
so sid though he goes to like record
these songs on this particular day
he gets back to the hotel room and
allegedly nancy was mad because she had
left because he had left her alone in
the hotel room to go off and do his
recording
so she had slit her wrists
not bad enough to like do any damage but
just like an attention seeking kind of
thing
which
you know uh that was kind of like
something they did a lot they had a lot
of um
[ __ ] up
suicide pact kind of stuff she was very
attention seeking in that way um
which is why i kind of i'm not gonna say
like i think she stabbed herself because
i don't know i wasn't there
but i'm saying that's not outside of the
bounds of possibility because she did do
that kind of grandstanding she did do
that kind of [ __ ] for attention um and
it's entirely possible that she did that
for attention not realizing how serious
of a wound she had inflicted because
they were so [ __ ] up i'm not saying
that's what happened i'm just saying
that's possible
uh so yeah
so then they went to london
and uh and then at that point they're
like okay well we have to go back to the
us because like i said nancy was
american uh but they didn't have any
money
now at this point they blen they bump
into glenn matlock who like i said was
the former bass player of uh sex pistols
and uh they were like well let's let's
play a gig together we'll make some
money
so
glenn matlock had formed his own band
after leaving this expos so called the
rich kids uh and so he had uh
rat scabies from the damned and a couple
of so they got sid vicious in there and
they called it uh the vicious white kids
and they did uh one performance at the
electric ballroom in camdentown that was
in august of
1978. uh sid sang at this he wasn't uh
he didn't play guitar
nancy also sang backing vocals
but glenn matlock uh told her she could
sing backing vocals but uh did not turn
on her microphone i don't i don't wish
i don't i don't know
i don't know what her voice sounded like
i mean that was something that they did
a lot like to sid they'd be like yeah
you can play on this but then they
wouldn't plug his [ __ ] in they wouldn't
plug in his amp or anything
um so i kind of feel like they just say
yeah sure you can like sing in the band
and then they would just go because you
wouldn't know you'd just be singing to
your microphone you thought everybody
could hear you nobody can hear you so
that's just kind of what they did i
don't know i don't know what her voice
sounded like like probably not good
probably not but they didn't like her so
that's kind of what they did yeah it
wouldn't matter if it was good or not
yeah
so uh so yeah so after that sid and
nancy
then went back to new york and then they
moved into the infamous room 100 of the
even more infamous chelsea hotel
now apparently they'd moved into one
room before that but started a fire in
there so they had to move them to
another room because what the [ __ ] is it
with everybody like starting fires at
the chelsea the chelsea hotel we should
do a whole show about that man
there's a [ __ ] hotel full of losers
well they were famous i mean this losers
there's all kind of like legendary
stories about the chelsea hotel like
[ __ ] leonard cohen wrote a song about
that [ __ ] with him and janice joplin
giving him a [ __ ] and it's like it's
a whole thing so yeah the chelsea hotel
is just one of those places that's like
iconic in rock music history so probably
we should do a thing about that
but uh yeah so uh so they check in uh
under the names mr and mrs john richie
and at this point like i said nancy was
actually kind of
doing managerial stuff she was setting
up gigs she was putting bands together
um
she got he played a couple shows like at
cbgb's and max's kansas city you know so
she was actually doing something
uh and she did sing at some of the shows
cbgb's in case you guys don't know it's
a famous new york club big in the
[ __ ] american scene eddie cochran
thank you
for having real good bands and dog [ __ ]
everywhere on the [ __ ] floor for a
while yeah i read the place too the
people that owned it lived there and
they let their dogs run around and
[ __ ] take a dump [ __ ] and they had
to clean it up but i was there in like
uh
97 or 98
uh
went down there from a vis it was when i
was living in boston visited it and it
was uh just kind of a live music event
kind of dead during the time that i went
in there
but i think it was back in 98
97 98
but you know i was i was uh happy to go
like okay yeah this is the cbg you're
talking about
i mean you got to see it it's famous
made great shirts i'm going to make a
[ __ ] cbgb [ __ ] bootleg shirt jenny
i mean you might as well they're clothes
now they're closed it was just a white
print on black on black shirt just like
everything else they drink something
okay
yeah yeah cbg bootleg shirt if you guys
are interested to drop it in the comment
section yeah we can make something and
we'll send it out to our [ __ ]
subscribers
so yeah so she did actually like put
some shows together and it had like
[ __ ] arthur cain from new york dolls
and like you know some other like you
know people that were famous in the
scene at the time
so that mick jones was there from you
know he was from uh the clash leader
and uh johnny thunders like i said from
heartbreakers and a lot of people did
show up
uh but apparently what was going on was
that sid he was singing as i said
and
a lot of people kind of accused him it's
like oh you're just trying to sound like
johnny rotten are you just like ripping
that off
um you know and
he would kind of get pissed off about it
like i said because he was usually drunk
or high or both and so there would be
like a lot of confrontation between him
and the audience there are some
recordings of that uh if you would like
to look them up
but uh yeah so they did get paid for the
[ __ ] so as i said nancy was actually
trying to do something to
manage his career even though obviously
they were both spiraling downward very
very quickly
uh nancy also said at this point and
like i said she's still uh she's quite
young too uh you know both her own poor
tequila in there oh yeah
i don't want that
jenny does not want tequila
um
so nancy was still even though they were
making money from the gigs she was still
kind of like hitting up her parents for
money
and she also told reportedly according
to her mom she actually told her mom
around this time that she was having
kidney problems
and um
she actually did according to her mom
say that she wanted her and sid to go
into detox or you know go into a detox
program around this time i don't know if
that's true or not but according to her
mom
nancy was apparently trying to get them
both off of heroin i don't know if
that's true or not
however unfortunately uh that's not how
the [ __ ] worked out as most people know
october 11th 1978
sid and nancy were having a party in
their hotel room uh room 100.
now during this party
sid apparently took uh 30
two and all tablets uh they're a
barbiturate barbiturate
um 30 of them
is uh
probably about three times well actually
maybe more than three times
what a normal but he had like a very
high tolerance uh so that probably would
have killed most people
uh didn't kill him though
so he took about 30 of those
now during this party
there were a bunch of people
just hanging around it was a party so a
bunch of people were kind of in and out
like throughout the course of the night
most people that were at the party that
they that were interviewed later
um
sid said uh said sid was uh pretty much
out of it most of the party like i said
32 in all tablets probably do that to
you that he was kind of comatose or
sleeping most of the time
now sometime during that night nobody
knows exactly what happened but
about 11 o'clock the next morning
uh october 12 1978
the hotel staff came in
and found nancy
dead on the bathroom floor
she had a knife wound in her abdomen she
had apparently walked into the bathroom
and just laid in there and died
now they did find sid wandering around
in the hallway of the hotel
now
interestingly okay now the wikipedia
page says
uh that he
claimed to have killed her
but a couple of the documentaries i saw
they talked to some of the investigating
officers or some of the police you know
that were first on the scene
one of the guys that would investigate
the case said that's he's like that's
actually not true he's like that wasn't
in the original police report
he's like what we found no what happened
pulling [ __ ] out of it oh pulling books
out he says that when they first got
there he was just wandering around in
the halls and didn't really know what
the [ __ ] was going on
and
he didn't say he had killed her he said
he didn't remember anything is what he
said
um so i don't know if that's true i
don't know if he initially said yeah i
killed her or i mean he said all kind of
crazy [ __ ] later on but
i think initially he said he didn't
really remember what had happened which
would kind of
i mean that kind of goes along with what
most people that were in and out of the
apartment uh or the hotel room that
night said because like i said they had
a party people had been in and out of
there all night
and most people that had been in and out
said well nancy was still alive at 5 00
a.m like they saw her alive at 5 am and
she was fine
um so it must have happened sometime
between 5 and 11 so in that six hour
period
but um
for most of that time i don't know what
happened after 5am but most people said
well sid was pretty out of it uh almost
all of that night like he was just
laying around like not really moving all
that much
now the murder weapon uh was a jaguar
k11 hunting knife now nancy had actually
given this to sid as a present uh just a
few days earlier they had a weird like
uh knife obsession you know they they
were cutters kind of a little bit yeah
kind of cut each other and make little
things yeah and yeah cut themselves yeah
that's cool
it was that kind of [ __ ] yeah
um it was part of their [ __ ] now
interestingly the the knife
was left in the room i think it was
wiped off
but they somebody left it i think it was
just left like by the door there was
like some luggage or some [ __ ] like that
and somebody just left it by the door
but it had been wiped clean of
fingerprints there was that
wait a minute how do they know that was
wiped clean well they're because there
were no fingerprints that doesn't mean
anything i know all about frankie well
no i'm just saying there were no
fingerprints on it so there's nothing
there assuming that it was wiped i don't
so don't don't i would not as a listener
i wouldn't
put much weight in that
because during during a forensic
investigation and you know i have i have
a
history
with working for companies that provides
support for law enforcement uh i happen
to be the louisiana state police a lot
of it
they'll [ __ ] try to find fingerprints
on [ __ ] when they don't find anything a
prosecutor will go away it must have
been wiped clean no
no sometimes things don't have
fingerprints on them that's all
even though somebody picked it up
because there's a lot of different
conditions it may have been fingerprints
on there for a while the person's hands
were kind of oily and over time
or the object had been oiled and the
fingerprints are lost or there were
fingerprints but you can't draw them
they don't have the technology to get
them off of there because there might be
too many oils involved
and it's it's a prosecutor tactic to say
it was wiped clean no
just means they couldn't pull a print
well now they did say that in the hotel
room yeah they did find the fingerprints
of six people yeah that had prior police
records that had been in and out of that
room that night for the party all right
so that's why there has been speculation
that maybe sid didn't because sid
apparently could not remember what had
happened
uh and some people have speculated that
it could have been
uh somebody else that was in the room
that night which like i said i think
that even if sid had gone to trial which
didn't happen
um
i think that his defense would have been
uh to able to like uh muster enough
reasonable doubt just because there had
been so many people in and out of that
room that night and there were some
other mitigating circumstances which
i'll get into in a minute which
could have suggested another scenario
that's that's what yeah
uh so yeah
so whether or not i don't know if
because you know the the cops said
different things you know some of them
said yeah he
initially admitted that he killed her
but then he admitted no i didn't know
what happened
um
one cop i saw like in a documentary said
no he never said that he killed he said
that later
uh at first he said he didn't know what
was going on he was just wandering
around
and that was that uh but uh regardless
sid was their only suspect
which seems i mean they probably should
have investigated this a little bit
better
i'm just gonna say because there were
some other possibilities going on there
but syd he was the only suspect he got
arrested he was actually charged with
second degree murder
now he did end up saying yeah we did
have an argument that night
but they argued every night that's what
i mean
there was a lot of that going on and
most people said that like and even when
they'd been at the hotel they said yeah
they fought all the time uh you know it
wasn't anything that was unusual
uh but sid gave them several different
conflicting stories uh at one point he
said yeah i stabbed her but i didn't
mean to kill her uh one said i don't
remember what happened
uh one time he said she fell on the
knife so he was so i kind of feel like
he was so out of it that he i don't
think he knew i don't think he knew what
was happening and honestly i think that
maybe that contributed to him because he
died not too long after this
was the guilt
of thinking that maybe he had done it
and just didn't remember
um but like i said no one was there so i
don't know if he did it or not i mean
there's a lot of other possibilities one
a big possibility is that she did it
she could have very well done it to
herself they were they were self-cutters
and stunters and emotional and
grandstanding and and
there's a good chance she's like you
[ __ ] you don't love me and he she
stabbed himself she's like what are you
doing you know
that could have happened you know
because i will say i mean she was only
stabbed one time yeah
she apparently stabbed herself in the
room and then walked to the bathroom and
then just laid there and bled
for like two or three hours
well it couldn't have been bleeding that
much because
no it was a long time but you can bleed
out all your blood in a few seconds
well it depends on where you're stabbed
yeah that's what i'm saying the fact
that she just stabbed herself which if
she had gotten to a hospital probably
would not have been a fatal wound at all
but the fact that she did not
feel the need to seek medical attention
yeah um she just wandered into the
bathroom and laid down and then just let
herself bleed to death over
several hours
you know what does that say it says a
lot of things okay i mean obviously if
sid did stab her he obviously didn't
mean to kill her because if he'd meant
to kill her he would have kept stabbing
her until she was dead yeah that would
have been manslaughter okay
um here's the problem he never would
have gotten a second-degree murder
conviction never
at worst it would have been manslaughter
where he stabbed her in an argument
and then she ended up dying from that
wound that would be manslaughter
if it was a murder and to get a murder
conviction he would have intended had to
have intended to kill her which i have
an absolute evidence does not dare i
absolutely do not believe evidence
if you know anything about killing
somebody with the knives and we've
talked about this on earlier shows to
kill someone with a knife usually
they're stabbed multiple times 30 40
times well yeah because you got to make
sure i mean that's [ __ ] up but and it
takes a long time to kill to kill
somebody like with a knife yeah and then
the other the other uh uh the other
thing that's just not there is that she
wasn't running she wasn't seeking help
or medical attention she
so she got stabbed somehow we don't know
but she didn't feel that there was the
threat to where she had to get out of
that damn apartment and seek help
so it just tells me that
there was some kind of an argument
where she was
stabbed either he did it or she did it
or something like i said somebody else
might have done it too there was a lot
of other people after after the stabbing
they chose not they chose
not to get help from the law or medical
so that tells me not murder
because they obviously whoever stabbed
her didn't really think it was enough of
a deal yeah she didn't think she was
gonna die and the brother person didn't
think that they were gonna die
um
knowing the way junkies are
she got stabbed during an argument
he may have done it
afterwards they're like oh [ __ ]
oh it's okay we'll be all right and and
then
they're like well let's take some more
smack let's hang out oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
won't stop bleeding what are we gonna do
oh i'm not going to the hospital we
don't have any money or
it might be i don't want to get in
trouble you know it's that kind of i
mean it very well might have been that
yeah right you know i don't want you
going
i could totally see that happening so it
might have been where nancy didn't want
him going to jail
so i mean she might have been i mean she
was probably [ __ ] up too and she was
just oh it's fine yeah it's right we'll
just hide that this happened
that's probably what happened
let's just let's just say most likely
what happened they were arguing
he may have stabbed her once and then it
was like oh [ __ ] sorry
and they're like oh [ __ ] yeah well [ __ ]
we gotta hide this
because they're high they're not in a
normal state of mind
yeah i mean they were incredibly [ __ ]
up yeah yeah incredibly [ __ ] up so i
chances are she tried to protect him
afterwards like well we can't go to the
hospital
and uh because i don't want you getting
in trouble it'll be all right it's just
a little cut
just a flesh weight yeah it'll heal up
and then they probably did some more
drugs
that's probably what happened the other
option is is that she was jealous and
got mad and [ __ ] was grandstand and
she stabbed herself and he's like what
are you doing don't do that which like i
said there was some president i should
do that there was some precedent for
doing that but either way it was between
a couple and i don't think there was
an intent or malice
not real malice or he kept stabbing her
ass he'd cut her head off that's what
i'm saying if you really wanted to kill
somebody you could just keep on stabbing
them you wouldn't just like stab them
one time and let them wander off and
then just be like oh well i'm not gonna
worry about it
couples fight they just do
um
it's normal uh now it doesn't normally
go to violence but you're dealing with
young punk rockers that who are on ship
and have no idea what's going on
uh and the evidence says that [ __ ]
nancy covered
what happened she tried to cover that up
it wasn't
it wasn't a uh
she forgave him it wasn't a big deal and
this was not a serial thing he was not
known for beating her up it was not well
kinda
he did kind of beat her up she beat him
up too yeah
punk rockers beat on each other but it
was kind of like
not serious it was part of being punk
rock
uh but she was never put into a hospital
or had blackened eyes or a bunch of
black and dyes all that well
what well no because she there was a
thing where she did actually turn up
like wounded sometimes like kind of beat
up
and for a long time she told her mom
that it was like her john's doing it but
then like later she told she was like no
it was sid so they're fine okay yeah
okay but
a lot a lot of people said that nancy
would beat up on him too yeah it was
mutual so
in this this goes back to kind of like
in the 90s
in the 90s [ __ ]
the goth scene which kind of came from
the puck rock scene wasn't
really gay or straight
its sexual orientation was bdsm
that was kind of the
but it was
not even so much that it was just
whatever yeah
it's still like that to be honest with
you yeah so
punk punk rock culture was it
it prided itself on being trashy and
rough
they didn't have the same moral
standards this
as that normal civilian population this
lawn biting was about i i don't those
two did not hate each other
they didn't no that was [ __ ] love
actually by all accounts and they looked
up and co-dependent as it was they
actually did seem to love each other
yeah well as much as someone is damaged
as they were right could love each other
yeah but it was kind of like that real
unhealthy like romeo and juliet kind of
all kill myself for you type of thing
they were young but yeah it's a very
young person they were very young which
i think is why a lot of people like
romanticized right yeah but like i said
you have to think yeah they were 19 20
21 years old which is very young and
back then you know emotions are very
heightened you're just kind of oh my god
if something happens to you i want to
die and okay i'll come you you [ __ ] you
right it's a yeah
it's that kind of it was that don't you
dare betray me all right
no everything is a massive deal yeah
yeah
and it's just kind of like drama queen
[ __ ] well everybody's like that
when they're young most people are like
that when they're young i mean once you
get to our age you're just kind of like
you don't give a [ __ ] about anything
anymore they pull knives out and [ __ ]
carve [ __ ]
carve names and like each other's names
into their [ __ ] yeah so you know
that's the kind that's the way they were
which yeah that's not good i'm just
saying that a lot of people did that
that whole scene was about pushing
boundaries yeah i mean they would
[ __ ] inject heroin knowing that that
[ __ ] was very addictive they would they
would do it um
girls would go out and [ __ ] turn
tricks knowing that that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] highly dangerous and very
immoral
but they were like yeah i don't care i
just need the money
you know it was very counter culture
well as i said counter culture
a lot of them came from really [ __ ] up
backgrounds right so they really had a
kind of nihilistic who gives a [ __ ]
you know they didn't really have much
i don't want to say they didn't have
much self-respect they didn't really
have much or they didn't really think of
themselves as very valuable they were
kind of wallowing in it so yeah so they
were just kind of like who cares what
happens to me
it was just it was that and i get that i
get that attitude um you know they're
trying to glorify it yeah
so i kind of feel like that was what
happened but yeah so
so whether said stabbed her i don't know
he didn't seem to remember
i think now
probably did i mean but like i said
they're 50 50 50 50. there could have
been some there were some other
scenarios that were possible so like i
said had i been on the jury i probably
would have let him off because
there were some other scenarios that
were just as likely i kind of feel like
uh but yeah so i definitely would have
quitted him for murder
yeah that was absolutely not yeah no it
wasn't intended it wasn't intended
um
the close maybe negligent homicide he
didn't get her help
yeah i mean at the worst yeah negligent
homicide is when you i absolutely don't
think that he meant to
hurt her or kill her or anything like
that i don't think he meant it even if
he did do it i don't think he meant it
negligent homicide is when
you're responsible for someone's death
by
by uh neglecting to act
yeah
she had been injured he didn't get her
yeah i could see that now negligent
homicide maxim will be five years first
offender would
year maybe and then some probation
you know if that first offender might
get probation for that
but chances are u.s court would have
given him a year
cheryl says it's incredibly hard to stab
someone to death yeah yeah usually got
to hit vital organs and this one stabbed
to the abdomen was totally something she
could have survived that's what i'm
saying had she gone to get help yeah she
would have lived yeah um but the fact
that she just got stabbed one time
whoever did it and just wandered off
into the bathroom and just laid there
and bled out for a couple of hours
did she actually die in the bed though
no oh she didn't die in the bedroom no
she died in the bathroom they found her
in the bathroom okay she actually walked
to the bathroom okay she was in bed for
a while and then walked on the bed yes
all right uh and that's where they found
her she was dead in there uh but they
they assumed they knew that she had been
in there for a couple of hours so she
had been bleeding out he could say that
i would say that
sid was guilty of negligent negligent
homicide failure to act
he didn't get her any help
um yeah but you could say well he had
maybe he had diminished capacity because
he was in in he was completely really
[ __ ] up yet but usually diminished
capacity [ __ ] the argument doesn't
work too well in court from what my
understanding
depending on how what the jury thinks of
you
i think he would have gotten about a
year and then and then he got a couple
years of probation which he'd [ __ ] up
because he was a drug addict
uh it'd been hard to straighten sid out
but he definitely wasn't guilty of
murder
yeah i absolutely don't it
absolutely was not no first i i even if
he did stab her which i'm not sure if he
did
um even if he never proved even if he
did i don't think he did it maliciously
and i don't really think he meant to
kill her or even hurt her they would
have never i just think they were so
[ __ ] up they didn't really know what
they were doing they would have never
been able to prove that he stabbed her
the only thing they could have been able
to prove is that he failed to act
knowing that she was stabbed
that's how they would have got him
and it would have been negligence
negligent homicide that's what i think
tammy points out when you're treated
like trash all your life it's hard to
give a [ __ ] yeah it's true
and i kind of feel like that's kind of
what happened with both of them and they
were getting famous by not giving a [ __ ]
because they were
so they were yeah so they were getting
like uh encouraged encouraged to be that
way to be that way which was probably
not good right uh so yeah so at this
point like i said sid gave a bunch of
different conflicting stories but at
some point he probably said yeah we had
an argument and i stabbed her
um i don't really remember what happened
all that good
now they did have uh
they went around to some kind of because
they had money like i said you know he
was a sex pistol and uh so they had and
virgin records was actually paying all
his legal costs still at this point
um because he was famous
so they actually did kind of approach
some high-profile lawyers so he got kind
of like a decent lawyer um not f lee
bailey they did approach him but his
kind of like a dude that was at his firm
or whatever
now they did actually get him
sid released on fifty thousand dollars
bail
the only uh conditions of that
were that uh he couldn't leave new york
and then he had to sign in at the uh
homicide unit offices
and he had to sign it at the methadone
center
uh so like i said virgin records was
paying i think there was an urban legend
going around that mick jagger had paid
his like legal defenses but that's not
true
virgin records paid all of his uh legal
costs far as i'm aware
now malcolm mclaren
has come out and said he absolutely does
not think thank you no need for me to
just because well thank you very much
that's nice
uh love kills is a great circle jerk
song i agree it is uh i love the circle
jerks honestly
uh malcolm mclaren um he absolutely did
not think that sid vicious uh killed
nancy
he thought that and this is something
that and somebody brought this up
earlier dj maniac brought this up
and this is something again this is a
possibility and this would have raised
some reasonable doubt in my mind
uh the knife was actually whether it was
wipe to print or not i don't know but it
didn't have any prints on it but there
were
again
six people's prince in the hotel room
that were known to police as in they had
police records
i don't know what the charges were for
those because they'd had a party so
people were in and out
sid and nancy um
they had a lot of cash on hand uh they
liked to be paid in cash so they always
had a lot of cash piles of it
so they kind of had a lot of it in their
room
so malcolm mclaren and some other people
have speculated that you know uh there
were a lot of people including uh this
dude who was like a comedian that lived
in the same building who went under the
name rockets red glare
uh he knew that they had all this cash
in their room
and he was there that night a lot of
people saw him so some people have
speculated that somebody else there
maybe him
uh that knew about the cash
maybe stabbed her and like took the you
know because sid was asleep
and so
there's a possibility because there were
other people in and out of there that
night and some people said yeah there
was like all this cash like in the room
and then later on it wasn't there
anymore i would like to see the
transcripts of the police i'm just there
so there's other like possibilities i
would like to see the transcripts of the
police interrogation
he said he stabbed her
i want to see what that's not what he
said at first i want to see what under
what conditions he said that he said
right
just because the police said well he
said he stabbed her i want to see the
actual trend that's what i'm saying and
it's honestly i'm not i don't entirely
trust the police because
you know he's a punk rocker he's famous
uh he had a reputation
uh for violence and things like that
and so i kind of feel like maybe he
wouldn't have gotten as fair a shake as
maybe somebody that looked like you know
respectable quote-unquote
uh you know and he was a drug addict
also
so i kind of feel like i mean they
didn't even look into
i think they like did a perfunctory like
interview of like other people that were
there at that night but not really they
didn't really seem to do much of an
in-depth investigation into other people
that were at the party that night
even though there were a lot of people
in and out of that room and there were a
lot of people that knew them that lived
at the chelsea
uh that knew that they kept a lot of
cash in the room for example i'm not
saying that's what happened i'm just
saying that's another possibility
somebody could have absolutely been at
the party they could have been [ __ ] up
themselves could have seen the cash and
be like you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna [ __ ] steal that and then nancy
maybe was like hey what the [ __ ] you
doing
and then maybe they stabbed her you know
it could happen could there's no there
has to be evidence no i'm just saying
that there's that's i'm just saying
that's another possibility i would like
to see what the transcripts or
recordings of what sid actually said the
cops are saying
well he said that he stabbed her at one
point
at one point but he said lots of other
things did he really say that or did he
say well maybe i stabbed her i don't
know or maybe it uh you know i don't
know if i stabbed her you know just
because the cops said that he said yeah
that doesn't mean that doesn't mean
that's what he said you know i got the
impression that that he didn't remember
yeah and that later on he was worried
that maybe he had stabbed her and didn't
remember it and that like upset him that
was the impression that i got
i don't think he remembered doing it at
all
oh i'm probably [ __ ] just super high
yeah so like i said there's a
possibility he might have but i think it
bothered him like the rest of his life
which was only like a few months uh
sadly but
i think it bothered him that he didn't
remember like what if i did kill her
because imagine what that would be like
if you were so [ __ ] up
god can you imagine like being so [ __ ]
up like drunk or on drugs or whatever
and then like your
you know your boyfriend your girlfriend
whatever like they end up dead
and then you're kind of like wait did i
do that and they're like you can't
remember and that will like [ __ ]
haunt you forever i kind of feel like so
i don't know so there was a lot of other
[ __ ] going on
now uh
effly bailey the lawyer
did actually hire a forensic
psychiatrist
and he interviewed sid
now
sid
during the first interview
uh they said he was really that what
preoccupied with whatever was on tv so
they couldn't really get much out of him
um
but they thought like his mom
was kind of in there saying we shouldn't
leave him alone she was afraid that like
he would do something bad because like i
said she she understood i think the
weird
codependent relationship that he had
with nancy and that like um
maybe something bad would happen now
that she was dead and that he couldn't
remember if he was responsible for it or
not uh and indeed
sid uh apparently later did break a
light bulb and try to slit his wrists
with it um later on
so at that point they have to come back
to the hotel they get an ambulance
and then
when sid saw the people from the you
know the the uh
the people from the ambulance he tried
to like jump out the window or like you
know ran for the window like he was
gonna jump out of it
and at that point uh they took him to
bellevue like a you know mental hospital
and then took him to like another uh
behavioral health center
and kind of kept him in there like under
suicide watch
for a while because it did seem like he
was trying to commit suicide so they did
put him under like mental health
uh watch
so they let him out of there uh november
26th and then he went back to the
chelsea
um
johnny rotten apparently tried to
contact him at this point
but his mom and malcolm mclaren would
not let him
uh at this point and i think you can
still see this on youtube i actually saw
parts of it earlier today
a british journalist irish journalist
named bernard clark interviewed sid
vicious
on november 20th two days after he was
led at the mental health center
and he said
that nancy's death was quote unquote
meant to happen
nancy always said she'd die before she
was 21.
and
i saw this part of it and it's actually
like he's pretty [ __ ] up you can tell
and
the journalist asks well where do you
want to be right now and he says
under the ground yeah i remember that
yeah
he wants to be dead yeah
uh because like i said as he seriously
did
yeah he was having some uh problems
now
uh so a little time passes not much time
but a little bit of time passes so sid
kind of goes back out until he's out on
bond
and he's kind of like dating around
hanging out in the scene again
uh so he was kind of seeing some
women
uh didi ramon's ex-girlfriend kind grip
who was one of them judy nylon another
one
uh michelle robison who was uh it was
her apartment that he actually died in
and he was actually seeing uh johnny
rotten's ex-girlfriend danielle booth
also on the side
now on december 5th
sid goes to a nightclub the hurrah
uh with
uh danielle booth
and a guy named david still who was a
photographer and a guy named peter cody
gravel who was a friend of his who also
gave him the drugs that
maybe killed him uh there was an
interview with him on the uh on the who
killed nancy documentary which is
actually kind of interesting
um also with them
was the comedian who i mentioned earlier
who went under the stage name rockets
red glare his real name was michael mora
who some people have thought that maybe
he was the one that stabbed nancy i'm
not saying that he's dead now so he
can't really defend himself but
um some people have speculated that
maybe he was the one that didn't like
stole the money of their room but as
like i said he i think he lived at the
chelsea at the time
um
so they all go out to this nightclub to
see skyfish the band
uh now at this place and like it now
remember sid is still
on i mean he still has a trial date
coming up for murder
at this point they just kind of let him
out of bond
so he's at this club
there's this woman there named tara who
was the girlfriend of patty smith's
brother todd
so sid starts flirting with this girl
she tells him to [ __ ] off he pinched her
and then at this point patty smith's
brother
uh says hey [ __ ] off
sid
breaks a beer bottle
in
uh
todd smith's face
it which
uh cut it open and he had to get five
stitches
now later the comedian michael mora
told the cops oh well um the guy like
provoked sid
and uh the bottle broken sids hands and
all these guys it was an accident
essentially it's what he tried to say
um
but sid who was essentially like i said
he's a waiting
for murder uh he's out on bond so
they arrested sid on december 7th and
charged him with assault
now uh
so this is essentially breaking the
terms of his bill yeah he's just go back
so they sent him to rikers island oh
[ __ ]
now he's in rikers island for a while
and uh obviously while he's in there he
can't get any drugs right so he's going
under detox and us and apparently by all
accounts was a completely [ __ ]
miserable yeah man
now january 8th so he was in there for a
while but more than a month
january 18th uh he shows up in court
and the judge let him out on ten
thousand dollars bail and actually even
reduced his previous bail conditions
yeah you still have to report to the
homicide unit but you only have to do it
three days a week now instead of every
day you don't have to go to the
methadone uh clinic anymore
the only condition other than that was
oh well you can't go to nightclubs
anymore that's what he said so they did
like let him out
now
at this point
according to the documentary he comes
out
of rikers island and his mom was there
and uh
his friend gravel was there also
now
sid
has not had any heroin for
more than a month and he is
flipping out
so basically
what i heard
was that his mom
to celebrate him getting let out
had got him some heroin
and they said pretty much from the
courthouse back to the hotel room back
to the apartment because i think they
went to michelle robinson's apartment
who he was like who was dating at the
time
um he was basically like did you get it
did you get it did you get it like he
was just like did you get the heroine
you know what i mean
so they go back uh they're having this
party to celebrate him being let out on
probation essentially
so they have this party
and his mom got him some heroin but
apparently it wasn't that good of you
know that good of stuff because it
didn't really do much of anything
so then his friend
goes out and gets him some good [ __ ]
right apparently
so gravel goes out he gets 200 worth of
the [ __ ] and then he brings it back
now a lot of people are here it was like
sid vicious it's michelle robeson who
was dating at the time his mom jerry
only from the misfits um howie pyro
who uh actually he was in uh the blessed
he was in degeneration he worked with
joey ramon and danzig and [ __ ] like that
uh genesis pierce all that stuff so that
guy was there also there was like a [ __ ]
ton of people there
so
uh so they gave him some of the good
heroin
um now
i'm not a heroin addict but from what i
have everything i've heard
if you are a heroin addict and you have
not done heroin for a very long time
very very dangerous
to do really really good [ __ ] or do a
lot of it sid apparently was not worried
about that because uh they gave him some
and he's like that's not good enough i
just like i need better [ __ ]
and uh so they did give him a little bit
more yeah
and uh so yeah so apparently they all
sat around doing a bunch of drugs um
until about three in the morning at
which point graval who had brought him
the drugs uh left he said yeah now at
this point jerry only as like i said
from the misfits he was also the party
he says that him and uh sid's mom we're
making food for everybody
uh and then he took off not too long
after that and then more people started
using drugs now
now most people said sid
when he got the good heroin like he
immediately had like a
a reaction to it like he started like
vomiting
and he was kind of like flopping around
and so they were just kind of like
trying to keep him awake and and he
seemed fine after that
um
and they were worried about him for a
little while because like i said he was
barfing a lot and you know they thought
that he was going to od
but he seemed to recover and then like a
couple hours later he seemed like he was
back to normal and then he was just kind
of like no i want some more at which
point they probably should have said no
but you know
um this is basically what happened to
that finance [ __ ] that i showed in that
video earlier yeah she got a hold of
something really good
pretty girls can do that
and it [ __ ] killed her
yeah well that's what happened with this
one too yeah
um
so
evidently uh somebody
i don't know like everybody has a
different story about this uh there was
a story going around for a little while
which i think later on kind of came out
that's maybe not there was a story going
around a little while that his mom
actually deliberately gave him an
overdose of heroin because
yeah because she thought oh well he's
not going to get off he's going to be a
murder charge and he's miserable i don't
buy that either
um but yeah that was a that was a story
that was going around for a time i'm
pretty sure people knew that he was not
going to get a whole lot of time
that was probably i mean he probably
would not have no that was not murder he
might have got some time but he probably
wouldn't have gotten i mean he wouldn't
have gotten
first-degree murder or even
second-degree murder i don't think no
worst case would a worst case would have
been manslaughter
and uh
mass slaughter can be very light five
years two years it depends on the
situation
i think they would have got him on
something more kind of lighter like
negligent homicide
yeah i'm kind of thinking it would
probably be something like because at
least they could kind of like prove that
they could prove that they could say
well this is an accidental stabbing and
he did not go get help for her
that would be negligence negligent
homicide yeah
and he'd got
first offender
maybe a year
two years maybe mid year if if not
probation but i probably would have got
a year or two
and then yeah it works yeah and then
gotten superlation when he got out
and uh his punk rock street cred
would have been magnified by getting a
year or two
he would have been a legend
his mom did not try to try to uh kill
him no what came out like later that was
kind of like i think the documentary who
killed nancy like this guy like had
written a book and kind of like put that
forward
and they kind of portrayed it but then
later on like many years later he came
out and said no that was [ __ ] i was
just trying to like get more money yeah
like from the book sales yeah no mom but
his mom wouldn't do that i mean his mom
was [ __ ] up i'm not gonna land he's
not trying to kill him though his mom
died of a heroin overdose yeah two like
uh many actually 2006 i want to say
maybe
and here's the weird
weird thing this was happening in a time
when the sex pistols career
possibilities were starting to expand
they could have been [ __ ] now the
band they could actually kind of broke
up they had broken up but it it would
have gotten back together it would have
uh they got back together in the 90s
they did that filthy looker tour right
i think sid vicious death
put the nail in the in that coffin for
many many decades
but had he not died they probably have
been together [ __ ] five years later
this just wouldn't have stopped there
have been a lot of bands that would have
wanted his name
well yeah i mean as [ __ ] up as he was
he was famous just his name would have
been enough sure
so no although honestly i wonder if he
hadn't died so young would he still be
as legendary
i don't know maybe i do kind of feel
like sometimes he'd have been like john
lyden
i mean sometimes if you die young
you know like jim morrison or something
like that yeah um
sometimes your legend is like gross like
much bigger than he would have been like
john lyden he'd been like johnny rotten
he probably just would ended up in other
bands not quite as good
i think you know the real talent if he
asked me was john
i gotta pee oh sorry
john john was a uh uh was was a much
bigger talent
but
maybe a couple years clean
something maybe would have changed with
sid maybe maybe he could have picked
himself up and come back
stronger
and uh not on drugs and uh maybe he
could have learned to play bass a little
bit which is not that hard to learn to
play bass somebody in a band could teach
you how to do it um and a studio
musician can do your tracks for you in
the [ __ ] in the studio
so no i think i think um had he not odd
i think it would have [ __ ] evened out
i don't think he would have done much
time
there's no way he would have been
convicted of murder i don't even think
he would have gotten manslaughter
he'd have to have a
a pretty [ __ ] up lawyer or a pretty
[ __ ] up jury
it would have been something else like i
said probably like negligent homicide
uh if he did get manslaughter it would
have been like uh along the lines of
vince neil i mean vince neil from motley
crew got a
got a mass daughter charged from you
know accidentally killing a guy with him
a passenger [ __ ] in a car doing a
drunk driving thing
and vince neal really
didn't [ __ ] i think it was vincent
wouldn't it man i'm kind of drunk now
but i'm pretty sure it was vic's fitness
his career really wasn't
was it [ __ ] neil who went to uh got a
manslaughter charge for drunk driving
and killed the guy uh yeah
yeah yeah i think it was vincent so i
think it would have been something like
that and that didn't destroy vince neil
it was a bump in the road but it
he you know it would have been like that
i'd be interested i mean obviously we're
never going to know but that's kind of
thing well because there is something
romantic
you know as [ __ ] up as that sounds
uh of people who die young why do you
think and i'm not saying that joy
division would not be as well remembered
nowadays ian curtis hadn't hanged
himself when he was 23.
um
but
would it have been the same because if
you're around long enough even if you're
a legendary rock star
with very few exceptions if you're
around long enough to see yourself
become
old and irrelevant
um
there is something to be said for
rock stars that die when they're still
very young
and very
uh
relevant
that you know you don't ever see them
get old and fat and
you know
and like
so there is something to that you always
remember them so you're always going to
remember sid
looking like a [ __ ] 21 year old
because that's how old he was when he
died bless you sweetie
pookie sneezed yeah it was a boy you all
right she's been sneezing a lot of the
last couple days i hope she doesn't have
a cold
but um
you know
you never saw him get old and fat and
bald
so
there is something kind of like roma
like i said it's just like jim morrison
you never saw him get old and fat
he's just you're always going to
remember him like that because that's
what he looked like when he died but he
didn't see him get fat oh that's true he
did that's a bad example he got fat he
did get fat yeah he got fit well he got
he got chubby yeah he got checked
uh morrison wouldn't have made it
not long term
uh his his music was good though
but it would have aged out
it would have aged out that's what i'm
saying so i don't know i mean the thing
about john lydon was that he was
actually music musically talented
and he went on
after the sex pistols and he went on and
did public image limited and he kind of
went on and did other like innovative
[ __ ] well john wasn't only talented he
was innovative that's what i just said
yeah he did like innovative [ __ ] yeah um
he was a dick but he was kind of cool in
a way yeah he would go to [ __ ] he would
go to [ __ ] talk shows
on
purposely to troll the [ __ ] out of him
and get kicked out
he did not like the corporate
media thing he just didn't like it
and uh
he was he was very contrary very
contrary to what was going on well
that's kind of his whole family yeah and
and and i like that he was critic
you know he's going to go oh you're
going to do that well i'm going to do
this are you going to say that i'm going
to say no
and uh i
i kind of like that kind of like that
was this that was his thing that was his
thing
uh yeah so
so we don't know so anyway that night
after that party uh sid
died in his sleep
so his mom and michelle robison uh found
his body the next day
nobody knows
uh who gave grivel says i feel kind of
partially responsible because i'm the
one that procured the really good [ __ ]
like the really good heroine uh he's
like i tried to
what he says he's like i gave him a
little bit because i was like dude
you've been in detox for like a month
and a half you really need to like take
it easy because this is really strong
and [ __ ] will [ __ ] you up and um so he
tried to like so he gave him some of it
and then the rest of it he gave to his
mom and it's like don't give him this
until like later because this is like
really powerful [ __ ] and you know i
don't know if that's true or not that's
what he said
um well junkies usually know what they
have so it probably was true it's just
that he had really lost his
tolerance and his receptors have all
been cleared out from being above rikers
island they gave him that [ __ ] they
[ __ ] killed him
because honestly that's the sad thing
the the second i mean according to them
they said the second he got out of
rikers i don't like his mom and gravel
were the only people there to meet him
apparently and that was the first thing
he said yeah was where is did you get it
he said to his mom because his mom
apparently told him i'm gonna get you
some heroin like when he could have he'd
been without it which like i said that
which would have been a perfect time to
quit but you know
the [ __ ] yeah you would think i mean
dumbass you already haven't had it for
that you just might as well just like
suffer through it but he wasn't thinking
like that he was thinking
i need to get it like right now i
haven't done it in like a really long
time so i was telling you people man
[ __ ] do not [ __ ] with the horse
heroin is like i said i'm it's not worth
it i'm not averse to like a lot of other
drugs we'll take all this [ __ ] but not
that yeah i'll take other [ __ ] but
heroin no i i've never
felt the least bit uh tempted to try
that not at all you can get away with a
lot in moderation you can there is
nothing moderate about heroin it's very
addictive
and i've smoked opium which is a heroin
heroin is a derivative of opium but it's
highly purified opium is a totally
different thing it's like alcohol it's
very controllable a lot milder and it's
a great smoke got that nice [ __ ]
heavy oily [ __ ] and it was legal
where i was smoking it which was egypt
all right and [ __ ] uh but you don't
want to [ __ ] know
heroin no
everything i've heard about heroin it's
like heaven
and you won't want to come out of heaven
even though i have seen some awesome
[ __ ] produced on heroin yeah
most people that i heard of that were on
heroin just made them completely useless
they just slept all the time and did
nothing
it's kind of like that star trek movie
where they go into the [ __ ] like i
said it's fine for them but
what they call that starting that star
trek move the nexus yeah where the
[ __ ] damn the rift from another
dimension you jump in there it's like
going into heaven and you come back out
it's like some [ __ ] like that uh no
don't [ __ ] with that
i mean honestly i kind of feel like uh
even at least in the reenactment which
oh you guys
just correct me if i'm wrong in this i
think this is the documentary who killed
nancy and i watched it was on youtube
pretty sure
the guy that was playing sid vicious
was the same guy from friday from uh
nightmare on elm street part two
i'm pretty sure that was the same dude
the same guy that did the documentary
scream queen if you guys saw that like
on [ __ ] shutter
um
i'm pretty sure that was the same guy i
could i didn't recognize him because he
had totally different hair but i was
looking at his face in his mouth i'm
like that's not and i'm straight too
dude i'm pretty sure like the guy that
played jessie i mean i could be wrong
but it looked exactly like him if it was
now
and the mom like i said she also died
she died of a of an overdose
later on she said
that um
sid and nancy had a suicide pact
not a crazy thing to think that totally
something that sounds like me they would
do well no i'm just saying that does
kind of sound like something they would
do yeah his mom said his mom said
that she found in the pocket of his
iconic leather jacket
uh that she found a handwritten note in
there from him
that said
this is what she said it said or she
produced it i don't know if she wrote it
or you know i mean i'm just saying she
produced this letter she says we had a
death pact i have to keep my half of the
bargain
please bury me next to my baby bury me
in my leather jacket jeans and
motorcycle boots goodbye that's what the
note said
did they do that did they bury him in
his jacket jeans and motorcycle boots uh
they did not they uh they um cremated
him cremated him
uh yeah
now uh apparently his mom or nancy's mom
nancy's mom said that sid had written
her a letter
when he was in the hospital last time
uh that said pretty much the same thing
so maybe that was legit maybe they did
have that thing going on
um the letter that he apparently sent to
nancy's mom
said we always knew that we would go to
the same place when we died
we so much wanted to die together in
each other's arms i cry every time i
think about it i promised my baby that i
would kill myself if anything ever
happened to her and she promised me the
same this is my final commitment to my
love so this is a suicide pact that
they've made up long before anybody got
stabbed
yes okay so they must have been talking
about some other [ __ ] at another time
and then she died so he he decides he
has to go after her
yeah i mean that's very possible that's
possible i don't know if he od on
purpose i think he does but the thing
about it like what i got like i said i'm
not inside the dude's head i wasn't
there
but what i got from
listening to people that knew him or
people that were hanging out with him
around this time period
um they said he seemed pretty [ __ ] up
not just because obviously nancy was
dead but obviously because he might have
he might go to prison he was kind of
worried about that he's got a lot of
strength but he couldn't he legit could
not remember whether he had actually
stabbed her or not yeah and that was
kind of [ __ ] him i kind of buy that i
think maybe he thought that he did kill
her which can you imagine how that would
eat you up right and then he's got this
[ __ ] second-degree murder trial
hanging over his head
and then he's got that heroine sitting
there he's like i'm gonna take a bunch
of that if i don't come back i don't
give a [ __ ] and that might have been i
kind of feel like yeah i mean i feel
like when when people overdose like that
yeah
it's hard to say whether it's like
whether they meant to or not i just kind
of feel like they don't even care i
guess i was going to say i was going to
say
i'm feeling
desperation and indifference he's just
in a desperate situation
yeah he's gonna know
he doesn't care if he lives or dies kind
of a kamikaze thing and he doesn't he
dies
so
but i don't think he's like yeah this
one will kill me i'm gonna die uh that's
probably not i don't think yeah i don't
think they're thinking that much about
it i don't care what they're just kind
of like i don't care what happened
whatever
it's probably what it was because they
probably feel like well if i died i
wouldn't like not to face notice it
anyway
you know that's there you go that sounds
likely to me yeah but apparently he did
write a letter to uh to nancy's mom
saying this essentially the same thing
so maybe that letter that mom because
somebody um
danny rowling said is his mom still
alive no she died in 1996 of a heroin uh
overdose
cause like i said she was an addict as
well
um
so he wanted to be buried next to nancy
uh and obviously nancy's mom was not
having it
uh and also nancy was jewish so she was
buried in a jewish cemetery in
pennsylvania
and uh so sid got cremated
now um
so then
uh sid's mom asks well can we at least
scatter his ashes over her grave and she
again said no
um but according to some sources
jerry only
drove
anne and her sister and a couple of
sid's friends to nancy's gravesite and
they scattered sid's ashes over the
grave like without permission i don't
know if that's true or not but that's
what they said they did
um so yeah that's kind of like like i
said
the fact that this
happened
probably
i mean propelled he was already kind of
legendary at this point but it probably
propelled him even to more like
legendary status to the fact that like
he's still remembered nowadays and like
i said even nowadays i saw
photos from 2000 halloween 2021 of like
famous people dressed up like sid and
nancy for halloween
you know what i'm saying you know
katavatsalan says sid vicious i don't
know who that is there was a wrestler
named that in the 90s
there was a wrestler named that but they
were named after
this guy who was uh more famous than the
wrestler come on man
god he concepts
pecan if you've never heard of the sex
pistols
just go
how many rocks do you have to be living
under here too he doesn't [ __ ] really
like rock music i think i think he's
probably up there listening to that damn
mexican country music
but you go up there and listen to the
[ __ ] uh the
sex people's album never mind the
bullocks this is about this is what i
said i said bollocks bollocks
bollocks with an o same thing with two
o's it's the same [ __ ] thing
[Laughter]
go up there and [ __ ] watch that [ __ ]
it's on youtube you can see one of the
best ones of the best real hard rock
albums of all times the punk rock album
it's good very good
amazing and i wanna oh [ __ ] she's
corrected my english hold on let me go
to the restaurant well you're saying it
wrong i said it exactly the way it says
you're saying it wrong
only tom is correct so uh so yeah so we
were mentioning earlier
about uh and i think dj maniac mentioned
this too
about uh michael mora or rockets red
glare who like i said he's also dead
uh i think he died in 2001
so i don't necessarily want to like
impugn his character or anything but
some people have pointed out there was a
book that came out in 2007 called pretty
vacant a history of punk
and
he kind of thought that maybe
uh michael mora was the one that had
actually killed nancy
uh he was there at the party that night
and he was the one that brought the two
and all like i said sid had taken like
30 of them and it was kind of like out
of it for most of the party according to
most of the people that were there
and uh michael mora also supposedly knew
about all the cash that they kept in the
hotel room they just apparently kept it
in drawers and stuff it's funny because
i was watching this documentary and
legs mcneil said
he's like they insisted on being paid
cash for everything because you know
cash i guess it was easier to like buy
drugs with or whatever so it's like so
a lot of times they would have all this
cash and they'd be like either super
drunk or super on drugs or whatever and
they'd just be walking down the streets
of new york with like cash falling out
of their pockets because they had so
much of it and they just like had you
know because like i mean they were kind
of famous so they kind of like had all
this cash stashed in their hotel room
and
this author is making the point that uh
you know michael mora and a lot of other
people knew that they had a bunch of
cash in there and if they wanted to
steal it
and you know something was happening
where everyone was kind of out of it
then you know there was maybe an
opportunity like i said i'm not saying
that's what happened i'm just saying
it's kind of like a possibility uh and
there have been like people put forward
and some people have said too that there
was another guy that lived in the same
building uh who was also a like a punk
rock guy named neon leon and he actually
lived in the chelsea like right down the
hall from sid and nancy
and allegedly
uh they found some of sid's [ __ ] in his
possession like after
nancy was killed like it or and after
his death like his leather jacket a
couple of his gold records [ __ ] like
that
and he just said oh sid gave me the [ __ ]
like to look after
but
who knows i mean it it's a possibility
that some people that knew about the
[ __ ] were like coming in there stealing
[ __ ] because they knew that they were
out of it so i don't know
and uh some people have said to you that
michael mora aka rockets reglair
uh had told some of his friends yeah i
totally stabbed nancy
but he wouldn't like say that publicly
allegedly
so
no i'm just saying sounds like somebody
else trying to write themselves into it
well some people have said yeah he did
tell people that he'd stabbed nancy but
a couple of his friends said well he
made stuff up for attention sometimes
too so we don't really know if that's
true or not
uh they said he was there that night and
he did know that they kept a lot of cash
in their hotel room so it's possible
sure but
nobody knows and like i said he died in
2001. he can't defend himself so like i
said but i'm just saying that like some
people have put that forward and that's
why that's why i'm saying that
if i was on the jury i don't think that
there's any way there's too much
reasonable doubt there's just too many
other
possibilities
yes sid could have stabbed her sure they
kind of did it together
nancy could have stabbed herself
somebody else could have stabbed her
there's a lot of things that could have
been good and we will never know what
happened because we weren't there
um whatever it was it wasn't murder and
most of the people are dead and yeah
like i said even if he did stab her it
wasn't murder it wasn't murder because
i'm sure he didn't mean to kill her
the the evidence demonstrates that they
both tried to hide it whatever it was
it's not she didn't go running for help
or like i said they thought that it
wasn't a big deal yeah yeah i mean
clearly she thought it wasn't a big deal
she's like hey i'm just gonna go in the
bathroom for a second and then she just
laid down and then like a couple hours
later she was dead she just like bled
out so
if she thought she was in any danger you
would think that she would have
gone for help but she did not and no one
else did either
so whoever did it nobody took it
entirely seriously or everyone was so
[ __ ] up they didn't know what was
going on in most states the legal
definition of murder is an intentional
homicide that's what i'm saying and this
is an intentional i'm sure this is not
interesting you're gonna stab somebody
with an intentional homicide that means
you're going to sit there and you're
going to work them over with that blade
until they're dead
this whole thing you stab them once and
then you sit around for three or four
hours and then talk about that that no
no no no
no
no but it wasn't a murder
negligent homicide
i could see that because like i said she
was obviously wounded right and after a
while he's like oh well he didn't get
her help he should have gone free yeah
right
they it was something they did together
it was just their it was on both of them
they did that [ __ ] together
and when she started to go down he
didn't go get her help that's where he
that's where he [ __ ] up yeah so i
could see him
i could see him being called to account
for that yeah that's what i would give
him if i was on a jury
but
and i don't think there was any malice
no intended
bridges negligence they were so messed
up the two of them he killed it was just
a sad [ __ ] he killed her by lack of
action
yeah yeah i could see that
2006 sid vicious and the sex pistols
inducted into the rock and roll hall of
fame
and
most punk rock thing ever they didn't
show up because they're like [ __ ] that
yeah
because why would you i mean that's kind
of like the whole thing
uh i found this actually i thought this
was kind of interesting steve severin of
susan the banshees because like i said
sid vicious play drums for them in their
first uh live gig
steve said uh that he actually really
likes it this is like uh
steve severn from the banshee yeah yeah
he says before he got deeply into drugs
he was one of the funniest guys he had a
brilliant sense of humor goofy sweet and
very cute that's what he called him and
like i said most of the people that knew
him
said that before he was like a druggie
he was actually a lovely lovely person
like he was very shy he's very
soft-spoken
just a nice guy
super funny
um you know drugs kind of change your
brain kind of [ __ ] him up and you know
so he'd have been all right though i
would have given that [ __ ] 18 months
for negligent homicide that's what i
would have done with him
and then he straightened him out and
then yeah give him 18. he might have
turned out okay yeah if he'd gotten a
little bit of prison time or gone into a
detox or something i'd given him 18
months for negligent homicide and give
him about three years probation
see if he could handle that
and then he probably would have [ __ ]
gone out and [ __ ] done some cool [ __ ]
in the music industry
that's that's what i would have done
with it murder no
no
yeah i'm not i'm not buying it like i
said
yeah he didn't need to kill her no
i mean and she didn't think that he
meant to kill her she wasn't running out
of there screaming for help like i said
it wasn't a healthy relationship i'm not
saying that it was [ __ ] up they were
just [ __ ] up but [ __ ] you [ __ ] i want
to keep things out oh [ __ ] oh no man you
got me it's just like that you go what
are we gonna do now that's okay i'll be
all right
yeah i'll walk it off yeah i'll walk it
off there's a little cut it'll be okay
you want some heroin yeah yeah sounds
good
that's probably honestly that's probably
exactly what yeah you can't really see
that i can see that read too much into
it they were they were simple people but
they were not smart they were young
dummies
yeah like i said they were i mean you're
talking about 19 20 21 year old kids
who were completely [ __ ] up and had no
idea what was going on i would not have
and had a history of like smacking each
other around it was like a bdsm type
relationship but they were in love with
each other
peas and a pod
and yeah she was a [ __ ] but he was
[ __ ] nuts you know so but and i
wouldn't have fried him for that no way
no no way no
i mean he took it hard he felt guilty he
killed himself i you know i just i in a
way i think that that cause it's kind of
a testament the fact that he was
innocent that's what i was going to say
is that if dude who killed her and
didn't give a [ __ ] would have [ __ ]
just walked away from her like nothing
yeah he's like yeah whatever he killed
that [ __ ] yeah but the fact that he
felt so yeah [ __ ] up about it right
and the fact that he might not have even
stabbed her but the fact that maybe he
did
like haunted him yeah she could have
done it he could have done it they did
that [ __ ] together yeah
so i mean that kind of shows you that at
his heart he was a good person because
he did he seemed to feel really bad
about it yeah i think it was he was a
good little dude he just
got wrapped up he didn't have much of a
connection
well he was having a good time being a
punk rock star and [ __ ] one thing led
to another getting high a lot and
[ __ ]
and then he's retired what am i going to
do now and you know
well well yeah a lot of things took
place like the sex pistols broke up yeah
um which even though he just kind of
stood around and looked pretty yeah um
he was still in nature i think that was
giving him some purpose in life and then
when that was gone he was kind of like
not really sure
what was happening and then like you
know there was other [ __ ] going on in
his life and i kind of feel like he was
going under go and throw like a lot of
[ __ ]
um another quote that i found too was
from john lyden because like you said uh
john lyon felt really bad about it yeah
he says i'm sorry god for the day i
brought sid into the band yeah he felt
so isolated poor old sid
because he wasn't the sharpest knife on
the block yeah the best aspect of his
character which was his humor just
vanished the day he joined the pistols
that's what he said so yeah
everyone and honestly
john lyden like i said he can kind of be
he's
can be a dick for real he's kind of a
cool dick though
but he really does seem to feel bad he
still seems to feel bad about what
happened to sid john is not a dumb dude
and a great storyteller and uh he is
well he's egotistical but he has a right
to be egotistical he made his mark on uh
music history
uh he wasn't in an important phase
in uh
uh anglo-american culture english
english actually world culture even in
[ __ ] brazil people knew when i was
growing up there people [ __ ]
listen to the sex pistols right along
with iron maiden and [ __ ] american
bands too you know so no no no
he he
john is not of just full of hot air
john [ __ ] made his mark
um i mean the sex pistol is one of the
most influential bands of all time right
i don't think anyone would argue with
you at least in white culture i think a
lot of black people don't know who they
are but in white culture we you know
yeah i mean you know but the the you
know there he was
it was a great band and it was it was a
couple of great albums that they made
uh but actually musically come on let's
be honest
no man pill was better
pill was better in a lot of ways it
wasn't
it wasn't as subversive
as this it was more innovative though it
was a lot more innovative it's a lot
more free in terms of expression
although he will say that he's a great
performer i saw i saw him you know open
up with the sex pit with the with the
[ __ ] um uh the sugar cubes and the
new order it was he put on a great show
so i'm at pine up theater he's great
um
but getting back to him
feeling bad about
sid there's nothing [ __ ] john could
have done
it went down the way that it it did well
like i said it's just kind of like
i mean it's just the same thing as like
nowadays like you know the members of
new order
still feel bad about ian curtis
committing suicide even though obviously
there's nothing they could have done
they were all kids at the time
but
you only can do what you can do
but honestly the fact that they still
feel bad about it yeah i mean i was like
that's good that means you're like a
good person yeah because
you still feel bad you still like wish
you could have done something about it
you still wish you could have helped
them even though realistically you maybe
you couldn't have
but in a lot of ways you probably
couldn't have but
the fact that you feel bad about it i
mean that at least you have like some
[ __ ]
empathy yeah uh you know so so there's
that
um
tammy says
uh they're talking about
showing what it is like uh like to lose
someone very close to you
and cheryl said i almost did husband had
cancer a few years ago he made it
that show hits a little close to home oh
they're talking about like a show and
tammy says i had a son die 20 years ago
at age 11. damn and then his dad died
six years later so i know what you mean
holy [ __ ] tammy i didn't know that about
i'm sorry
um
and then yeah she said for a long time
it was just me my daughter and our dog
i know that's terrible yeah i mean holy
[ __ ]
um
[Music]
yeah stardog 78 is talking about gary
oldman yeah um
the movie sit in nancy even though it
does kind of like romanticize it and it
does kind of show like one possible
scenario of what maybe happened which
who knows what happened because no one
was there
uh but that is still a great film
even though like i said hilariously even
though gary oldman is great in it he
[ __ ] hated
uh punk and i think he [ __ ] hated
that movie not really it's ridiculous
which is crazy because he's because he's
fantastic yeah it's good uh he even
looks a lot like sid like
facially like his whole like uh
mannerisms and everything he really did
uh he really did a good job yeah now
just set striker set the record straight
i think sid did stab nancy i did well
like i said i don't know i think he
probably did but i don't think it was
meant in the way that
i don't think he i don't think he meant
it in the way that that would happen
between [ __ ] civilians
you gotta understand the [ __ ] punk
rock culture and these five
[ __ ] were just not
normal people there's different cultures
involved
he stabbed her i think but he don't
think he meant to if you understand he's
under the influence
and and
i think it was more theatrics than
anything else and then once he realized
oh [ __ ]
stabbing somebody's a reality
he didn't do it anymore it's kind of
like i kind of feel like sid was yeah
not only because he was kind of dumb but
also because he was kind of on a lot of
drugs he was almost kind of like
childlike yeah yeah
so i don't know if he actually grasped
the graviton no i don't think he
realized it no oh i think he stabbed her
and i think they immediately both
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] and then they covered it
up
that's what that's what i see that
that's what i really think like i said
there's other possibilities but i mean
that's probably the most likely most
likely is that you gotta say that
they're like oh [ __ ] don't wanna get in
trouble
and then they both because that's the
first thing you would think of yeah in
that situation yeah and then they were
both they both covered it up i think and
then she didn't make it and
then he killed himself
not by by just taking too many goddamn
drugs
he felt bad about it now
he may have not have remembered exactly
what happened but i think that's
probably what happened
and maybe that's what he suspected had
happened
he may have had a couple different
versions of what had happened in his
head
well as i said i'm sure he probably
didn't remember at all
i didn't remember real clearly what
happened but that's probably what
actually happened
if you had it on camera
and if you had it on camera you probably
would have kind of forgiven him because
they were probably [ __ ] super high
and
as soon as it happened like oh [ __ ]
sorry
oh man well here here put this you know
i mean then if i remember correctly it
was probably something like that in the
movie sit in nancy yeah they kind of had
i don't remember if they um i haven't
seen the movie in a long time i remember
it being really i have to like re i
should have rewatched it for this now
that i'm thinking about it but i haven't
seen a long time but i
don't remember if they
talked about that they'd had a party
that there were other people like in and
out of the apartment all night there are
people there until like five or six a.m
just going in and out
um so i don't know if they address that
in the movie but i do remember in the
movie
that they made it
um
that nancy almost
provoked him into it like yeah [ __ ]
like kill me kill me yeah yeah do it
like i kind of said it's kind of like
that yeah um which like i said i don't
know if that's what happened but that's
what they portrayed in the movie so i
don't know the movie's kind of like
fictionalized knowing the way that they
were in punk rock culture they were
probably both talking [ __ ] she's
slapping him and they're slapping each
other like that a little bit and it's
just roughing each other up and it's
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] like that and then
she goes ow you got me yeah i mean she's
like oh really oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh sorry
here here let's play it patch it up
it'll be all right yeah it'd be this
stupid [ __ ] like that stupid [ __ ] yeah
like i said i don't know i wasn't mad i
don't think they were really thinking
[ __ ] through at that point
it probably was not not thinking [ __ ]
through definitely wasn't trying to kill
her he would continue to stab her
it was uh
heat of the moment
minor argument i don't even think i way
i'm picturing it knowing the way those
[ __ ] were
[ __ ] like that would happen within a
minor argument not a major argument they
weren't even [ __ ] probably serious
yeah it was funny dumb [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
yeah
like you said like your friend rich like
over arguing over the remote control my
friend blew his head off arguing over
the [ __ ] volume of the television i
showed you a picture of his same
generation which like i said you're
[ __ ] the volume of the television i
can see that happening
watching the movie [ __ ] excalibur and
he was talking about me he says he was
talking about me and my friend
eric who would just come out of the army
he was ex-army too he was telling the
girl y'all don't know you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing you don't
know honor you don't know he was telling
her she didn't know anything about otter
two junkies fighting over otter that
sounds like some [ __ ] you would say
though yeah
over the
volume of television he gets a 38
special comes out of the [ __ ] closet
with his [ __ ] dress green tops on
from his army dress green's top with a
[ __ ] 38 special revolver in his hand
he goes [ __ ] you i'm [ __ ] sick of you
i'm out of here and he pulls in a boom
and blows his [ __ ] head off right in
front of her
and he was 52 and she was about 25.
i mean
she was [ __ ] hot and he's he was a
hot dude
over the volume of a [ __ ] television
set well i'm sure she didn't hold it
against him she was like it was an
accident he didn't mean it
that's what he probably didn't yeah he
didn't he was just well the thing about
it it's like whenever they there's a
fight like that and everybody kind of
said oh he blew his head off over like
the volume of television it's never just
about that well there's always like
other there was exacerbated
circumstances and he's probably mad
about lots of other things yeah but that
was just like the one thing that like
tipped him started to get kind of
ostracized from the scene because he was
showing up [ __ ] seething and
breathing
like that doing the [ __ ] like sometimes
i do about doing this he was doing that
all the time but it was because he was
constantly [ __ ]
on a fifth of [ __ ] scotch
with a whole bunch of [ __ ] cocaine
and heroin
so he was constantly in this weird
state of
semi
i can't imagine
at that age at that age because i'm yeah
i'll be 50 this year in september
and i'm just kind of like man we go out
drinking one night i'd say i need like
two days to recover from that oh yeah no
it's like the next i don't
i don't feel terrible terrible i just
feel really really really really tired i
just feel really tired
even if i get sleep i'm still tired he
would sleep you know
and and recover
he would be in heroin heaven with these
little hotties and [ __ ] get up and go
to he worked in the building that he
lived in so he didn't have like a normal
nine-to-five job he only had to work
when a tenant needed him
so he had a sweet job he didn't pay any
rent he stayed there for free and then
they gave him so he was like an
apartment manager he's an apartment
manager so he stayed there for free and
they gave him a couple grand a month to
just keep the [ __ ] apartment running
nice and um
yeah and he was just ex-military guy and
picked up a bad [ __ ] hat heroin habit
um but he was a good here's the weird
thing that's why i'm kind of i'm kind of
i would never do that [ __ ] you know i
mean it's a bad drug uh but i'm kind of
understanding of these dudes
good people in these days got
wrapped up in that drug yeah you know it
was sad too yeah and they were very
talented because yeah a lot of them they
were bad people they were bad people
they were all trapped in this damn web
of a drug that was out there that was
just working them over
and um
it was the weirdest thing because uh
they were very charismatic the ones that
i knew
yeah good looking girls good looking
guys and they just
but they the problem was they would
[ __ ] just sleep sleep and sleep like
[ __ ] vampires which kind of
lent itself to the gothic scene
eventually this [ __ ] vampiric thing
of just [ __ ] sleeping and being
pretty
sleep and be pretty yeah i wish i could
live like that yeah and there was always
[ __ ] pretty girls just [ __ ]
injecting this [ __ ] into them and
sleeping you know and and older guys in
their 50s who
were in still good shape just with these
girls in their 20s and just injecting
this [ __ ] into them
um
kind of a
interesting lifestyle but definitely not
not healthy they were like the living
dead
yeah like i said there's a reason that
heroin addicts hang out with other
junkies yeah because like people that
aren't in that [ __ ] aren't going to hang
out so it's like what i want to hang out
with you while you sleep for [ __ ]
eight hours nothing but you have
beautiful conversations about music and
[ __ ] culture
you know at least rich he's just real
real cultured you know you're not
talking about a scumbag
so it wasn't like your typical
like punk rock junkie or anything you
know what i mean
and some people did actually like
function yeah on the stuff right kinda
like a functional alcoholic
yeah so some people did like i said you
know i i bring up nick cable up because
he's kind of like the you know i'm a big
fan of his and he was like known as like
a big heroin addict but
he did manage to make
awesome albums and write novels and [ __ ]
on that stuff so he wasn't just like
useless all the time right it wasn't
like trainspotting just everybody's
laying around letting their babies
suffocate yeah just just i think half of
them were like that it seemed like i
mean just like everything else it kind
of depends on the person i guess i mean
he i'm sure uh you know he did his fair
share of like sleeping and laying around
but
he seemed to have
uh
sort of winnowed that into
productivity
where i feel like heroin in particular
seems uh
counterproductive yeah if you're trying
to like you know trying to do something
with your life because it does kind of
just make you be like yeah and then just
like lay around i go over to rich's
[ __ ] apartment
[ __ ] knock on the door and [ __ ] i
hear a little [ __ ] s
soleil with his girlfriend's name at
that time
and i could hear her [ __ ] mumbling a
little bit i'm going to open up the door
and she's like come in i said open the
door she go come in and we'd fight over
if i could open the door and come in i
didn't want to open the door she would
just say come in and i [ __ ] open up
the door and they'd be sleeping on the
couch and he'd be passed out and she'd
be there and they'd be all [ __ ] goth
out she's just gorgeous
kind of [ __ ] gotcha you know and
i'm going get this [ __ ] [ __ ] up get him
up let's go to the [ __ ] axis you know
the club's at that and he's like she's
like wake up wake up she's just smacking
him see i don't wake up this is why i'm
not super this is why i don't hang out
with heroin addicts he's like dude
we got we got [ __ ] to do yeah you can't
just be like laying around on the couch
all day yeah let's go yeah
yeah i'm very much a let's get up and do
some [ __ ] yeah kind of person and we
finally get him up and [ __ ] you know
i can't lay around all day and honestly
like i can't even sleep [ __ ] i can't
even sleep
past i woke up at quarter to six this
morning
and i just i was like well i could get
up right now but it's still dark so that
would be weird so i said well maybe i'll
just lay here and wait till the sun
comes up and then i'll get out yeah so
as soon as the sun came up at like a
quarter to seven i got up
[Laughter]
you would like do you think it's funny
you didn't think it was funny they were
sexy too she you wanna have sex with us
no i can't have sex so let's go
you all have it bathed in a couple days
like i smell it once you get this [ __ ]
up
she's like she's like i'll change my
dress and this is yeah you go ahead
get in the goddamn shower and [ __ ]
man there's another time i was over
there
and i go in the refrigerator and i'm
[ __ ] pull up pouring a drink he had
the [ __ ] scotch in the refrigerator
and porn drink went to go get some ice
cubes i'll open up a freezer and the
[ __ ] cat is in the freezer frozen
that was like there were some horror
movies like yeah
[ __ ] like
the cats in the freezer [ __ ] frozen
rock solid and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
the cat doing in the freezer oh yeah
the cat died
the cat died we put him in the freezer
so what's he doing in the [ __ ]
freezer
well we couldn't bury him it's frozen
outside because it was winter
and
i was like it made sense at the time
yeah so what's he doing in the freezer
well we couldn't throw him out it's the
cat we gotta bury him
so it kind of made sense when i heard it
like yeah i guess so we couldn't throw
him outside still you know we couldn't
throw him outside in the garbage
so we got to bury him and we gotta wait
until the [ __ ] ground thaws
and i was like but he's in the [ __ ]
freezer
you know and he's like he's okay he's
sitting on the couch before that he's
just in the freezer now it just kind of
made junky sense i'm like yeah oh i got
chucky's well he was alive on the couch
and what different you know he was what
difference does he make if he's in the
couch in a freezer you know i guess you
know i'm like okay all right
yeah
they're not worried about it no really
it's [ __ ] funny you liked it this is
[ __ ] are funny
i don't know so you you bringing that up
reminded me yeah of going to
lollapalooza in atlanta
in the early 90s
and i was staying
at the apartment of my
friend's
boyfriend
who i didn't know
and the boyfriend lived with a whole
bunch of roommates so it was a bunch of
like 20ish year old dudes yeah and they
were all filthy yeah so like i was
afraid to go to the bathroom
their
kitchen was filled with dirty dishes
that had maggots on them oh
um i was just kind of like what please
kill me like i drove up to atlanta or
actually i took i took a
i took a greyhound to atlanta actually
because i didn't have a car at the time
so i took a greyhound i thought i was
going to be staying at my friend's house
which she actually she was staying with
her dad i think and he had like a really
nice house in atlanta or outside of
atlanta
i thought we were gonna be staying there
but of course uh her boyfriend at the
time she's like no we're gonna be
staying with the boyfriend like after
the show and i was just kind of like
great i don't know any of these people
so i was just like okay fantastic so i
end up in this [ __ ] room and with all
these stinky dudes with their maggoty
dishes
and their gross ass bathroom and i'm
just like jesus [ __ ] christ kill me
now that apartment
all right with this [ __ ] here
i'm gonna show you a picture of him
again
this [ __ ] here all right
this [ __ ] here and his
girlfriend
that apartment smelled nothing
nothing but like patchouli
it was just [ __ ] patchouli you could
smell patchouli down the [ __ ]
down i do like that smell yeah i like it
[ __ ] the fact that those
[ __ ]
would sit up in the [ __ ] same spot
for two or three days and not take a
damn shower they're just like zonked out
patchouli
so we're done we're done with this show
yeah we've been going almost five hours
yeah it's almost five hours we gotta get
out of here i mean we still got a strong
following listening to us though really
yeah i'm starving yeah i'll make some to
eat i think i've had one sandwich today
that's yeah
john's going i actually thought of that
if my cat died in the winter what to do
well [ __ ] john put the cat in the
freezer i mean like that's weird yeah i
but i get it i didn't even have a cat in
a bag
it was just sitting on a rack
man hearing about oh that bumps me out
so much yeah he feels like i said if you
guys weren't here at the beginning
he felt it was disrespectful put the cat
in a plastic bag so he just had the cat
sitting up there on the road i get that
yeah i get that yeah okay i mean
honestly like you guys know
you know
i get it i don't that that would be like
putting a person yeah
she had the cat just i can kind of curl
that curled up in the foot on the top
rack of the freezer
whoa what's the cat doing in there
tammy says tammy says i had to put my
little dog in our spare freezer because
he died on a saturday and i was going to
have him cremated and they were closed
until monday yeah so like i said it's
not that weird i mean yeah if you just
came over to somebody's house i'm
getting iced next if you just came over
to somebody's house but if you explained
it i mean
yeah i'd be shocked but if you explained
it to me i'd be like oh okay i get it i
get it it's not that weird yeah
um you know it's
like what's he doing here well he was on
the couch
he was on the couch when he died he's
been a cow on the couch when he he's
alive he you know [ __ ] what
difference does he make he's in the
couch or in the [ __ ] freezer he's
been all over the house so
it made sense in their their that's what
i'm saying like yeah it's kind of like
oh my god like at first but if you think
about it for a second right it was a
cat's house not really that weird right
that's not really that weird it's not
like you like murdered people and like
have their arms and legs in the freezer
no it's it's a cat you know yeah he's
just chilling in the freezer
that makes me sad like i said
all right jenny i'm gonna go ahead and
start with somebody what you gonna make
i'm gonna get down there and go look
yeah let's see what i got we don't know
we don't we don't know what's happening
i got roast beef cooked already uh i can
do uh ramen
ramen's good
roast beef is good sandwich
well her food sandwich is easiest
yeah i mean we had that earlier uh roast
beef with uh
mashed potatoes gravy
yeah oh yeah if i have if i have the uh
the mashed potatoes still i mean if we
do then we can have that but if not then
sandwiches
or ramen is good too okay
all right so uh thank you guys for
hanging out holy crap i can't believe
we've been going for five hours but i
kind of figured it would because i'm
this is actually a very interesting
topic for me
um
captain blair says i should have put a
sex pistols poster in buddy's cask at
his funeral he was my neighbor and a
detective on the sid and nancy case
and he thought sid did it i mean
i don't know if sid did it or not if he
did i don't think he meant
i don't think he meant it i think they
were just kind of like so [ __ ] up they
didn't know what was going on but you
know what i mean like i said i'm not in
the jury no one was there so we're never
gonna know everyone's dead that's
involved so
it's it's kind of sad but yeah uh so
thanks for everybody for hanging out
with us this wednesday evening we'll be
back on friday for our side track show
so hopefully you guys can um come and
hang out with us for that so thanks for
coming by thanks everybody for super
chats and we will see you guys on friday
evening
bye
stop it polk